morning everyone if you please rise and
Allegiance I pledge aliance to the flag
of the United States of America and to
the repblic for which it stands one one
nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for
all
thank you with that I'm going to open
the public hearing on House Bill 1050
bill
for
thank you Mr chair sorry for the uh
delay over the summer um I met a New
Hampshire mom who lost her only son to
gun
suicide um she's here today and you're
going to have the opportunity to meet
her and you'll have the opportunity to
hear her story
too what I learned from our
conversations over the last few months
are are three things devastating impact
that a tragedy like this can have on the
people who are left
behind
the finality of an attempted suicide by
firearm which has a 90% success rate and
the fact that there are small but
significant changes we can make to our
laws to help people who are at risk for
suicide as well as their
families there are many people who
experience suicidal thoughts for some
the idea that they can buy a firearm is
troubling but at times the temptation to
do so can be
overwhelming they may have no History of
Violence or self harm or they may have
already tried to they may be prone to
severe
deppression
they may suffer from severe bipolar
disorder many of them may have never
been treated for mental illness they may
be fine now but they know the UPS the
Downs the mood swings and the
overwhelming urge to do themselves harm
back they also know that having a
firearm in their lives will put them at
risk for taking their own
life in most parts of the country
including New Hampshire
there's no ability to voluntarily add
yourself to the federal background check
system so you can't purchase a
firearm what this bill would do is
change that by establishing a voluntary
Firearms do not sell list for people who
voluntarily wish to wave their right to
buy
firearms the bill authorizes the
department of safety to create
administrative processes needed to
establish and manage this list it also
establishes ground rules for handling
these applications s for example once an
application is submitted the department
of safety will have one business day to
transmit this information to the
systems used by law enforcement agencies
to identify people who purchase
firearms once the person is on the list
and in the system they won't be able to
pass a background check for any type of
firearm in effect they become a
prohibited person should a Firearms
dealer sell a weapon to one of them
anyway they would risk the same penalty
they would for selling a gun to any
other type of prohibited
person meanwhile a listed person who
attempts to buy a firearm would also be
subject to a penalty but in this
particular Bill uh We've written that as
a violation level penalty rather than a
misdemeanor to class B felony penalty
that provide to other people who provide
false
information while my preferences Prime
sponsor would have been to have no
penalty and to avoid the risk of further
harming a person who may already be in
crisis one of the first states to pass a
law like this learned uh the hard way
that unless the offense actually carries
a penalty it it can't be entered into
the next system uh the state of
Washington actually had to amend their
bill later on so they could actually add
people into the system so for this
reason the bill has the lowest penalty
available to us under our
law also part of the bill is a provision
that allows a listed person to apply for
removal from the list at any time after
having been on it for 60 days once the
application for removal is received the
department of safety would have a
maximum of 21 days to remove them from
any federal or state firearms background
check database or file there are also
safeguards in the bill that protect the
privacy of anyone who appears on the
list who applies for the list and who is
removed from the
list what this legislation
also attempts to do is to strike a
balance between authorizing the
department of safety to manage the list
and having us in the legislature
micromanage them however if you believe
that there are key parts of the process
that need to be changed or that need to
be spelled out more clearly uh I would
ask for your help uh in doing
that to date three other states uh Utah
Virginia and Washington State have
passed legislation like this in Utah the
bill had the full support of the gun
community
in Washington state after some glitches
with the initial signup process uh they
found it was helpful to amend the law to
authorize Healthcare Providers to submit
the necessary paperwork with the patient
authorization now this is not part of
the bill that's before us today uh but I
do want to make you aware that the
sponsors of the bill told me that this
change did result in a substantial
uptick uh in signups so it's something
we could
consider one piece of information I'll
leave you with is a survey conducted of
people at RIS for suicide when asked if
they would sign up for a list like this
46% of them said they
would the bottom line is with this bill
nobody's guns are taken away if a person
decides to voluntarily give up their
right to purchase a firearm there is a
process for them to get that right back
if they decide that's what they
want you may ask why do we need a bill
like this when people can simply decide
not to buy a
gun let me read you part of an email I
got from a doctor who supports the bill
and survived a suicide attempt that
didn't involve a firearm a few years
ago he writes by limiting access to high
lethality means of suicide we can
provide people like me who struggle with
Suicidal Thoughts with a tool to protect
themselves in the event of foreseeable
Mental Health
crisis as a person who has previously
attempted suicide I know that I am
dramatically at increased lifetime risk
for another suicide
attempt so what we have here is people
in this situation they know themselves
and they know their vulnerabilities and
they know them far better than we do
they know there are times when they may
not have total control over their
emotions and their actions when it comes
to doing themselves
harm by taking this simple step we can
take the quickest the deadliest in our
state the most common form of suicide
off the table for people who simply go
the extra step of asking us to take it
off the
table and with that I'll take any
questions the committee has on the
bill thank you representative I I see
the other states have done it what what
I'm curious about is the interaction
with the federal laws do the federal
laws allow this that the um FBI has
allowed these states to put these names
in and withdraw them with no problems
they do and have you tracked the success
as far as the number of people who have
signed up for this in those various
States yeah I I think one of the issues
uh I believe in Washington DC was that
initially as anytime there's a change in
the law it can be difficult getting the
word out to the right people um so one
of the things that that they did to
actually uh uh make more people aware of
it was a campaign to actually make more
physicians in the state aware of it and
one of the things that they did to
supplement that was they actually
created a process that allows a
physician to have that conversation with
a patient get their authorization so
we're talking about a wet signature type
of an authorization and then transmit
the paperwork uh to the people in the
state who in in in in Washington state
who then send it on to the federal
government so that is not in this bill
um it's something that could be in the
bill if we thought it was a good idea
but I think the the most important thing
right now is just to get this process
underway and to get something started
and if we decide uh perhaps there are
better ways to do it or there are ways
we can supplement it to make it more
effective those are things that we can
consider down the
road thank you I noticed that there's a
a significant fiscal note what are your
thoughts on that as far as um what's
been given to us I I saw that too and
and you know having been a member on
this committee and having seen fiscal
notes several times um I I think one of
the reasons why why we we I wanted to
make sure we gave the department of
safety wide latitude is because I know
that um they're not a wash in cash no
New Hampshire Department is um given the
number of people who might be on a list
like this uh it might be something uh
that could be managed it could be
managed with a database that needs to be
set up it could be managed with an
existing database it could be managed
with a spreadsheet um there are a bunch
of different ways to manage it I'm a
little puzzled at the need to add two
employees to manage to manage the
process uh uh I I I think part of Again
part of the reason for giving them the
flexibility is uh so we don't have to
design something that's over overly
elaborate we can design something that
meets the need hopefully with the
Personnel that the department of safety
already has but I'm I'm sure we'll hear
from them on that too thank you
committee representative um excuse me
read thank you Mr chairman a couple qu
two two questions if I may um I'm sorry
could you speak into your mic so um the
when once somebody puts themselves on on
the list um how difficult is it to get
your name off of after the 60 days or
whatever and do people actually go back
and take their names off um and um how
you know that's three okay then that's
it thank you very very from what I've
heard and I've and I actually had
conversations with the Washington
sponsor and uh from what I understand
very few people take themselves off the
list once they're on it but I think it's
very important that we have a process in
place for people who want to do that so
uh the way that the bill envisions that
process working is there would be a
separate application uh that would be
available from the Department of Safety
to remove yourself from the list uh and
the department of safety would have 21
days once that's submitted to make that
happen um the the thing I think that we
try we're we try to avoid is in a lot of
situations you in these situations we're
talking about people who know they're
prone to severe depression they know
they're prone to bipolar epod episodes
so these are people who a lot of the
time I mean they're just as functional
as we are I mean there there's no issue
um but then they can hit one of those
points and and the issue is when they
hit one of those points um one of the
things that that they want in
participating in you know in in on a
list like this is they want to be able
to take their access to purchasing a
firearm off the table you know their
ability to do themselves harm by the by
basically the most lethal means
available so there are processes um uh
that are you know that in the bill that
are in the bill that uh speak to that
there are also things in the bill that
speak to the Privacy uh the Privacy
rights of the people who are actually on
the list and and one of the things I
just wanted to make clear to everybody
too is that if you're if you're actually
list you know get on the list for this
reason
um a nobody at a gun store would
actually know why you're a prohibited
person they wouldn't know that you
voluntarily uh they wouldn't they
wouldn't know the difference between uh
somebody who's on this list and let's
say somebody who is a convicted felon
you're both prohibited people and that's
the way it works and because this is a
federal list this would pertain to other
states as well not just New Hampshire so
once you were listed you would not only
be listed in New Hampshire you would be
listed
federally follow-up question okay um
representative
Pratt has a lot of questions I have I'm
just going to ask a couple um the cost
of 354,000 for three years uh we talked
about you talked about a simple
spreadsheet uh this is an awesome
responsibility that the government and
the gun owners are taking over a
responsibility that the person is not
responsible for themselves so uh what is
the liability if an error is made in
this simple spreadsheet if a person buys
a gun that's not supposed to buy a gun
the liability of a person who buys a gun
that wasn't on the list because of an
error oh who's who's on who's on the
list so there is for the person who for
the person who's listed who tries to buy
a gun it's a violation level penalty so
there is a penalty we have to have that
or NYX won't actually let us list it in
the in the system for the dealer who who
would actually if so for instance if a
dealer sees that this is a prohibited
person and sells the gun gun anyway the
same penalties would apply to the
Firearms dealer as if they would have
sold a felon a firearm so there's and
and again the dealer has no way of
knowing so that and I I I think that's
the way we want our lot of work anyway
followup J just one quick followup uh
that's not exactly what I meant so say
an error is made on creating this list
somehow the person isn't on the list the
gun own sells them the gun and the
person uses the gun um in the wrong way
now who is responsible for that there's
got to be a liability if you're going to
keep a list so you're saying if a person
applies to be on the list and then
somehow they're not put on the list I
mean we're talking simple spreadsheets
to the extreme of 354,000 for three
years so you're talking two different
ranges of list here if this list isn't
done correctly who is liable if somebody
buys a gun and they thought they were on
a
list it's a good question I mean there
you know I think one of the things that
you try to do when you establish a
process like this is to you know you you
try to create and and I think this is
one of the things where it'll be
important to actually get some feedback
on realistically how quickly we can make
some of these things happen but once we
actually agree to that those are
parameters that we really do need to
stick with uh because these are people
you know who are prone to incidents like
this so I mean I it's a little bit of a
kind of a a wh if question is this a
possibility you know that that there
could be some liability if the list
somehow is mismanaged um I I guess Poss
posibly but that's that's really all I
representative so not quite a question
but maybe a clarification for the bill
and I I know this is going to sound cold
and hard but I I just dealt with this in
another bill that um a relative of mine
was put on a a list that's on a
website uh and I asked she actually
passed and I asked asked for them to be
removed from the list and there was no
way for them to remove her from the list
which which list so this is for the EMS
board disciplinary list that comes up on
a
website and her name is going to stay
there forever but I have a bill coming
back to this committee that will allow
the director to remove deceased people
from a list right she can't come back
for a job so I would think that you
might want to put a provision in here
so the family could go remove them if
they so desired but right now there it's
on
indefinitely right so even if that
person passes away from old
age they can't remove that name from the
list it has to stay in the spreadsheet
forever and and I would I wouldn't think
that would be the way but I just
experience it it doesn't say they can
take them off they can't take them off
and I think what you're saying is that
there's a it's it's important to have a
process for removing people from you
know from a list like this I would agree
even not the person themselves the
family member or or something else that
wants that name removed out of
documentation for whatever reason you
mean if the person is no longer with us
right yeah okay I I guess I guess I can
understand that the for clarification
representative if if this is to be
handled the way that normally people um
who are submitted for prohibited persons
the state should not be maintaining any
list it should be uploaded to the Nick
system and then wiped from the state
would be the optimal way because I think
we don't want the state maintaining list
of people they submit it to NX it's in
there once it's in there it's not the
state's responsibility anymore is that
the way you understand it or do you
understand it to be that dos would keep
a list of
people I I think that's I think for the
purpose of making sure that people I
mean you know part of it is the the
request the request to get off the list
needs to be managed um at the state
level and to do that the state actually
probably needs to know who's on the list
and maybe they can do that once once
actually you know kind of thinking it
through um they would probably be able
to just get that information from Nick
you know just do a download who are all
the people who are currently listed for
this particular reason so I I I don't
think we really have an
issue representative Stone thank you
chairman Roy and thank you for taking my
question can you you tell me under what
current federal law guarantees they'd
have to honor a state's request to
remove somebody upon request from the
next database under what federal law I
can't I I can't tell you I don't have my
Federal Register in front of me are you
aware that uh Nicks is solely the
responsibility of the federal
government yes and you're also aware
that the state uh basically has to make
a request they can't
employ also aware that there are people
who are are are listed and and Dlisted
um we do that for protective orders and
things of that nature um this is
something that um we have experience
with uh as a state it's something that
the folks who run the Nick system have
experience with as well um and I I don't
think it's a showstopper in this
case she no further questions thank you
for your T
who represent
Balden
I'm aware of um short-term
conditions such as um being uh
institutionalize for mental health issue
that while
shortterm affect uh someone's ability to
purchase a firearm forever I I think I
understand the law correctly um so would
this if someone is listed and then
delisted that's short term um does that
play a role in their ability to buy buy
a gun in the
future if there're do like do you have
any sense of whether it would be a
consider voluntary a completely
voluntary process so one of the things
that's really important to understand
about this is you cannot be put on this
list by a relative by a police officer
you know by a by a judge um nobody can
put this on your on you can put you on a
list like this except yourself um it it
it's totally
voluntary
thank you
Moren hello um this bill allows a person
to surrender their second amendment
rights for whatever reason and be kept
on a list so if they attempt to purchase
a firearm after voluntarily being put
out on put on this list they will be
unable to we've established that if a
person is suicidal they are most likely
not in any mental health condition to
make sound choices such as giving up
their fundamental human right to
self-defense if a person attempts to
practice their Second Amendment right
while being on the list they will be in
violation this bill is so poorly written
it doesn't even explain what the P
penalty actually is but they'll become a
felon if they according to federal law
if they try to purchase a fire while
still remaining on this list and New
Hampshire currently doesn't have any way
for a person to get off that list it
would cost them thousands of dollars to
go the federal route to try to get off
that nics list the gun control crowd is
once again using suicide as an excuse to
push more gun control this bill is a
self-induced red flag bill that doesn't
provide mental health help for anyone
it's discriminatory in that it only
applies to Gun Owners or potential gun
owners and if passed could open a
Pandora's Box for for Bloomberg's red
flag Bill to be implemented by simply
changing legislation a language in the
legislation please vote inexpedient to
legislate on this poorly written and
poorly thought out bill that claims to
be about stopping suicides when it will
you chair calls I believe it's Dr
Leonard
k
yes my name is Leonard Korn I'm a
psychiatrist who's practiced in
Portsmouth since
1974 I represent both the med New
Hampshire Medical Society and the New
Hampshire psychiatric sociey in my
testimony today I serve also as chair of
the New Hampshire Medical Society
subcommittee on violence as a public
health
issue I want to begin by thanking all of
you for your service and specifically
for the time today to consult to
consider many bills related to firearm
safety in New Hampshire I'm sure you're
all aware of the epidemic of gun
violence in our country both homicides
and
suicides our rate of gun violence is
simply tragic and far
surpasses the rates of other similar
Western
societies I've testified here in the
house for years on this issue but
unfortunately the will to pass Common
Sense gun violence laws still eludes Us
in New
Hampshire although it is certainly true
that laws cannot remove the risk of
Violence by Firearms completely many
stud Studies have shown that Common
Sense gun violence laws can reduce the
risk of gun violence
substantially in New Hampshire suicide
by Firearms Is tragically far too
prevalent as a psychiatrist I've had two
men who shot themselves in their heads
and died just in the last two
years
hb150 is a relatively simple and
straightforward statute allowing persons
who
self-identify
voluntarily as at risk of harming
themselves to be listed again
list and to and that would prevent them
from purchasing a firearm the statute
also as described
by
uh representative representative Muse
has a mechanism for being removed from
this do do not sell list please consider
supporting hb150 so we can reduce
somewhat the high rate of suicide in New
Hampshire thank
you represent Reed thank you Mr chairman
in in your opinion can who is more
likely to use um a gun uh in a suicide
situation somebody who has a
pre-existing Med mental health condition
like bipolar or you know schizophrenia
or whatever or somebody in a crisis
situation so if somebody's in a crisis
situation um are they more likely to use
a gun as opposed to somebody with a a
and my point of the question is is um
how effective a list would be if if
people who commit suicide are most
likely in a situational crisis um
episode well some people people who have
a mental health disorder recognize that
at certain points they may be suicidal
and those people and it might just be a
small number of people we don't really
know might agree to
voluntarily give up their right to
purchase a gun so that when the uh
emergency episode occurs they would be
prevented and they would know that they
would be prevented from uh purchasing a
safety followup so this offers minimal
protection to the people that are really
most vulnerable the ones that are having
a sudden crisis incident correct is do
you see it that way uh probably that's
probably true um in other words this
bill might save some people but it's
certainly not going to save everyone
from uh uh from suicide by guns
represent
sik thank you and thank you for taking
my question um for people who for
whatever is going on in their lives have
suicidal
idation um does that tend to be a
one-time occurrence for the majority of
them or is it something that um unless
they're success uccessful at committing
suicide um tends to recur with you know
over time it tends to occur reoccur uh
during crisis when faced with a variety
of stressors we ask a followup thank you
and so for people who may have had um a
suicidal episode and survived
it um who seek treatment and recognize
that they're
likely is a bill like this in your
opinion more or less likely to save even
one life it it might because if if we
have this bill Ava available let's say
that I have a patient who has tried to
kill themselves maybe not with a gun
because most likely with a gun it would
be successful but if they've tried to
kill themselves and then in therapy or
treatment they recognize that this kind
of Crisis might occur again then the
mental health um provider might
recommend to them that they might get on
such a list if we had one and if they do
then when the next Crisis if it does
occur occurs um they would be protected
from purchasing a gun thank you
representative
Stone thank you chairman waran thank you
for taking my question in your uh
professional experience what are the
other forms of suicide you've dealt with
with your patients all kinds of I've
been a psychiatrist for 50 years all
kinds of followup attempts
uh drugs
overdoses is there a percentage you
could clarify of what uh relates to
Firearms versus drugs for
suicide
well suicide by Firearms is uh as has
been mentioned is about 90% effective in
killing a person
overdose uh is much less
successful um people also can kill
themselves by hanging that's relatively
successful there are other means of uh
suicide that uh are sometimes successful
but there's no uh mechanism of suicide
that's more success uccessful in
succeeding to kill a person than with a
you um representative
Balden thanks for taking my question um
I have a an old friend who
um several years years ago was in a car
accident when I went to visit him in the
hospital he's actually a a former rep
um I noticed a bruise on his neck and I
asked him about it and he said that I
was the first person to notice and that
that was from when he had tried to hang
himself and that's when I learned that
he spent the prior two weeks quietly
going through different methods of
attempted suicide first pills then
hanging he woke up from the pills the
the news broke from the ceiling and then
he survived the car accident he's pretty
displeased with the results so if
someone like that was in your care and
they admitted to you that they had been
making an effort um to end their lives
but kept surviving and you knew about
this um the efficacy of suicide by gun
would you be recommending like If This
Were law would you recommend to such a
patient that they voluntarily enroll
before another episode I think I would
certainly suggest uh that they consider
list thank you for your
testimony representative
RS
good morning and thank you I'm
representative sah ORS and I'm here to
testify in favor of not going forward
with this bill you know people forget
history lessons and it's a shame because
gun control started in
America against the black
population the woodro Wilson
Administration did not want blacks to
have
firearms they wanted the K clu's Clan to
have firearms they wanted other groups
to have firearms but not the blacks and
historically speaking we've seen this in
Europe and it wasn't that many years ago
when the Jews were denied firearms and
then the Christians were denied
firearms and then the Lutheran were
denied firearms and we know what the
result to that that was 20 million
people that could not defend themselves
whether it was the ghettos in Warsaw or
whatever it might be we seem to keep
forgetting history and to have people
put their name on a list like this I can
see where they would get coerced into
this I've had my mental health issues
after living through
911 and then my post office was under
the anthrax terrorist attack in New
Jersey when I'd get a bag of mail and it
was
burnt and then I was working in London
when the terrorist bomb the buses and
Subways and then
just I I don't I don't believe in lucky
rabbit's foots but then I was in
Bingington New York when some guy from
Thailand blocked the back exit door of
the Civic Center where I was supposed to
be volunteering and killed 13 people
that day so I've had my experience
is and I'll tell you what anybody that
is healthy and well and doesn't have a
weapon at their disposal is really
taking a chance especially if you're
black and Jewish and Christian in this
country as well as Europe you know we we
heard testimony that in Europe you know
we are the most uh we have the most Mass
shoot no we don't the mass shootings in
Europe are just they're they're about
the same what we have is suppression
from the media so a couple things I like
to say in addition to that is there's no
such thing is gun violence there are
weapons and people use weapons but
people can use hammers blunts
instruments when I worked for the
Department of Defense a buddy of mine
who I worked with he worked in London
for about six seven years him and his
wife are there and he said when they
took away the weapons they used bats or
they used hammers or they used the two
by for so we could do these things but
to put people on a list like this you
know I can see where a they be coerced
in some cases maybe not but the thing
you got to remember is what if they
forget to take their name off the list
now you've made an innocent person into
a felon if they forget thank you I'll
any thank you for your testimony thank
you
chair
Slover hello I'm Kathleen Slover I'm
from Portsmith New Hampshire and I'm
representing myself today uh my son is a
proud member of the National Guard he
just went through boot camp this summer
and we are not a military family so this
was all new to us
um uh I got a pH I usually get phone
calls from him on Sunday and I got one
on Thursday and my stomach dropped he
said Mom I'm fine somebody in our
Barracks um died by suicide because he
had access to
Firearms we've talked a lot about um
suicide rates among military personnel
and Veterans and you would think as a
mother I would be looking at the what's
happening in the Middle East what's
happening at at uh in in South the South
China Sea after that phone call I went
down the rabbit hole because I'm worried
about my son he has access to firearms
and he's in
a he's in a profession or he wants to go
into the profession full-time which I am
supportive of uh once he finishes his
guard duties um but he's in a profession
that any given year it's 40 to 60%
higher rate of suicide than the average
population
ation so I went down the rabbit hole and
uh according to the US Department of
Veteran Affairs veterans are more likely
to die by Suicide than non- veterans 70%
by Firearms 90% of those cases are not
with issued not issued Firearms they are
from personally purchased Firearms
researchers surveyed VA patients who had
already received mental health treatment
to assess their attitudes towards
voluntary interventions to reduce access
to Firearms they were surprised that
93% of the respondents were open to a
low intensity technique such as talking
about their gun ownership with their
doctor that's not coercion they wanted
to talk about their mental health issues
and as they related to their gun
ownership about 75% of veterans um in
this survey also endorsed at least one
of the more intensive options to
substantially limit access to Firearms
like the disposal of the firearm that
they have or a VA program to store
firearms on their
behalfs voluntary waivers of firearms
are one tool like the options given in
the researchers study to give power to
those who know they are at risk so they
can take po a potentially lifesaving
action when utilized in conjunction with
other gun violence prevention measures a
volun waiver can help reduce suicide by
firearm as I went down the F uh the
rabbit hole I realized the Veterans
Affair Association the military the army
they have extensive research and
programs that military personnel and
Veterans can access and I'm really happy
that they do uh my son said that when he
came home from boot camp he said the
number one problem the military has is
mental health issues and they are
working on it as a mother I have talked
and canvased um from gun violence
prevention measures and I have talked to
psychiatrists gun owners across the
state and they believe in voluntary
measures to help people just give them a
tool um so I I'll end my testimony with
this I feel like the military is doing
their part they really are we're doing
our part by educating people I'm
educating myself as a mother of a son
who really wants to go full-time Army
and I'm proud of him and I want him to
do that I need you to do your part and
help the community stay safe and if this
is one small measure I think we should
take it so please support uh hb150 thank
you thank you for your
testimony um I have the the study here
sure
simin good morning Mr chairman and
members of the committee thank you for
giving me an opportunity to
testify uh I usually have prepared
testimony I do not on this bill
there and I've have attended many such
hearings over the years I'm a federally
licensed Firearms dealer and have been
so for a shade over four decades three
of them in New Hampshire so I understand
the law both federal and
state and I have another competence
that's relevant here I'm an
international economic consultant and
I've been that for about 20 years and a
corporate international Economist for
about 20 years before that so numbers
have a certain meaning to
me and they should to
you I suspect that no matter what durus
were applied to each of you you could
not come within 50 million of the number
of firearms in the United
States the number as at end 2022
and normally you would have print
written testimony from me with specific
data sources was
million that data point omits imports
from
20 21 through 2022 those data have not
yet been published so that data point
474 million is a
low-end data point if I put in my
guesstimate for imports for each of
those two years the number of firearms
in the United States is certainly over
million thus the concept that anyone can
control something so
numerous many of which are highly
concealable is
absurd gun control is for doomed to fail
it doesn't ma unless there's a qualifier
unless you are willing to enforce police
state measures so in Japan there is no
private ownership of
firearms there's an exception in
Japan's laws for Olympic competitors but
they can't keep their firearms in their
homes so obviously the incidence of
crime involving firearms in Japan is far
lower than it is here but I also point
out that in Japan police officers can
enter any private place without a
warrant and further that the conviction
rate for prosecutors in Japan is about
99% they don't bring cases unless they
are going to get a
conviction and the rights that we have
here for
example under Miranda Japanese don't
have so gun control can be made to
work but not
here unless you're willing to
countenance police state
measures I've been to Japan several
times it is a very quote safe place
however it's safe in a narrow sense
globally the downside to gun control
isn't Injustice it is genocide the
proposition is very simple it is not
possible to murder hundreds of thousands
or Millions unless and until the
targeted group and its sympathizers have
been disarmed that makes it easier for a
genocidal politician Vladimir V Putin go
President of Russia is potentially one
such he is not
yet but he admires the Soviet regime
which was
genocidal so
that when anyone votes for gun control
they're making a statement either one I
don't care about genocide or two yes I
care about genocide but it couldn't
happen here uh and a witness who
preceded me talked about Jews in Germany
it wasn't the disarming of the Jews that
mattered Jews were
0.7% of Germany's population in
1933 it was the
disarming of other
Germans who on 5 March
1933 when an election was held five
weeks after the Nazis lawfully took
office did not support the Nazis they
did not get a majority in that election
despite Stormtroopers being
able to attack other parties candidates
and other parties campaign
events
so the Nazis had to form a coalition to
get a majority in Mr simp um we have a
lot of people to testify today I
appreciate the history lesson it's all
very interesting but this bill relates
to people putting their names on a list
could you just narrow it down I will
conclude there with the following I'm a
licensed see I have had two persons
denied in the roughly 26 years we have
had background checks both were denied
for things that were fixable I knew I
didn't know what the things were but the
screeners at the gunline here in conquer
told me have your customer call us we
will tell them what they need to do to
get to get cleared one did the other I
never heard from again my my point is
that as a
dealer I don't want people coming to me
who are going to be denied and usually
people contact me and I pre-screen
them what folks do not know is that once
you are in the nick system good luck
getting out the federal authorities do
not and when I testify later I will set
forth the basis for what I'm about to
say the federal authorities do not have
to respect any State's attempt to remove
someone's name from The Nick system we
have no way to compel
them and anyone who knows differently
I'll be happy to be
educated thank you Mr chairman and
members of the committee I'll be happy
to take any
questions
thank you for your testimony thank you
Terrell good morning representative Roy
and the committee this is my first time
testifying I'll try to be quick and
forgive me if I break any rules of
decorum my name is UC Terell I work at
the University of New Hampshire's Cary
School of Public Policy but I'm um
testifying on my own behalf today I have
some remarks a request and an image
that's being passed around it is um a
lot of folks have talked about this as a
gun control Bill and this is never I've
followed this for a number of years um
uh as it's passed in other states it's
as it's been introduced federally last
year co-sponsored by two very
conservative Republicans and if this is
a bill about
self-control it's about the ability on
good days to make choices that protect
yourself on bad days when you struggle
with mental health you struggle uh in my
experience the worst part is not being
able to trust your own mind when the bad
times come there is total certainty that
your loved ones will be better off
without you your husband and your
children will Thrive after you're gone
you realize you're a burden to the world
it's hard to explain how clear that
realization is and what a relief it is
to know that you figured out what's
really going on suicide feels like a way
to regain
control so those are the bad periods but
even in the good periods there's this
niggling Terror in the back of your mind
because you know the disorientation is
going to hit you again without warning
followed by that awful Clarity of the
abomination of your
existence the idea of voluntarily
temporarily confidentially suspending
your ability to be buy a firearm would
be a tremendous
relief as I mentioned I've been
following this model for many years as
it passed in Utah um Washington Virginia
it was introduced federally it will be
introduced in 12 more States this year
as I understand it nationally it's
called Donna's Law And to be honest many
of the questions and concerns that have
been raised have already been addressed
um for example um in a peer-reviewed
medical journal a survey of inpatient
patients and outpatients of an Alabama
um psychiatric institution 46% said that
they would sign up uh rather than
speculation we can learn from other
states experiences and I am not an
expert by if I'm the both the person who
knows the most about this in the room
about other efforts I'm happy to try and
answer any questions you have as I
understand it this committee has had
recent experience with bipartisanship
with bail reform with Firearms reporting
reporting hb150 is squarely
in what New Hampshire stands for we
don't require that individuals wear seat
bels or motorcycle helmets but we
support individuals choices with that
government infrastructure like the
safety standards um in those other
examples that give individuals the power
to choose to protect themselves again
it's about self-control not about gun
control um so I mentioned in the other
uh states that have implemented a
voluntary do not sell list to date um
Utah was absolutely a bipartisan effort
with public um Health officials gun
owners and others on a coalition to move
this forward Washington wasn't initially
but in the most recent Amendment it
passed with um unanimously in the
committee so as a bipartisan effort my
fervent request is that chair Roy um
that others um L lend full-throated
support this once this hits the floor um
not only is it a know a good idea that
saves lives and eles but it also shows
that we can come together around some of
these these issues there's an image an
analogy from Greek and Roman mythology
that captures what this bill means to me
I'm not sure it will mean as much to you
as it to me but I wanted to offer it to
you in case it resonated with some of
you after the Trojan War the hero ulses
embarked on a 10-year journey by sea to
get home one of the monsters he faced
were the sirens beautiful creatures
whose voices were so alluring that
anyone who heard their song would jump
overboard to swim to them and get dashed
on the Rocks ulyses knew this madness
was coming he asked his team to help him
prepare to tie him to the mast in the
image that has been um passed around I
ask you to look at this painting really
look at it see the um the madness and
the Temptation that is so compelling and
imagine if his friends had said no had
told him that he simply needed to resist
the compulsion or to talk to them first
after the madness had already hit him
our government are Society needs to help
its people make their own choices to
protect themselves I urge you to advance
hb150 with bipartisan support and I'm
giddens good morning Mr chairman and
good morning committee um my name is
Katherine giddens I'm a lawful permanent
resident I'm also a local resident um
I'm a responsibly trained uh gun owner
and um I'm also the state representative
for a Women's National group called
women for gun rights forly known as the
DC
project and um I just wanted to offer a
couple of views here today um that to me
there is something deeply troubling
about um
legislating um an invitation for someone
to abandon their inalienable right um I
don't believe it makes any sense or it's
possible to legislate love or care or
Community
Spirit um someone who is in deep mental
distress such as you know if they're
suffering from from um bipolar or
schizophrenia um I'm not a medical
professional but I do know people who
have suffered from that and one of the
common um threads is the uh an intense
vulnerability to suggestion and also an
intense paranoia and I don't believe
that this kind of
bill um would in any way be um in
encouraging for someone to put their
name on a list that a government
controls someone who's in mental
distress like that I just don't see it
happening at all but on the plus side
there is a group already and I want to
tell you about them um just briefly um
they're called uh hold my guns they're
an amazing organization and one that
needs a lot more attention uh you can
find out about them on holdy guns. org
um they um they have firearm storage
they do community outreach crisis
awareness training mental they are huge
mental health Advocates and if you um
permit me just to read their vision
statement which I think is is
brilliant um hold my guns is working
together within the Firearms Community
combined with appropriate Community
partner alliances to raise awareness and
promote a self-governance
non-legislative approach to addressing
the prevention of suicide theft and
accidental shootings we will encourage
educational and enrichment opportunities
that approach stresses contributing to
Suicide risk such as Financial Wellness
conflict resolution and reac re
acclamation after deployment in a way
that is a matter of fact helpful and in
the stigma-free environment of
partnering gun shops isolation and lack
of connectedness which are risk factors
for suicide are holistically addressed
as gun shop customers volunteer
shoulder-to-shoulder through community
service opportunities available through
hold my guns partnering gun shops it is
an inevitable that those taking the time
to serve others will in turn feel a
sense of Pride and camaraderie knowing
that they are working together to make a
difference in their
neighborhood it's a beautiful group
there is not so far as I know
a partnership um here in New Hampshire
with them but I just want to say to the
committee and I want to let everyone
here know that as the state rep for
women for gun rights I will do
everything now that I know about them to
get as many Firearms businesses and as
many gun supporters as many veterans to
support this movement so that there are
places for people to go maybe to their
local gun shop maybe to to the local
shooting range if they own multiple guns
they know people they they have a
favorite spot that they go to to seek
advice to look at guns if they're
interested in guns if you've ever bought
one um you know what it's like you
establish a a place that you have a
connection with and the more places like
these gun shops that are connected to
whole my guns there will be safe places
there will be um Anonymous places where
you're not on a government list that you
can safely Place yourself if you have
the mental capacity to or if you have
close connections with family who can
support you through that as well without
fear of any doctor coercing you without
fear of any family member coercing you
tracked I love this group and I urge you
to reconsider um any approval of a
legislation that would um as I said
invite someone to give up a right that
they have when there are other
questions thank you very much for your
she you filled out two cards did you
want to do two different bills or no um
representative Muse did a card for me
and then he thought it was gone so I did
another one just one thank
you
um thank you for taking my testimony uh
this bill is named after another bill
called Donna's law and Donna's law is
ironically named after a woman whose
name was Don Nathan that was her
name I think it's ironic because I'm
here today speaking speaking in support
of this bill and my name is Donna and my
son his name is
Nathan and on January 5th
2022 Nathan drove to our local gun
shop and he purchased a
gun and 30 minutes later he was back at
our home and he took that gun and he put
it to his Temple and he shot
himself Donna's law a probably wouldn't
have saved Nathan's life I'll be honest
with
you however this bill would save the
life of someone like my daughter or
myself so January 5th 2022 was the
beginning of the worst days of my
life rushing to the
hospital seeing so much of my son's
Blood on the floor of the emergency room
and then hearing the doctor say that my
beautiful 21-year-old son with this
bright future as an engineer was going
to live his last hours in extreme
pain this is a trauma that no parent
should have to go through nobody should
so you might say well I bet that was the
worst day of her life but it
wasn't as horrific as that day was when
Nate took his life was that was for
me it pales in comparison to the pain I
feel every single day knowing that I
have to live the rest of my life without
him I would relive that day aund times
if I could have him back for just five
minutes I I really
would and the pain that I feel every
single
day it has brought me to thoughts of
suicide and I stay here for my husband
for my daughters for my
parents because I could not make them
live through another
suicide but the pain and the thoughts
are there all the time I don't want to
end up putting a gun to my head and
pulling the trigger I don't want my
family to find my
body I also know that if I was going to
end my life I would make sure it
worked because I don't want to end up
worse off than I am now and I certainly
don't want my family having to have to
spend the rest of their life taking care
of me and depleting our entire savings
dealing with any medical bills I might
have so the quickest and most effective
way to take my life would be with a
gun so I just want to tell you that I
have not shared this very personal part
of myself with literally anybody except
my therapist nobody
nobody knows this except now
apparently a movie thing that's going
and you guys and all these people here
um I'm speaking publicly about this even
though it's terrifying because I really
feel that this bill is that
important the goal of this bill is to
allow a person like myself to make a
decision when they are in a calm mind
and not in emotional distress we already
have a precedent for this when people
create living wills to decide how long
they choose to live before they become
physically
incapacitated Donna's law has a similar
goal in that people can make an advanced
directive indicating they don't want to
end their life with a
firearm when they are are emotionally
incapacitated so to protect my family
and myself I would put my name on a do
not sell list you're asking what kind of
person would do it it would be
me um just because I want to make sure
that I wouldn't be tempted to go down to
that same firearm dealer um when I'm not
thinking
clearly I don't want to have a moment of
weakness where I can't see that life's
not worth living because it is um and
this bill could literally save my life
there are many so many people out there
that simply are having a hard time
living and we don't know how to cope and
we sometimes feel that an escape is
really just the best answer and that's
how my son Nathan
felt but when we get to that place we
need to be able to just take a breath
and get through the moment I know that
there are other lethal means of suicide
I realize that you can take your life in
a bunch of other ways including like
someone else said Hammers and bats and
all kinds of things but why not allow
people who want to make sure that
they're safe from their own hand the
freedom to make that decision for
themselves they can make that decision
when they're in a safe State of Mind
when somebody kills themselves they're
not only destroying their own life but
they destroy the lives of everybody
around them and and we all know that
there's this ripple effect within the
community Nate's suicide was not an
isolation there were four previous
suicides that year at the college he
attended his friend had taken his life a
year and a half earlier passing this law
would allow people to protect those
those that they love by giving them a
chance to stay alive and get help I hope
I never need this law I anticipate that
I'm going to be strong enough and with
therapy I'll get to a point where the
pain just might not be that intense but
why not give someone like me the option
to protect my children and my husband
from losing me now I teach American
government so I'm going to end with that
we all know that the second amendment
gives us the right to bear arms the
ninth amendment is given less attention
but it gives citizens rights that are
not specified within the text of the
Bill of Rights
the Supreme uh Supreme Court Justice
Goldberg he wrote 1965 he said the
language in history of the 9th Amendment
reveal that the framers of the
Constitution believed that there are
additional fundamental rights protected
from governmental infringement which
exist alongside those fundamental rights
specifically mentioned in the first
eight Constitutional Amendments this is
just one of those additional rights
a right that a c citizen should have is
to be allowed to choose to not have a
firearm as a source of Temptation for a
mental illness that they are trying to
control so often legislators are asking
what can we do to help people with their
mental health something has to be done
well this bill is just one step in
helping reduce
suicides so I'll take any questions if
you have
them thank you very much here testimony
and I do have this do do you want this
sure whatever you want to give us thank
you thank you for your testimony and
today chair calls William
yeah I'll try to write better I really
printing thank you for your opportunity
to speak today I'm I'm kind of nervous
but this sounds like a good bill I mean
who could be opposed to doing something
that might prevent a suicide but it
seems to me when when I hear another
bill another
law I know it's redundant we know that
psychiatrists have ways to prevent
people from from going out and doing
things they can lock them up we've got
laws to prevent this we don't need
another law and every time there's
another law there's Administration for
that law and that Administration costs
money if it's at the state level or the
federal level it's going to cost us some
money and it's we've already got the
laws um sure I'm sure it's easy to get a
get on the Nicks list for prohibited
persons but I know it's as others have
testified it's hard to get off that list
and you may trust I don't well maybe
nobody trusts a giant Federal
bureaucracy to be able to handle stuff
like this they're already overwhelmed
with laws and and things like that so my
concern would be if you got on that
Nicks list would be getting it off and
second of all like I said there already
are laws psychiatrists can use to to to
lock people up and what they need to do
and they just don't do it so before we
pass new laws why don't we find a way to
enforce the laws that are already on the
books that are already there we don't
need more the last thing we need is more
more laws and more government and
especially more federal government to
administrate those laws um so I I think
other
people have have um alluded to the same
also liability it seems like an easy way
for medical professions to put the
liability back on the patient so that
they can say well they chose to do this
rather than them having to decide to you
know have a backbone and say okay we're
taking away your rights because they can
already take away their rights because
every time I fill out a a form for a
background check it says have you ever
been adjudicated nuts I'm I'm I'm sorry
me you know mentally defective or in a
hospital or anything like that so it's
already there and I know that you would
not be able to get off the next list
easily
um I think that's
all thank you for your
Hawkins good morning chairman Roy
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to testify today I'll
venture to be brief as much has already
been said uh my name is Sam Hawkins I'm
the public policy assistant at Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
nonprofit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy on behalf of Nami New Hampshire
I'm here today to speak in strong
support of
hb150 when an individual is experiencing
a mental health crisis limiting their
access to lethal means is a crucial step
in preventing suicide and saving lives I
want to further emphasize The lethality
of firearms and suicide attempts and
that Firearms are the most common you
method used in Sude attempts and
suicides deaths make up the majority of
all firearm deaths hb150 offers a
straightforward policy to help prevent
suicide by putting agency in the hands
of an individual when folks who live
with a mental health condition or
regularly experience suicidal ideation
are doing well they may recognize their
potential to be a danger to themselves
in the
future echoing the comments of a
previous speaker similar to an advanced
directive for healthcare decisions this
policy is a mechanism by which
individuals can formally communicate
their wishes for when their
decision-making may be later impaired in
many instances individuals already take
similar steps to protect themselves in
instance of suicide risk such as asking
their loved ones to take possession of
their firearms or other lethal means
when they feel their mental health
declining this bill is just one more
tool in that crucial toolbx hb150 is
thoughtful and balanced policy that
respects the agency rights and privacy
of those who choose to utilize it and it
could save lives for these reasons Nami
New Hampshire urges the committee to
recommend OTP for hp150 I can take any
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you and I'll hand in my written
you attorney Dean did you want to
testify on this
Dean
thank you for hearing my testimony
members of the committee good morning
and I would ask if this bill be ited for
several reasons and just as an aside
those of you who might consider hold my
guns or recommending them I don't
recommend them all I can say is run
forest run I've had ffls of mine say
have you heard about this hold my guns I
go yep probably shouldn't be interested
it's not what you think it is um fear
being tracked and stuff right up there I
have a Jewish friend who told me the
tractate on divorce was written before
the tractate on
marriage and I'm not Jewish but I've
been told tractates are these written
guidelines for Jewish people and so his
point is there's never a problem put in
the world from from their perspective
that the solution hasn't already been
provided and I think it's relevant to
this bill
because if the sponsors were truly
concerned about allowing people out of
the hotel California where you can check
out any time you like but you can never
leave they would have written the
process and procedure for getting off
the list oh we can write all that later
let's pass this bill and and we can take
care of all those things
later and the other thing that I would
note is with the exception of one um
testimony testifier or rather there all
these studies that say 70 and 80 and 90%
of gun owners support this or support
that I haven't seen the data brought
forth to the committee and I believe
they don't exist or if they did they're
not academically rigorous or not um
peer-reviewed so I would just talk about
the actual language of the
bill and just think about it from a dumb
country girl's practical point of view
of which I consider myself despite the
fact I'm a lawyer if you look at the
first page of the bill and you look at
um line
10 any person enrolled on the list shall
be ineligible to purchase or otherwise
receive ownership of a firearm from a
dealer as long as the person's name
remains on the
list so what about I'm a shooting
instructor and I sometimes say you know
people who have lived in New Hampshire
all the life go to the New Hampshire
State Police and run a New Hampshire
criminal background check comprehensive
for analment purposes on yourself and
bring it to me before you under the the
class and that's as good as I can get
that you're not a prohibited
person so what if as an introductory
classes I Supply Firearms to all the
students have I committed a criminal act
here but more importantly what's going
to appear on the New Hampshire State
Police criminal record
check because if they had been arrested
charged or convicted of a variety of
crimes it's going to appear on that list
on the record we get from the New
Hampshire State Police
but you're saying this can't appear so
this person if they want to do that they
sign up for my class and come into my
class now maybe they aren't going to
grab one of those guns and commit
suicide but maybe they just want to
shoot but it doesn't say anything about
possession per se receiving ownership of
a firearm but that's not possession
they're possessing them in my
class next we talk
about Nicks
NX is not responsive at all if you think
here's what I tell my clients if you've
tried to buy a gun and been wrongfully
denied and it was a handgun just sign a
release to me I'm going to go to the New
Hampshire State Police gun line I'm
going to show them the paperwork and I
bet it'll be fixed in no time if you
been denied from the
feds you can write me a $50,000 check
and they go whoa whoa $50,000 check I go
yeah $50,000 check because we're
probably going to have to sue in federal
court they like well what here's an
appeal thing and here's this I go yeah I
understand all those things just cuz
they write words on pieces of paper
doesn't mean they work rarely going to
work the feds have a system supposedly
that you can quote challenge a gun
denial I have unicorns in my backyard
too and so as a practical matter it just
doesn't work and so we look at this my
other concern is I think you're going to
see
situations where people are going to be
forced as they said or coursed to sign
these I'm mother and you want to live
with me anymore and I'm concerned about
you my adult child sign one of these
forms so you're not staying home with me
anymore I'm a
court um you want to go to jail it's a
choice I'm not forcing you you can go to
jail for 5 years and you can sign one of
these
forms no corion here
choice I can think of all these things
I'm my your therapist I don't feel
comfortable treating you unless you sign
this
form and so you ask yourself how many of
these people are actually going to quote
voluntarily sign this form and I
respectfully say there's a lot of room
for coercion here but then we talk about
well we can be removed from this but
here's what's really important to me
about the tractate for divorce versus
marriage the sponsors haven't prepared
the forms and the devil is in the
details which courts are going to have
jur dition to hear this that's important
first thing Court's going to say is
attorney Dean show me the statute show
me show me what gives me jurisdiction to
hear this case and so we're going to be
going around like homeless people from
knocking on every Court door and they're
going to say good luck to
you but the next thing is we're talking
21 days let's say a person really wants
their time period but now how many days
before they actually get their rights
back that they quote voluntarily gave up
well first 21 days after application's
been received for removal now then they
have to have a hearing but they have a
hearing in what court and where and who
gets to appear and what's the burden of
proof those are important things and I
can tell you a judge is going to ask
both sides to say give me a memo on
what's the standards how do I decide
these things and that's only fair to the
judge and make it easier to the court
the other thing is
um what about landlords and stuff and
they say landlords won't know about this
but how do we know if someone is or
isn't on the list if something isn't
being printed on your department of
safety
record and if it's not being printed
there does the department of safety have
the software and have the capabilities
to not put things like this on the
record they're passing out I don't know
if someone talked to the Department of
Safety about this and that's a serious
question question that their computer
out the other thing
is they talk about on page two line one
list I thought there wasn't supposed to
be a list if you're putting in NYX it's
going to be integrated with the database
I can't imagine for anything that
there's a separate list it's all
integrated but the question is NX is
pulled through every state in the
country
how are we going to restrict what other
states ultimately do with this data we
can't tell Utah what to
do and once it's out there you can't un
ring a bell you can't call back a bullet
it just doesn't work that way so the
question is how are we going to protect
these people and worse yet just like
swatting
people what if someone swats someone and
puts them on the list if I'm a domestic
vience abuser and I want to really fix
that person's Little Red Wagon be it men
or women in addition to fact abusing I'm
going to put them on the list so now
they go to buy a gun to protect
themselves from me and they're in a
logistical nightmare
here so you have to ask yourself how is
that going to work but then we go
further and if we go down the page on
page two and we look at um lines 12 and
13 within one business day of receiving
enrollment application the department of
safety shall submit identification
information what identification
information and again I'm going back to
the devil in the details will a passwort
passport work will a driver's license
work has anyone talk to the Department
of Safety about whether or not they have
the Manpower in which department is
going to handle this because you're
telling within one business day that's
quick and have submitted a form
voluntarily
okay and now here's the question it
comes to lines 15 and 16 on page two
database via the state police online
telecommunication spots for inclusion in
the
NCC so here's the question when I get
pulled over by the police and they run a
spots thing which is what they're going
to do probably the officer before he
runs up to my vehicle he's going to say
oh this vehicle's registered to her
we're going to see if she's driving it
and all these things come up am I a
wanted felon am I a bank robber is this
going to come up that I've signed up to
be on the
list and what if I'm open carrying then
he's going to say wait a minute you
signed up to be on the Don not buy list
and you're open carrying how does this
work and so there's a lot of things that
haven't been thought out and haven't
been considered what is that police
officer supposed to
do because maybe I say I didn't buy it I
already had it I just signed up so I
don't buy any more
guns but the bottom line is is that
going to come up every time they run
you and is that does that mean that the
police are going to treat mentally ill
people differently because I'm looking
that like the big red sign on my head
because what you're saying is this
person is mentally ill or thinks they're
mentally ill and not strong you know and
concerned about their own well-being
that they've signed this list so how is
that going to work in they're being
treated but then we go to line 19 on
page two within seven business days of
receiving an application from a listed
person to remove the listed person from
the list so we've got they've got 21
days then we got seven we're at 28 days
so you're not wanting to get off the
list I'm
predicting um the department of safety
shall initiate the process to remove the
person from the list I thought they were
going to court so maybe the department
of safety is handling this now do they
have a special administrative unit
that's going to do this do they have a
dedicated person is that person going to
be
trained and these are serious questions
they might seem to be nitpicky but if
you're the person that gets signed up
correctly or incorrectly or you change
your mind how is this going to work to
remove that person from any state or
federal list or database that would
identify them as a prohibited person for
the per purpose of purchasing or taking
ownership from a firearm or
dealer so the question you're going to
ask this says shall initiate the process
it doesn't say that they shall have
completed the process within a certain
period of time what is there to initiate
a process if a person has asked to be
off at you've got 21 days you got 7 days
why isn't it as simple as when you're
convicted of XYZ they put you in the
database takes 2 seconds you're now in
you get a DVP order against you in the
database right in there why are you not
switch o change o taken out the same way
they would if they put you in um but
here's the larger issue I have had case
after case where you anull things or
have things impr that were improperly
removed and Nick sometimes will not
remove them and there're the big grill
in the room and they're like make me and
so a person who's mentally ill or
struggling if they're truly on a road to
recovery and change their mind then the
issue is how they going to handle this
are they going to have to fight with
nyck to get themselves out okay now
within 30 um here's the next thing this
section shall not apply to a listed
person who's also prohibited from
purchasing or possession of firearm
because of a criminal offense or
protective order
I think you better think that one
through really carefully and here's the
reason protective orders are usually
good for a set period of time and they
expire so if a person wants to
voluntarily put themselves on this no
gum byy list and you say well we're not
going to put them in here because
they're already subject to a protective
order I bet the protective order has an
end date and so you're not going to be
solving your problem if you don't put
them in there because the protective
order ends now they're not prohibited
the other thing is people get their
crimes annulled all the time so you may
be prohibited because you have a bunch
of convictions but if you get them
annulled during the same time this
protective order for voluntarily no buy
is supposed to be in place again is that
going to be a 42 USC
1983 or other charge against the
government massive lawsuits because they
didn't enter it because they were told
not to because of this you have to think
now you're telling them about purchasing
not allowed but I think the most
interesting part is found on page
three
and this is a case where it is
absolutely word
salad and if you look at line three says
neither a voluntary waiver of firearm
rights nor a revocation of voluntary W
for fire right shall be considered by a
court in any legal proceeding that says
shell a judge is going to say this tells
me shell Shell's mandatory but you go
down a couple three lines and it says
lines 10 11 and 12 any person appearing
on the list with knowledge that person
has voluntarily waved a person's right
to purchase a farm and who attempts to
purchase a farm from a federal license
dealer should be guilty of a
violation well you're going to try and
bring that evidence into court and the
judge is going to say
I can't consider it and they're going to
prosecutor is going to say but it says
anybody shall be guilty of a violation
and the judge is like that's great show
me other evidence you have but I can't
look at that because lines three and
four says shall not be considered by any
Court uh or shall sh shall be considered
I'm sorry neither a waiver nor voluntary
um shall be considered okay so it says I
can't consider it we go down further any
person lines 13 through 15 any person
who knowingly gives any false
information who makes any false
statement with the intent of enrolling
or removing another person onto or from
misdemeanor so the question is are these
same forms not going to be allowed into
court so you say that you're going to
keep people from essentially swatting
other people but if those forms are not
admissible
how's that going to work so that means
really that I a bad person can with
impunity SWAT whoever they want because
the evidence is not going to be
admissible I think you have to look at
these proposed penalties and say how is
that work if you look at lines five and
six a voluntary waiver of firearm rights
may not be required of an individual as
a condition for receiving employment
housing
education benefits Insurance Contracting
or other
services but it doesn't say other
services against it's not Court it
doesn't say criminal convictions or
criminal things so I think that they
still are going to be able to
potentially say this sign the waiver or
go to jail sign the waiver or pay a fine
but the other thing is how
would anyone know if you had a voluntary
waiver cuz if if they make you sign a
voluntary waiver for receiving
employment let's say I'll just go and
remove it you just wait the six months
you remove it and so how are they going
to know this unless somebody somewhere
is telling them this you know this is
supposed to be so
confidential but I think you have
problems with it um and then it goes
further lines 16 17 and 18 any person
who discriminates against a person on
the list with respect to health care
services employment education housing
Insurance governmental benefits are
crack tacking because the person is on
the
list how are they going to know the
person's on the list is supposedly a
confidential
list so I think there's all these
mechanical problems that you have but I
think the most important problems anyone
who seriously puts Force something like
this has got to do as supposedly the
Jews have done you put forth the
solution first which is how you get off
the list and all the forms and how it's
going to work and then you talk about
the list I think this bill needs to be
it for a million reasons but even if one
supported it which I don't I support an
itl this is not the vehicle it's not the
mechanical thought out vehicle it's
worse than any rubbe Goldberg you've
ever
seen actually rubbe Goldberg's usually
worked they just worked weird this this
is not going to work um this is going to
keep you off the list forever I'm happy
to answer mechanical questions but it
just it's not well written or well
thought
out representative roads thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I'm sorry so so one of the
questions that I had written down that I
was waiting for somebody answer and you
did but I have a question with it is
on what am I on page
two line 26 the any person enrolled onto
the list shall not be removed from the
list list until days after an
application has been received for
removal then you talked about the
process for
removal So in
theory is there a timeline that the
person would have to be removed they
don't offer it in here so they don't
give you a time if I ask to be removed
in the 21 days then they have the seven
days but there's no penalties and
there's no mandated time like it has to
happen in 20 days 30 days 50 days it's
not in here so it could it could be in
definite time okay thank you for
question no further questions thank you
oh representative Stone thank you Mr
chairman and real
quickly given uh your profession would
you see this bill affecting those with
limited financial means from ensuring
their their rights they would be
affected the most because it breaks my
heart there are people with limited
financial means call me all the time
when their gun rights have been just
totally
decimated and they can't afford to hire
me cuz even just an hour I Church 300 an
hour which is actually very low for most
attorneys and they don't make 300 a week
or 400 a week they can't pay that the
the poorest among us are going to be hit
the hardest thank you very
thank you um I'm Dr Jeffrey feder I'm a
psychiatrist at New Hampshire hospital
and today I'm testifying on behalf of
DHHS in favor of this bill um I have
some written testimony I'm not going to
read through the whole thing I just want
to light three particular
points excuse
me um one is that um it has been shown
in multiple studies that decreasing
access to lethal means does decrease um
suicide rates it's been shown in um
India in a study with poisons um that
the majority of suicides at that time in
in that place were done through um
agricultural fertilizers when they
replaced it with a different type of
fertilizer that was less poisonous
people did not find other ways to kill
themselves um there's a famous study
where in an American city there were two
Bridges one um was favored for people to
jump off one was not they put fences so
you couldn't jump off that other Bridge
people did not walk two blocks to the
other
Bridge um similarly in uh in England
there was a study regarding um the
switch over from uh coal gas to Natural
Gas people used to mostly kill
themselves by putting their heads in the
stove um when they switch that type of
gas to a less lethal gas people do not
find other ways to kill themselves
denying access to lethal means is
effective as a public health
measure second is is the short-term
nature of suicidal
ideation um about 20 years ago there was
a study where they interviewed people
who survived jumping off the Golden Gate
Bridge and almost all of them said on
interview that they they regretted
Letting Go almost immediately on the way
down people are not at their best when
they are committing suicide and it is a
um an expression of their their of their
freedom to be able to have some control
over those dark moments when they are at
their best it's almost like having an
advanced directive we would never want
to take away the right of somebody to
make those decisions for themselves when
they're not at their best when they are
able to think straight and uh um uh make
their wishes known so for these reasons
DHHS is in favor of this bill as a
public health measure um and um be happy
questions represent
scitech uh doctor I have a question that
is this How likely is this scenario you
are treating a patient who is suicidal
and you are concerned and you say look
I'm going to have you involuntarily
committed based on what I've seen in our
therapy sessions unless you get on this
list that is likely scenario because I'm
concerned about coercion that's my there
are some mechanic well never mind that
that's
all if if I was thinking about
involuntarily committing a person this
would not be enough reassurance to me
that I would not involuntarily commit
them
I would expect they could get a gun some
other way doctor do you in your um
understanding if a patient you're
treating tells you that they're suicidal
or they're having violent thoughts about
someone else do you have a a obligation
to report that to the Department of
Safety as it stands under our current
statutes if I believe they have violent
thoughts towards someone else um I have
I have an obligation to take some sort
of measure to protect um that person so
if if I can involuntarily commit that
individual who told me about those
thoughts I don't have to notify the
department of safety at that point but
if they have to be released from um the
state hospital for technical reasons or
something like that then I would well I
was thinking more if you were just uh
under your license or treating someone
outside of the hospital for example in a
therapy session and they said to you you
know I'm I'm thinking I'm probably going
to kill myself tonight or I'm going to
kill my mother or someone tonight what
would your obligation be under the law
currently so it's basically still the
same if if I can have them committed at
that point it's that's considered the
safer thing to do to contain the
dangerousness if I can't have them
committed for whatever reason then
there's a um a rule called the terasoft
rule that requires um metal health
professional to notify the potential
victim or the authorities to protect
that person thank
you see no further representative sing
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um do you see this
lives I think there's a good chance that
it
could representative Pratt um I was a
fire chief in a fireman in a town for 42
years and I've seen 14 different
suicides only two of them was guns
how does the people choose what they're
going to use and if we block one way of
doing it what's going to prevent them
from using another
way so that question has been studied
and in mult multiple studies that have
been replicated denying access to one
lethal means and it's been studied in
Firearms as well as the kind of strange
methods that I me mentioned denying
access to lethal means does decrease the
chance that someone dies of
suicide all lethal means all lethal
means well I mean the most lethal means
okay so if you know for instance uh the
coal gas is considered a highly lethal
means compared to natural gas so just
switching that over people did not
decide okay I'm going to slip my throat
or hang myself instead um they they have
an idea of a certain means and throwing
any obstacle in their way tends to make
them change their mind um I've had
patients tell me I stood on the bridge
the the patient I can think of who
jumped off the Quee Bridge um told me
that if someone had just walked along
and said what's wrong is there something
going on I would have just turned around
but no one
did people are it's hard to commit
suicide you throw any little obstacle in
their way and you might change the path
thank you
yeah thank you for your testimony thank
you
HK good morning uh my name is Dr John
Hank and I'm representing the New
Hampshire Psychiatric Society the New
Hampshire Psychiatric Society supports
hb150 to potentially reduce the risk of
suicide and gun violence in individuals
who at risk I have worked as a
psychiatrist at New Hampshire hospital
since
1995 I have worked with many patients
who did something very dangerous with a
gun towards themselves or others when in
an episode of severe mental
illness many of those patients respond
very well to mental health
treatment and they later regret their
dangerous actions with which resulted in
serious
consequences hb150 would enable those
individuals to try to be proactive and
help prevent this type of dangerous
situation from happening again in the
future in closing the New Hampshire
Psychiatric
Society supports hb150 as a way to
improve Public Safety and decrease the
risk of suicide and violence in
individuals who are at risk
thank
you thank you VI test who now
representative
Newman yeah I I just want to ask a
question about some of the testimony we
heard earlier and I I can't tell you
exactly what it said but but I'll try
and paraphrase that there were no
peer-reviewed
studies that show um the various how how
violence how Firearms are connected
to
suicide no I think to to be clear I
think the witness said there's no
peer-reviewed studies or or um with
related to what percentage of gun owners
supported this legislation I think was
what the the comment was but you may ask
that question I'll withdraw my question
thank
you thank you
Doctor anyone else thank
you wishing to testify on this bill was
not testified on this bill
seeing none I hereby close the public
hearing on House Bill 1050 we're going
minutes
now
e
okay opening the public hearing on Hill
1186 and invite the prime sponsor to
introduce their
Bill thank you Mr chairman my name is
representative Jason Jen I represent
Rockingham District 40 which is the
towns of Hampton and sebr New Hampshire
uh today I introduce House Bill 1186 FN
um and I'll get into the bill but I want
to give a little history here of why
this bill is before the committee today
in 2018 the House of Representatives
Senate uh put a constitutional amendment
before the voters and it passed uh
giving them uh the citizens of New
Hampshire the right to privacy that same
year a colonist in the New York Times
placed a
column explaining that the federal
government because they're restricted
from doing a Firearms registry um would
should attack uh Firearms by going
through the banking system so
Amalgamated Bank approached the iso
which the international organization of
standardization you've all heard of ISO
9000 certification that sort of thing
and the iso based upon that petition
introduced a MCC which is a merchant
category code in September of 22 about
that same time after it was announced
that they would be doing that uh the New
Hampshire attorney general joined with
23 other Attorneys General across the
country and sent a letter to Visa
American Express Mastercard condemning
this move to do a uh Firearms registry
quas Firearms registry uh via Private
Industry so March 23 after several
houses of Representatives and senates
across the state across the country
introduced legislation to stop this type
of uh registry uh the Visa Mastercard
and American Express said that they were
going to pause their plans so I I'll
talk about the the states that have
instituted this a very similar Bill Sim
similar law to what I have before you
today it would be West Virginia I ho
Mississippi North Dakota Florida Montana
and Texas I understand there are five
other states in the union this year that
are contemplating a similar bill so the
first part of the bill is the
definitions of who this would affect
what a Farm's code is which is actually
a merchant uh nmcc under the iso using
big words if you have questions for me
again I I'd actually ask that you ask me
during the executive session because
there's a lot of people people here that
want to testify on the bill um so this
bill would prohibit the use of those
Firearms codes in the state of New
Hampshire and the third part is it
places it before the Attorney General to
investigate the violations of this law
in the ability of whoever violates the
law 30 days to come back into compliance
with the statute uh if they fail to do
so then there's a civil
penalty
and there is a process in the Civil
Court to appeal
that
um this if it's passed by the house
senate and signed by the governor this
will take effect in January of
25 um I just want to closeing saying
that if I go to kidy trading post a Bass
Pro Shop or one of these other places um
you you may not know but I'm an
Outdoorsman I'm an eagle scout I like to
go out and do things in the outdoors if
I go to Bass Pro Shop and buy hiking
boots a backpacking tent a frame pack
hiking poles Black Rifle coffee gortex
jacket rain pants and a kayak and I get
to the register and I use my credit card
and it comes up as a purchase of about
$4,000 I don't want somebody mistaken
that I went out and purchased a firearm
I want I don't want that discernable to
any other Sporting Goods category so
basically the bill is is telling these
um these places that they cannot use a
bills spec I mean a code specific for
firearms that it can be general
alone thank you and you've asked
questions to be held for session so yes
sir
um um thank you then for your
Davis
there we go honorable members of the
committee my name is Justin Davis I
serve as the New Hampshire state
director for the National Rifle
Association I'm also a gun owner here in
New Hampshire I appreciate the
opportunity to uh represent our members
uh belief that uh this bill should pass
uh in New Hampshire uh as representative
janver so eloquently said in 2018 the
New York Times published how Banks could
control gun sales when Washington won't
uh the the article argued that major
Banks credit card companies could set
new rules surrounding Merchant category
codes to track and potentially hinder
firearm purchases just four years later
the International Organization for
standardization announced that they
would create the MCC code on the
purchase of firearms and ammunition now
the important thing to understand about
this MCC code is that it's not just for
if a firearm or ammunition is purchased
but if it's at of firearm retailer right
so like representative janver said I go
to L Cody or Bass Pro Shops and I buy a
tent new boots coveralls for my hunting
um that would show up as a firearm
purchase just like it would buy if I one
bought a new CZ 612 for duck hunting
right so when you have these high level
purchases or these large amounts it
could flag for the Department of
Treasury or that credit card company
well as this person a threat they buying
large quantities of firearms um this
creates a major concern for privacy um
mainly because uh these these purchases
should not be flagged where a credit
card company can deny these purchases
because you want to make a firearm
related purchase um and it also serves
as a quasa gun registry right so we can
see where myself every firearm I
purchased or every time I went to these
gun stores this the government can then
look at what we've done so in a time
where data privacy is paramont to the
people of New Hampshire I think that
this is something that's certainly
needed um and even as representative Jan
said Visa and MasterCard and these major
credit card companies have already
paused this because there are major
concerns about the uh the facility of
that so happy to take any questions you
have but the National Rifle Association
Muse some something I'm trying to
understand is how information that's
recorded on your personal credit card
can
become public or can be disclosed to
people you know outside of you and and
your credit card company so the way I
understand Merchant codes and and I
actually appreciate them uh on my own
credit card statement because they show
things like charitable contributions and
and they can help me get organized for
tax purposes and things like that so I
I'm a little confused over over how
privacy rights might be violated and
where where the concern is coming from
here yeah absolutely so there's two
prongs to that one is that it can be
flag for the Department of Treasury uh
if there's large purchases made under
these codes um and I'm happy to provide
some more of that information for you I
don't have it readily available from you
but I'm Happ to provide you that
information uh secondly I think as we're
all aware there's a lot of data leak
issues uh a lot of stolen identity issue
so having that information become public
for firearm purchase that you make I
know as a gun owner I don't think I want
the general public to know all the
purchases that I make at certain retails
uh for whatever whether it's for hunting
whether it's for an actual firearm
ammunition purchase I think there's a
very real concern for people about the
data privacy uh not just in house in
these places but for that to become
public is there some type of a federal
um law that authorizes the credit card
companies to share information with the
Department of Treasury I'll have to look
at that to get a success statute for
that but I'll provide that for the
committee thank
Tes what bil yeah looks like 11 I think
it say these things um
Leonard Leonard is that you again oh
yeah it seems your handwriting is
so um as I said before I represent the
New Hampshire Psychiatric Society and
the New Hampshire Medical Society and
I'll just be
brief gun violence is a major epidemic
in our country it is the position
of uh our medical societies and the
American Medical
Association that guns Firearms be
registered and
Firearm operators be
licensed so the we we have information
about cars and ownership of cars and we
need to have information about uh guns
as well and I realize that uh uh people
are uh in favor of gun rights are not in
favor of these types of uh information
being available but for people who are
interested in gun safety registration
and knowledge about who are purchasing
guns uh is important that's all I have
to
say that's said enough thank you very
much um thank you the chair recognizes
uh Penny
Dean
thank you Mr chairman and members of the
committee my name is Penny Dean and as
in all these I represent myself and
myself only as a private citizen
and there are Banking and credit card
companies in this country that
discriminated against gun owners and the
most famous is probably Bank of America
and Bank of America told McMillan's
stock several years ago and McMillan and
I would not make stacks and high-end
competitive firearms that was one of
their main things after being a customer
for 20 years McMillan was told take your
money and get out of our bank and bless
his heart he made that public he took
the letter that was given to him and
spread it all for all gun owners to know
that you probably shouldn't do business
with Bank of America and when Bank of
America called him in and said we don't
want your money in your business anymore
he's like why we pay our loans we had a
great banking relationship with you
what's the problem you sell guns he says
I make stacks for custom guns I don't
per se sell guns didn't matter it was
gun business and they looked at it as
bad money because of guns and they
simply didn't want his business so how
many of us could see our bank Banking
and our credit card shut down because
it's going to be a gun purchase because
it's coded as a gun purchase how many of
us would see credit cards denied because
when they run a credit report they're
going to say you've bought a lot of guns
because we have code numbers here and
you shop at gun
stores and if anyone thinks that type of
discrimination doesn't appear all the
time I'll respectfully say it does and
it's as Insidious as racism was years
ago it's just a little um um becoming
more and more blatant every day
depending on which party you belong to
so this bill is absolutely
necessary and as the representative
noted he sees codes on his credit card
bill and more of us are seeing those
more and more of where you bought the
purchases and so what happens when your
credit card company happens to be the
same one that your employer is you have
a employer's credit card Your Own Credit
Card which you diligently keep separate
what happens when the credit card
company mistakenly sends your personal
Bill to your employer or transposes the
numbers in the accounts and now your
employer sees how many guns you buy for
some people that could be a job killer
even though it has nothing to do with
their job there's a million things that
how how about when you go to apply for
an apartment they want to see your most
recent credit card
statements you're going to see all those
codes on there so there's a million ways
in which it's can harm a private person
and so this bill I would strongly
recommend is ought to pass because it is
about privacy interest and civil rights
we should be treated as they say the
content of our soul not anything else
and how much money that we spend on any
particular thing be it jewelry or guns
or cars should be nobody's business and
so the bottom line is and we shouldn't
be treated differently by these
companies because of how we choose to
spend our money and I think that could
happen more and more and more because
more and more gun owners have talked
about banking of America and certain
other companies that don't want our
business so I respect I'm happy to
answer mechanical questions or practical
questions but I would ask respectfully
that
you consider this is an ought to pass
necessary to
s difficult name isn't it thank you Mr
chair it's
ORS uh thank you for hearing me once
again committee I testified a little
earlier
today and I just wanted to reiterate
this the fact about a little history and
when it was mentioned earlier here in
testimony that gun registration is
necessary well we know what happens in
Europe in the 40s and 30s with gun
registration and the same goes with
credit card information when the banks
are allowed to take credit card
information and screen people whether
it's for business or whether it's the
fact that they buy weapons or weapon
related materials ammunition whatever it
is the last thing we want in a free
Society in our Republic is to have our
privacy taken away by the government or
anyone and so I would like you to take
that into consideration as we move
forward on some of these bills the last
thing we want is big brother or somebody
else looking over our shoulders and then
going to tell us what to do or come
after us as we have seen as the doj and
different organizations within our
country become politicized thank you
very much and I'll take questions if you
have
any
thank you for your testimony thank you
anyone else wishing to testify on this
ahead thank you Mr chairman I apologize
for um not having the card handy um I
just wanted to quickly state that
there are two purposes for having that
code that identifies uh you know gun
businesses the first one is to create a
gun registry which uh is not a policy
that should be followed by anybody since
you'd be keeping a registry of people
who did nothing wrong and it was used in
the past to harass them I want to remind
you that in California there was a
accidental leak of all the people on the
gun registry who then ended up being
harassed I don't think we should keep
that information the other purpose for
this which is really the real purpose
for this is to treat
gun businesses gun firearm related
businesses the same way the feds treat
the weed businesses by cutting off their
Bank access one of the huge risks of
having a marijuana business anywhere in
the US is that no banks will do business
with you you got to deal in cash you got
to have armored vehicles and all that
because the federal law still still says
that doing business in there is illegal
there have been previous attempts from
the feds to do exactly that unofficially
but they were St it because they
couldn't quite track who to cut access
to so now they want a code to make it
really easy now there was a question
asked on whether this data would be
available commercially if you look up um
Senator weyden's recent press release uh
he's uh talking about the fact that the
NSA has purchased a massive massive
amount of commercially available
information to get around the Fourth
Amendment and basically search your
information whether a warrant because
they can buy that from Brokers if you
read the press release it includes
purchase information yes that is
available that information is on sale if
you want to purchase
it and if we think that having a bank
code for firearm Merchants is a good
idea would you feel that having a
separate banking code for abortion
providers would be appropriate would you
see concerns then in terms of what would
that do to the privacy of the people
that use those Services they're not
doing anything wrong they're not
breaking any laws why would I keep track
of them I want to assure you that I
would oppose efforts to keep track of
both those types of people or of anybody
else who is doing something legal and
the government has no business keeping
track of them I really appreciate the
time and uh I'm available for any
questions thank you I have a quick
question um the psychiatrist uh
testified a few minutes ago from the uh
New Hampshire Medical Association and he
said that they felt that there should be
a a list a registry of people that own
firearms and the Firearms they buy um do
you think that we should have a list of
people who go to see psychiatrists and
we keep that for safety purposes I
absolutely do not think the government
should keep that list because we already
have legislation saying that there is a
certain amount of mandatory reporting
from the medical service
professionals but it should be a very
high threshold before people end up
putting on a registry that can result in
them putting you know losing
constitutional rights and while I
respect the professional opinion of a
psychiatrist who Prof has a professional
opinion that less access to guns May
save lives our job as legislature is to
look at the big picture and
take a potential benefit and wait
against the other costs that such
legislation May incur so my opinion as a
legislature will consider the opinion of
professionals but it cannot just be
driven by that thank
you that I Clos the public hearing on
House Bill third oh another person
signed
up
simin
Christ
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I will be brief three words to
begin data are lethal two quick examples
18 April
1943 the island of bugville in the
Southwest Pacific Japanese aircraft
prepared to land it was shot down by US
Army aviators on board is soku Yamamoto
who planned the attack on Pearl
Harbor Admiral Yamamoto I guess didn't
know that the United States had broken
Japan's Naval code and thus had his
itinerary the only thing that the
aviators needed to know where and when
nothing more Admiral Yamamoto did not
survive the attack fast forward 3
January 2020
in the evening a car accompanied by some
others left Baghdad airport in one of
the cars was a colonel kasum
solmani of the Islamic revolutionary
guard
Corps he didn't know that a US drone was
up there it fired one or two hired
missiles he didn't survive the attack
again the only thing that the us needed
to know when and where so the idea that
data are somehow oh not dangerous is
provably false I don't have a horse in
this race I'm a lensee I have never
taken credit cards further as a leny my
name and address are published by the
feds this bill ought to be
enacted with support from both parties
because databases aren't secure anyone
who pretends to the
contrary should not drink
Kool-Aid when JP Morgan Chase major Bank
gets hacked and the hackers are in their
system for
weeks it's a big bank it has plenty of
money to spend on data
security you
cannot imagine you shouldn't imagine
that data are
secure I'll be happy to take
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you Mr
chairman with that I open the public
hearing on House Bill 1336 and invite
bill we got
any for 1336
yeah thank you very much Mr chair and U
I forgot to introduce myself when I
spoke last I apologize I figured that 3
minutes later should cover both I'm
Daniel popovic Miller representing
Windham Rockingham District
17 um I uh filed this bill based on a
constituent request somebody came to me
and told
me I have a problem I know you're are a
State
Rep I carry concealed my employer is
Banning firearm possession on their
property and I want to respect that
and I'm fine with that but unfortunately
because I have to park my vehicle in an
employee owned parking
lot that respecting that choice of my
employee which I want to respect
requires me to also not carry at all on
the way to work and I need to stop and
stop the grocery store stop at Banks we
have a life and I cannot make a separate
trip to work come back carry and now go
around so my intent was and by the way
here obviously due to the nature of of
the concern ask me not to uh ask him to
testify or to disclose his information
because obviously there are concerns so
my intent was to find a way to protect
the rights of you know people who want
to carry concealed while at the same
time not infringing at all or as little
as possible on the rights of the
employers I think this bill does exactly
that and I put a lot of thought into
that it's a very simple bill by the way
I don't want to use lots of word words
when I write legislation it basically
says an employee who is coming to work
in his own vehicle has the right to
leave that thing locked and out of sight
in the
vehicle as long as they do that the
employer is not allowed to ask them
about it to search the car or to punish
them in any way they become aware that
there is a firearm in the vehicle as
long as again the firearm is out of site
in a locked
vehicle because the
employer will you know have that firearm
potentially in the parking lot there is
a paragraph in the bill insulating the
employers from any civil action in
regards to uh any losses that may occur
from them following the law I don't want
to have a law that puts employees
employers at risk of being sued for
something they are legally required to
do and really that's about I recognize
that there is a minimal impact on the
right of an employer to control access
to firearms on their property but since
it is so restricted to just a personal
vehicle of employee and the firearm has
to remain locked and out of sight in the
vehicle I believe that I did everything
I could to minimize that impact while at
the same time protecting the rights of
people that want to carry concealed on
the way home and back to do so and again
respect the rights of the employer and
that's my introduction and of course I'm
Muse so I know in New Hampshire we spent
a lot of time on on especially on this
committee talking about property rights
as well as as well as gun rights and I'm
I'm I'm kind of curious how you how well
you think your law strikes your proposal
law strikes a balance between those two
things thank you for asking I
acknowledge that concern from the
beginning right I I try to present my
laws my bills in as objective a manner
as possible so I acknowledge there is an
absolutely minimal infringement that in
my opinion is more than balanced by the
benefits that it gives look I do not
believe that employers are creating
those restrictions to control what
people do outside side of their
property unfortunately we do have that
minimal area where I cross onto employee
proper employer property to park and
that's it and their desire to regulate
that essentially extends that boundary
tens of Miles depending on how long
somebody commutes to work I don't
believe that's their intent and I spend
a lot of time trying to again address
that issue with absolutely a minimal
impact and again this is why they're
insulated from any Civil Life ability
I've done everything I could and the
that would the liability protection in
your bill for example extend let's say
to uh an
employer uh let let's say somebody
breaks into the car on site a lot of a
lot of companies have parking lots that
are out in the open um steals the
weapons and uses the weapons to rob
somebody shoot somebody do harm to to
some other person um because the because
the employer had a policy allowing
weapons to be stored on site that may
not have
been maybe in an area that could have
been maybe better protected than it
could have been uh but maybe it wasn't
does that create a situation where the
the employer is exposed to a different
kind of
liability in my opinion no I also spoke
with the I OSS drafting attorneys and
asked that very question and they
assured me that this language would not
expose the employer to any liability
from this because obviously criminally
there couldn't be liability because they
are obeying state law and by the way
it's not their policy it's a state law
they have to obey it's not a
discretionary choice of theirs this
takes that decision out of that hand so
therefore no liability can be attached
to them for following a state law
essentially this would increase the
protection of employers that may
otherwise be look the real risk right
now is that you have a policy that's not
consistently enforced if the same
scenario happened the employer would
actually may be liable today if we do
pass this this will protect the employer
and frankly the liability in that
situation should be on the person who
broke into a car and stole property I I
really don't like the concept the legal
concept that I've seen applied that you
know I'm somehow responsible because
somebody broke into my house and stole
property and used that property to
commit crimes I mean you know anybody of
us could go to jail for that you know I
don't think it's okay to punish people
who've done nothing wrong because
they're a victim of a crime but that's a
discussion for another
hearing thank you thank you
representative
Newman yeah I just want to clar clarify
this law would apply apply to a loaded
weapon that is just secur is under the
seat and the the vehicle is locked the
requirement is that the firearm be out
of sight and the vehicle be locked the
the intent behind this is to have
reasonable protections against the
possibility somebody may see something
and be tempted to steal it I mean if you
live a firearm on your dashboard and
everybody can see it this this does not
protect you you were careless but as
long as it's out of sight and in a
locked vehicle how much more can we
reasonably ask anybody to do to protect
their property I mean to me that's as
far as you can ask and be reasonable and
not start in trapping innocent people in
crimes follow up follow up and uh it
well I'm Not Gon to ask
question represent
sake thank you and thank you for taking
my question I'm I'm wondering whether
you would be be open to a very small
amendment that would say that the person
would need to have their weapon in a
locked case within a locked vehicle
essentially to double the layer of
security right so that if someone
happened to be randomly breaking into
cars as we know happens or if someone
forgot to lock their car that day it
would just add an additional layer of
protection for the general public
um I I will consider it but my first
take since you know it I had exactly
five seconds to think about it I come
from Massachusetts and I've seen
Massachusetts prosecute innocent people
for having their house broken into and
Firearms stolen because they violated
the Massachusetts storage law I think
that anybody who breaks into a vehicle
will also have the ability to break into
a log boox look I have a little safe in
my house that I use for my carry stuff
right I know that if somebody takes it
outside and US uses a big hammer in 5
minutes they'll open it it's meant to
protect somebody from you know a quick
attempt to grab something in a few
seconds I think that anybody who already
broke into a car will not be deterred by
more boxes and I I hesitate
to add more risk for the employees that
I'm trying to protect and more costs
without what I perceive to see a good
benefit but I would be open to talking
about it maybe offline after the hearing
sense thank
phone um wow I'm even short at the desk
um while we agree that granted Staters
should be able to practice their
fundamental human right to self-defense
however and wherever they say fit the
government shouldn't be getting involved
nor mandating what a private company
does we know of instances where
companies have a no firearms policy but
in domestic abuse and stalking cases
they have allowed employees to carry
firearms in their vehicles so they could
be protected when they left the actual U
business and um another thing to think
about is if this was actually
implemented and it could be easily
flipped around if God forbid the gun
control crowd was to gain control of the
legislature and the corner office they
could flip this and say that no
employers are allowed to ever allow
employees to carry firearms whether in
their vehicle or on the person and this
would apply to ranges gun shops Etc this
is an issue between employees and their
employers not an issue that the
government should be involved with
please vote in expedient to legislate on
this
you chair calls attorney Penny
Dean
Penny Dean again from conquered New
Hampshire representing myself I
respectfully say this should get an
ought to pass um as it is and here's the
reason we have more multinational
companies in this state than you'd
realize
and a lot of them are large employers
and some of them come from places where
the Second Amendment just is doesn't
exist and it's an Abomination to some of
them sadly but yet they choose to do
business in our state and this would
give those employers cover in other
words employees that work there would be
able to carry firearms and they would be
able to tell their corporate owners in
Europe primarily Europe some in the East
to say look look we have to let
employees carry here because it's state
law we can't do anything about it we
have to follow the laws of the state we
don't want to pick up and move and the
bottom line is the ones that claim that
the only reason that they don't want
employees to have firearms in their
vehicles in the parking lot they'll say
we're afraid of liability taking care of
here you don't have any liability so the
objections that they have are all solved
right here but the bottom line is I'm
very fortunate I work for myself so I I
can do what I want but I know a lot of
people because of family reasons because
of obligations because of health
insurance because of careers that work
at places that don't allow them to
exercise their second amendment rights
they are mandated to park an employee
parking lot and the employee parking lot
isn't allowed
guns and they know their vehicle to get
searched at any time and if their guns
are found there'd be a problem some
choose not to kill carry guns cuz of the
risk others choose the option that I
suggest is you have to be alive to be
fired but again that's an easy choice
for a person that doesn't have a wife
and three kids to support so I look at
this and this gives people a Level
Playing Field I respectfully suggest
that there's harm to no
one that whether or not it should be
between employers and employees as a
practical matter employees don't have
the same bargaining power and that gives
those who don't have the education I'm
very fortunate I have a fair amount of
Education I have a lot of employment
options there's a lot of people in the
state that don't have a lot of
employment options even though we have a
great economy and low employment they
can't just go anywhere and so you have
to say this protects the least of us
this protects the man who can't stand up
for himself this protects the man with a
high school diploma that's trying to
support his family so I respectfully say
if there's anything you could can do to
help the poor and the powerless this
does help them this gives them the
opportunity to protect themselves going
home maybe in the Lesser quality
neighborhood you know maybe shopping at
the store picking up their wife or
whatever I respectfully say I don't see
the harm in it and I see a lot of good
in it and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you um could you tell us
what the state of the law is currently
with regard to um leaving firearms and
vehicles um in New
Hampshire we don't have a law requiring
they be locked in vehicles so there
currently is not a law requiring they be
locked and there isn't any statutory law
per se there is laws that say about
negligent um storage where miners get
access to guns of course and you could
say that's in a car anywhere so most
prudent people are going to lock a car
but I do agree with um representative
that adding lock boxes and stuff that's
just a pain in the foot and a recipe for
disaster each person's going to make
their own choices but it's kind of like
the robber rapists that they'll break 10
laws but they won't break 11 I'm not
buying that anybody is going to break
into your car you know they're just
going to take the lock box with them
anyhow you know so I think that this
solves the problem presuming you keep
your vehicle locked and I don't see any
other legal impediments in New Hampshire
to this bill and it really does give the
employers cover you know and and that's
what they they claim they're worried
it representative Stone thank you
chairman Roy and thank you for taking my
question in your opinion or in the state
of New Hampshire is it viewed under law
that your motor vehicle has a higher uh
interest of privacy such as an extension
of your home it is is it is um we are
very very fortunate and a lot of people
don't understand this but the United
States Constitution um has a baseline
you can't go before in constitutional
rights but you're allowed to go higher
and in New Hampshire in many areas we've
chosen to value our constitutional
rights if you will greater than the
federal and so it is considered an
extension of your person and just like I
wouldn't expect that you could just walk
and get in my vehicle and start picking
through my glove box I would presume I
have some privacy and everything
contained in the vehicle and as long as
my employment contract doesn't provide
otherwise um I think they should stay
out of my vehicle quick
followup could you also remind me what
the penalty for a theft of a firearm in
New Hampshire
is under federal law under New Hampshire
state law there is an append it would
depend on the value of the firearm 1500
would be a felony so in New Hampshire
the penalty levels go on the dollar
value of the item
thank you is there a federal law that
you're aware of um regarding the theft
of firearms I'm sorry is there a federal
law that you're aware of regarding the
theft of firearms depending on what you
do yes depending on how it's taken in in
such
yes and from where it's taken I should
add okay thank you um see no further
questions thank you you
Testament the chair calls Katherine
giddens
thank you Mr chair um I'm speaking right
now just as uh for myself as a local
resident um and I just wanted to um at
whatever weight that is I'll be it uh
very minimal uh to the spirit of this
bill I think it um
um I think it does make sense that
although you may be parked on your
employers you know in your employers
parking lot it's it's your car it's an
extension of your home and uh If an
employer is not allowed to um inquire
into your religion you know if they're
not allowed to um um make any decisions
for or against you based on your you
know your ual preference or your
whatever Creed you have whatever race
you are um I would argue that um firearm
ownership is part of a certain Creed and
um if you uh store that safely in your
car then uh it's no business of an
employers um and that is just my
personal opinion that's all I have to
say thank you see no questions thank you
Rogers thank you
again for giving me a chance to speak um
I carry every day and when I heard this
come up I said you know if I was in that
situation I would have a problem I would
not
feel I was being responsible if I left a
car if I left my firearm in a car even
if it was locked I would not I would my
choice would be not to do that because
it's too easily stolen if it's stolen
well let's let's face it Saints don't
steal things if it's if they're going to
steal it they're probably going to use
it in a crime but when the
representative said perhaps an amendment
to have to put it in a locked box still
out of sight in a car I would support
that um but I wouldn't I could not
support it without that Amendment
because again personally I would not
leave my gun in a locked
Lynn thank you Mr chair and uh members
of the committee I I appear here in
support of this bill I'm co-sponsor and
I have to say when representative
papichi meller first approached me about
whether I would be a co-sponsor in this
bill I I have to say that I had to think
about it because as representative Muse
points out I I am also a very strong
believer in property rights and you know
the general view I think the general
rule is if it's the employer's property
you know the employer gets to say what
the rules are I mean I I you know I
gener as a general matter I I support
that view um but I think here you're
it's a question really of balancing that
employer's right against the uh the the
individual's right uh to be able to
exercise his second amendment rights or
his rights under uh under the New
Hampshire Constitution to to own uh and
and to uh and to Bear uh firearms and as
as as representative uh papichi Muller
pointed out if you you know the problem
here is if you have If an employer has
that policy of no guns in the parking
lot it effectively mean it it
effectively means that the the employee
can't exercise his rights on the way to
the to the to work or on the way home
because it you know you're not going to
what are you going to do uh it it's just
not it's just not practical and I guess
I I I guess I would use a sort of a a
sort of personal example fortunately I
never worked at an employer that had a
rule of no no guns outside the you know
outside wherever you are but I'm a
Target shooter so on Tuesday night uh
you know it it's it's very recently very
recently stopped because the the other
people on the team you know got too old
to to continue shooting and so that that
that particular team kind of went to
Funk but for 20 years if it was Tuesday
night I was shooting in at the major
walren uh Sportsman Club in barington
New Hampshire we had a we had a league
so I live in Windham and I worked in
conquered for a good part of that time
so you know if you if you chart that out
that's a pretty that's a pretty pretty
big triangle to drive from Windam to
conquer to go to work then after work
drive to barington to go shoot and then
drive back home to Windam so if I
couldn't you know and I would have so on
Tuesday night I would have my 22 target
rifle locked in the car in the in my the
back of my car and since it's a rifle
you know you wouldn't put you can't put
it under the seat um it was in the it
was either in the trunk or if I had a a
station wagon it was was in the back and
I and I always kept the the case locked
although candidly you know that's not as
other people have pointed out that's not
really much protection the the case is
locked but you know somebody has a
somebody has a sledgehammer or whatever
they're going to be able to pretty it's
not going to take them very long to uh
to to get into the into the uh into the
gun case and so I use that just as a
very practical example is if you know if
I worked at some employer that said you
can't have guns in the parking lot what
what what what do I do and why does it
make sense for me for for me not to be
able to have a gun locked in the car um
so that I can you know so that at the
end of the day I can go target shooting
I just don't think should I have to park
or off you know and if you're talking
about some big employer I don't know
like GE or some big employer that
parking lot can be really huge what what
do I what do I do I have to park like
off the employer's property and and you
know somehow walk in and then maybe I'm
parking and maybe there's no place to
park in the area or whatever it just it
seems to me that on balance here the
infringement if you want to call it that
on on an employer's property right is
pretty minimal
um uh compared to the protection of the
of the of the right of the person to to
uh uh to have you know to pursue a law
to pursue a lawful ownership and use of
firearms so for those reasons I strongly
support uh this bill and I hope you'll I
hope you'll decide to consider it ought
to
pass thank you would you in in your
understanding would you consider the
Second Amendment of Civil Right ABS oh
absolutely absolutely I think it was a
civil right are there any other laws
that you're aware of that we allow
employers to discriminate against
people's civil's
rights no you know I I mean the thing I
I understand what you're saying the only
thing where I raise you know I raise an
issue here because I think I I think
there is a point here of the property
right in other words you know I I I
suppose that an employer could have a
policy of you know no speaking I mean
I'm I'm making an a sort of
an an you know a really extreme example
but I suppose an employer could have an
a policy of no talking on the uh you
know on my premises except ex
specifically about work you can't talk
about anything else now you know I'm I
suspect that employer is not going to
stay in business for very long but
presumably they could um and and I guess
it would be a question you know there
there that there it might be a little
bit different because if if an employ
employer had that
rule at least that wouldn't prevent
infringe on an employees First Amendment
rights on their way to work or on their
way home uh whereas this this sort of
does um but there's you know there I I I
guess what would a court say If an
employer did have that rule no talking
about anything other than you know other
than uh uh the employer's business on
the employer's property I don't know not
sure the court the court has ever had
such a case and hopefully there's not an
employer that would be kind of foolish
enough to adopt such a policy
but it it would be a qu I think it would
be an open question I guess well to your
point a civil right that an employer
impacted through their policy that not
only impacted the person while they were
there but on their way to and from work
oh exactly exactly I think that I think
that's I think that's exactly right U
thank
you Representative
scitec no one this morning has mentioned
and I think it's a time that this be
this get into play we have passed a
constitutional amendment guaranteeing
privacy in the in New
Hampshire what right does an employer
have to say about anything in my
personal car brought on premises locked
up uh he has no legitimate business
interest in anything in my car and
doesn't our right under the con the our
constitutional right Trump the
employer right to uh to the concern in
my car anything in my car any more than
the employer it's his property but I can
use the washroom privately can I not I'm
infringing on his right in that
case I I want to bring up our
constitutional right is my part point no
no no I I mean I think the I think the
Privacy issue is a is a very is a is an
important one I mean I guess you know I
I I
think I this is personally I would kind
of dra in in the context of this
Firearms thing I would draw the line at
at the where this bill does in other
words I would I would have a real
problem I think I would if if there was
a bill that proposed listen if you have
a if you can lawfully con carry
concealed you can carry concealed into
the you know into the employer's
business they can't have a policy that
says nobody nobody can be carrying
concealed in the business inside while
they're working I would say no no no
that goes too far they've got you know
inside the workplace if if you own the
business you can say I don't want
anybody armed in here even though I
might personally if I had a business I
would not have that policy i' would say
if you can legally own a gun fine you
could come on in and carry out the you
know do your job but I can certainly see
that other people would have a different
View and I would I would not I would not
go you know I would not support a bill
like that because I think that just
would be too much of an infringment on
rights in your opinion the in other
words the the Constitutional Amendment
representative scitec brought up really
is against the government versus an
employer but the does the in your
opinion does this balance this bill
strike a balance between the rights of
the employer and the rights of the
employee I I I think it does and I you
know I uh I I I think it's very limited
it's only in the parking lot it's the
car's got to be locked the gun can't be
visible um I think I I think that the
intrusion the intrusion on the
employers employer property rights in
that circumstance it seems to me is
pretty minimal and I think the benefit
to the you know person who wants to
exercise their second amendment rights
is pretty strong and so I would say that
you know that does strike a proper
balance as we learned in New Hampshire
um ly of a firearm isn't necessarily a
specific crime it's based on the value
would you not see some value in in since
if we're going to contemplate this at
the same time making the theft of a
firearm be a specific crime of its own
yeah that might that I think I think
under Colonel if if it's a firearm it up
it can up the penalty from you know
enhancement yeah enhancement but no that
might make that might make a lot of
sense to do
that thank you represent
Muse yeah I I did have one scenario I
wanted to run by you and just have you
comment on it so let's say the business
that I operate is a daycare center and
let's say the parking lot that my
employees Park in is next to the
building and next to the building is
outdoor equipment that the children in
the daycare center play in um given the
fact that all of us at one time or
another have gotten text messages or
found ourselves busy when we're getting
in and out of our cars and we come back
and we go oh I forgot to lock my car
given the nature of a business like that
would you think that a business like
that would have the ability to should
have the ability as a condition of
employment to say we don't want you to
put firearms in your car when your car
is on our property and and I guess on
top of that we also have a child
negligence law uh in New Hampshire that
actually penalizes people if their
firearms fall into the hands of uh of
children who use them to commit crimes
or shoot other people so I'm curious how
you react to that yeah I I I'm not sure
that that would change my view on it I
mean it's you know can
the can the
employer I would you know can the
employer say well listen you can't you
know um in in that circumstance of the
daycare the employer say to the employee
you know don't you can't bring uh you
can't you can't pick up your
prescription for uh perco set or
whatever on your way to work because you
can't leave it in the car uh because you
know maybe somebody maybe one of the
kids will get into the car or you can't
have uh you know um I don't know if you
if you uh if you break a glass or
something in the car you're driving to
work with a and somehow you break a
glass or there's glass in the car you
know you can't come you can't you can't
you have to clean it up before you uh
come into work because maybe a kid will
uh one of the kids from the daycare
center will get in and cut themselves I
I would tend to say you shouldn't be
able to do any of those things and to
sort
of single out firearm arms you know I I
don't I just I don't I would not think
that that would make sense thank
joeann good afternoon members of the
committee my name is uh Joe Hannon uh I
signed in and support of this bill for
gun owners of New Hampshire but I'm
speaking on my own behalf um right now
uh I didn't think I was going to speak
but there was a lot of comments that
came up about why it's necessary to have
this this uh change in law uh I actually
worked at a very gun-free facility when
I was in residency in North Philadelphia
and and uh I could I'd like to say it
wasn't the the best let's just say it
wasn't the safest neighborhood to
commute to and from um my now wife then
girlfriend uh a few weeks after we met
uh she was leaving the hospital got into
her car drove home to a different part
of Philadelphia was walking to her
apartment and was pistol whipped by two
armed individuals took her purse luckily
that was all that happened she got a few
stitches that was our third date
watching her get the
stitches um she became a very uh strong
Enthusiast of second amendment rights
after this incident um also uh
personally I had several um close calls
or scares coming to and going from toing
from uh the hospital uh I had been
chastised by one nurse because I opened
a medicine bottle with a Swiss army
knife she told me you couldn't have any
weapons in the hospital I was okay I
didn't know that uh I couldn't have a
knife I was there as a foot and ankle
surgery resident I had a fist full of
scalples in my jacket pocket that was
okay but a pocket knife
wasn't anyway I didn't even ask about a
gun I just let it go um but uh the
parking garage was secured we had to go
in and out there was a guard there so
even if someone did break in they would
probably be able to find them pretty
quickly so I wasn't worried about
securing a firearm in the parking lot uh
however uh most people did not do so uh
after uh someone wins the Super Bowl or
big basketball game you know some cities
have problems occasionally with rioting
or celebration not rioting let's just
say
celebration uh after leaving the
hospital one night after the 76ers
didn't do very well uh my car broke
down and there were helicopters fires
looked like something out of uh science
fiction movie it was pretty crazy uh I'm
sitting at a gas station trying to get
help the person was ducked below some
bulletproof glass wouldn't even take $20
for a gallon of gas to help me get keep
going uh my then girlfriend now wife
dropped off some gas that she got didn't
even slow down just threw a gas can at
me and took off so um I think that
someone and we heard all these other
arguments about you know property rights
the cars and extension all this other
stuff but I think it's important to
understand that not everyone lives in
and now I live in Lee which is wonderful
I don't worry my most people don't even
lock their doors or cars I still do I'd
lock my door when I check my mailbox
because I grew up in that City but uh I
think this is very important I think
this is something that is not just a
rights issue or a privacy issue I think
this is a an issue of uh you know
allowing someone an individual to
protect themselves outside of
environment now whether an an an
institution can be gunfree or not I
think that'll come up in uh some later
testimony today but I will just say that
this is an absolutely necessary Bill to
prevent uh
possible dangerous situations from
happening to individuals you happy to
take any
questions seeing none thank you for your
testimony her scar looks pretty good too
by the way
thanks that's it anyone else wish to
testify on this bill was not done so see
none I hereby close the public hearing
wa what did you turn in a
card Oh attorney
on
I swear I'll be very quick it's a turny
Andrew do you have a card or you didn't
fill out card I didn't fill one out I
certainly will okay um there was just a
mention of whether or not theft of a
firearm is a specific crime in New
Hampshire if you do steal a firearm it
makes theft a class a felony under RSA
6371 yeah is the penalty section of the
theft statute yeah which makes theft of
a firearm a class a felony so that' be
punishable by 7 and half to 15 years in
the state prison so under under the this
proposed Bill if someone broke into a
car and stole a firearm it would be a
class a felony with that penalty
possible whether this bill passes or not
if you break into a car and steal a
firearm it's a class a felony thank you
thank you further questions fy's
here okay I'll fill out a card for you
that's right and now it's really
Clos with that I open the public hearing
on House Bill
1337 and invite the prime sponsor Mr
chair I got to go get the sponsor okay
yeah we're going to take uh we're going
minutes
if Dam opening the public hearing on
House Bill 1337 I invite the prime
Bill thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Tom Manny representing Hillsboro one the
town of pelum uh this bill is a result
of a constituent request uh when they
explained it to me what the process is
for having your property returned uh to
you upon the expiration of a protective
order I had to reread the RSA several
times to confirm yes in fact we have a
law in the books that requires a
defendant to prove their innocence
before the court this is a complete
inversion of due process flying in the
face of the foundational system that
innocent until proven guilty so this
bill attempts to rectify this by
inverting the responsibility uh to call
a hearing before the court onto the
plaintiff and uh should no hearing be
called the defendant can retrieve their
property without the Injustice of
pleading before a court to do so uh a
second Granite stat are also brought to
my attention a situation where the
storage fees they incurred uh from
having their property held amounted to
more than the value of the item I
haven't followed up with that individual
but that is it's an anecdotal experience
so I did uh I had an assistant call
around to various police St uh stations
around the state including uh one from
this specific situation and they all
claimed they do not charge storage fees
for property seeds from a protective
order uh so there's a contradiction
between those statements the anecdotal
experience I was told and the fiscal
note attached um uh since the phone
calls lead me to believe that these
stations aren't charging storage feeds
at all I see no reason to give such
leeway as a reasonable fee that may be
uh inconsistently or maybe maliciously
determined on a case-by Case basis um
now if the methodology of this bill
could be better served through some
other design I'm happy to work with the
committee on Amendment but I believe
it's plain to see that there's an
inversion of due process on the books
that needs to be remedied uh same for
the storage fees perhaps a hard cap
would also suffice in that or in in in
that realm uh regardless I ask the
committee to vote OTP on HB 1337 thank
you thank you uh representative did you
just say you had an assistant call I was
I was wondering how you got an assistant
I must have missed that no I didn't get
one in it's like an intern okay all
right uh that's true um thank you any
questions uh no no questions thank you
for sweet thank you um
I did you
there the chair calls uh Dr Leonard
Korn
thank you you again all for uh hearing
my
testimony so this bill has to do with
protective orders and protective orders
are difficult to obtain and they are
obtained
when uh an
individual
is felt to be a danger to another person
usually a partner or a spouse this is
usually an abuse
situation and the protective orders last
for a certain interval of
time statute right now requires
the
defendant or abuser to go to court and
get their rights to have guns ammunition
and other deadly items back in their
possession it's the burden of the abuser
to go to court for that to take effect
this bill in front of us changes the
burden to the abused and the abused
person has to object
to the
hearing and uh create the uh
necessary uh
Court situation so that the formerly
abusing person doesn't get their guns
back I think it behooves the state to
keep the situation as it is rather than
uh present the abused person the burden
to
prove
that the their abuser is uh safe to get
their guns that's about all I would have
to
say thank you for your
testimony chair calls attorney peny
Dean
thank you members of the
committee I strongly support this bill
and I think it's highly necessary for
many
reasons the last statistics I've seen if
I recall them correctly were that about
75% of protective orders were ultimately
granted if I've read and and that's two
years behind the way I read um the
statistics that are put out by the state
of New Hampshire so that's going two
years back I have not seen because there
usually is a delay in reporting the last
couple
years I consider that pretty darn easy
to obtain the other thing the only thing
I think is easier is than dating a ham
sandwich and those of us who have
defended against these protective
orders most people are shocked when they
know that they went to court and what
they thought was a simple hearing and it
took their gun rights for a year and
they call and they'll say to me well can
we appeal this then and I go yes we can
appeal it but we Appeal on issues of law
not issues of fact and the chance of
winning that is pretty slim you're going
to pay me a whole lot of money and get a
whole lot of
nothing so if they happen to come to me
before the hearing there's a chance but
here's what you have to understand these
people generally women who fill out 4 to
eight pages of allegations and I say to
them in order to effectively defend you
CU any one of these single allegations
will win her this protective order and
here's what you have to understand why a
lot of these women go get the protective
order while the protective orders in
place let me explain to you what happens
I have one most recently man owned the
house guess what he's out of his house
because that's what she has been allowed
to have and he cannot change anything so
we had to ask for a longer hearing
because if you've got pages and pages of
allegations you're going to have to ask
for sometimes two three I've had
multi-day hearings you may have to wait
up for a year for a hearing date while
you do for a hearing date that temporary
order stays in place which means he's
still paying a house payment of a house
he can't stay in he's still paying the
lights the phone I can go down the whole
list lights phone cable he says wait a
minute why do I have to pay the lights
phone and cable for a house I'm not
living in when I'm going to throw the
broad out if you will because we're
getting divorced or we're getting
separated or we're not having a
relationship anymore and my answer is
cuz there's a protective order in place
now and so she can do what she does
which is turn the heat up to 80 and
leave the windows open and you have to
pay the Heat every month cuz if not
guess what you're in
contempt you can't change anything you
have to pay her phone bill every bill
that's being paid up at that point you
have to continue to
pay and you say where is the Justice in
that my answer is there isn't any but
the bottom line is the only reason this
75% statistic isn't higher in my opinion
and I do not know I don't remember from
the sheet is because a lot of these
individuals the complaining if you will
don't show up for the hearing and then
it's automatically dismissed and I do
not there's a percentage out there I've
seen the number I just can't remember it
to tell
you so this number would even be higher
so anyone that says these are difficult
to obtain has never been in my shoes for
my clients but I think what's even worse
is as a practical matter I've seen some
Department say now prove them your guns
and you're like but I turned them over
and you seized them you got them from me
I have a receipt here yeah we know but
we we need some receipts to show their
your guns or we're not giving them
back and even then once you get a court
order which can take weeks and weeks and
months and months you then have to make
an appointment with the evidence
technician or The Evidence Officer and
The Evidence Officer he only works from
2: to 4: on Tuesdays and Thursdays and
the particular time you make an
appointment with him yeah they're
short-handed at the department he went
out on a call come back well I took the
day off work today yeah I know but he he
had to go out on a call so we're coming
back and so getting these Firearms
backers not as simple and easy as they
would make you think it is so putting
and what's even more important here this
person has not been convicted in a
domestic violence sense this person has
made the preponderance of the evidence
standard which means just as we say 51%
the scale tipped more that the judge
believed
the
complainant there's no evidence in these
cases that the person's been convicted
of
anything because if he were convicted he
wouldn't be allowed to get his Firearms
back so making it more difficult and
more expensive for these people to get
their firearms back when they're not
under any restriction at the end of a
domestic violence protection order to
get their firearms back is unfair it'd
be like before letting someone out of
jail after they serve their time jump
through some other Hoops or do some
other things we don't do that to people
once you've went through the process
you're now a free person you're to be
treated like a free person but the other
thing that you talk about is um the
storage fees and more importantly the
obligation to store these things nicely
I've had guys with a brand new Sig funny
thing went in there came out the front
sight's all gone and damaged and messed
up now do you believe that just happened
accidentally or whatever sigs are pretty
rugged
you see abuse and damage to firearms
that are sometimes darn near Priceless
and there's nothing you can do about it
so I
think every part of this bill makes
common sense and it begins to level a
playing field which quite frankly I
think is unfair because what happens is
the women who generally apply for these
we've got all sorts of state and
volunteer helpers who help them fill out
the forms who come support them in cour
court and
yet the person who's accused has got to
go hire a private attorney usually in
very short notice and sometimes to
defend against pages and pages of
allegations that are quite frankly a lot
of times very difficult to defend
against because they're allegations of
he said she said so I'm happy to answer
practical questions but this begins to
make it more fair and more Equitable and
quite frankly save these people from
grief and getting Firearms
back thank you if you could um walk walk
me through the process so I have an
order against me I turn in my firearms
as I should yep the order expires it's
not renewed how do I go about getting my
firearms back right now you make a
motion to the court where the domestic
violence order was pending and ask for a
motion for return of firearms they're
going to have a they're going to set up
a hearing now there's no statutory
mandated date when they're going to set
a hearing so it can be week or weeks or
months from the time you
ask when they go to the hearing what is
supposed to have happened or what the
court wants to happen and it's one of
the many things that I disagree with but
it's the way it is is that when you go
to that hearing um and they're going to
notify the complainant the party whose
DVP is against and that person sometimes
come and says they object well I don't
even think they should be a party to
this I think it's wrong because whether
they object is whoopity ditya they got
no legal basis to object because the
order's over so you go there now it
depends on the particular Police
Department that's holding the Firearms
they may may or may not show up but let
me tell you the worst thing that happens
and it happens all too
frequently judges want a clean check
from the gun line before they'll give
the Firearms back even though there's no
evidence before the court that the the
person is prohibited from Firearms so
more than once you go to court you pay
your lawyer to go to court we all go to
court and the judge says where's the gun
line check oh it's not back yet your
honor reschedule this court hearing and
you're like what so what I try to do if
it's if it's some case I'm handling a c
Court Clerk and I say hey is the gun
line check back yet because if it isn't
I try to continue the matter so the
client doesn't have to pay me to go to
court I sit there and wait for our
hearing right we go up only to find the
gun line check isn't back yet and so the
gunline check and when I said the gun
line check they're not doing a gunline
check cuz that's illegal they're
actually running a triple ey check but
the gun line what does it if you will
they're people that handle it last time
I
checked and so what happens
is that if that check isn't back again
and again and again if whoever's
involved even though it should be able
to be done it's just like a spots check
behind side the road a trooper can do
that in 2 seconds there's no reason it's
not instant not done it's because some
sort of Staff communication are busy it
can be weeks and weeks and months and
months so then you go to court and then
you get it presumably an order that says
you get your guns back and so and this
is to tell you how difficult some police
departments even make it so their
officer was in court physically when
this happened when the judge said give
him his guns back right gives you the
order so I tell the client listen you're
going to have to go make an appointment
with their evidence person to get your
Firearms back but here's what we started
doing because some police departments
this is just tell you how difficult they
make it the client goes there they said
well where's your order and he's like
well you're in court right beside me
when they said it oh no we have to have
a copy of the court order so the client
goes and gives them a copy of the court
order oh no we have to have a certified
copy of the court order and we're like
but you were sitting right there when it
happened so I can understand maybe a
department where they don't go to court
I see no need for that record so to me
as a matter of practice I just tell the
client look when we leave we get
certified records because some of them
played this game so you're just going to
say oh good I've got a certified record
right here but even then sometimes even
physically getting a hold of The
Evidence Officer to make the appointment
can take a client weeks literally weeks
and there have been departments I've had
to call and say hey can I speak to this
person and make an appointment for my
client because it's taken an awful long
time so you're talking from the time
this dvpn till you get your guns back
can be 6 months or more I'm not saying
there isn't wonderful occasions I've had
wonderful occasions where a wonderful
Department's there and says hey come B
you later and get your guns those are
rare rare rare exceptions so meanwhile
you've been without your guns you now
get them back but it's months and months
and months and weeks and weeks and weeks
before you actually physically retrieve
them your guns and your ammo and I've
had officers say to my clients well
you're not prohibited from buying guns
now just go buy another gun well if you
got lots of money you can do that but
not everybody has lots of
money so it's it's an uous process and
this the other thing is clients are
shocked if they didn't have a lawyer
that they have to file a motion to get
their guns back yeah I mean they're like
you got to be kidding I have seat here
they took them you know I I voluntarily
gave them up why do I have to file a
motion to get my guns back and I tell
them if you don't file this motion
you're not going to be getting your guns
back there's no Police Department that I
know without a court order that'll give
them
back what if you know is the average
what would you charge a client to handle
a a the just the guns are giving back
case cuz that sounds like it's a totally
different case than the it's a totally
separate case thousand and here's why I
first have to fill out the motion which
is 60 bucks 80 bucks right but I have to
dve I charge as most many lawyers do
what's I call portal to Portal from the
time I leave my office till the time I
get back is the time I charge so we have
to go set in court they're going to give
us a court date if we're lucky we're in
and out in a half hour if there's been a
cur fluffle at the court if something
else happens which courts are busy we
could sit there for 2 hours waiting to
be heard so paying for me to sit there
for those two hours which I'm not happy
about but I'm you know I mean they're
paying that's $300 an hour and 55 cents
a mile for my travel time and then when
we leave of course it's I don't know 10
bucks 5 to 10 bucks for a certified copy
but then if I have to continue to call
um the police department for them
because sometimes it doesn't work and
sometimes you have to I quite frankly be
extra nice to him cuz I want him to give
my client guns back that sometimes means
longer conversations you can't just call
them up and bark orders to them you got
to ask nicely and so literally if you do
the math it depends on where it is
geographically like I have some clients
say where I say well G I could recommend
a lawyer closer and they go no I want
you to handle this because you've done
this before so it depends on how far
geographically it is from conquered is
the total price you know I've had people
pay me go to South Boston the time and
they feel that you know some of the
things I know are helpful to them so
that's a lot of money to get your guns
back and sometimes the guns monetarily
aren't that great one of my favorite
clients only had two guns but they were
his two guns and they were his property
at matter Jim he had a handgun and a
long gun and one of my dearest clients
and like he said they shouldn't get to
keep his property and that's and that's
why he's paid more on me than they were
worth quite frankly and the other thing
is sometimes when judges get objections
from the original complainant until they
get a lawyer involved they're
disinclined to give them back even
though they have quote have to give them
back so it's it's a very difficult and
arous process for the person who's doing
this who's who's trying to get their
firearms back and again I know it seems
so simple you say you file a motion you
go to court um if all the pieces aren't
in place you don't know how many times
the Court's tell you to come back again
and the defend the accused person who
had the complaint order against him he's
not going to know to call the court
clerk and make sure the gun line ran the
check you know he he's not going to know
that and he's taken a half day off work
and some people work by the hour they've
not only made their employer not happy
but they've missed income that's a lot
of money for a working man and just to
be clear the people we're talking about
here are innocent correct they haven't
been convicted because then they won't
be able to get their firearms back at
all yes these are not convicted men
these are men who are innocent of all
crimes that were aware of because if
they had been convicted in a thing they
would not be allowed to have these firms
so these are innocent citizens that are
being penalized I call it the double
whammy by the
system and so there's no reason to do
this to these people these are innocent
men whose property's been taken they
have receipts everybody agrees it's
their proper property and all they're
asking for return of their property
because meanwhile again average working
men can't go out and buy a bunch more
guns these are the ones they used to
protect them themselves to protect their
home to protect their
families and they just want them back
you know that that's really what it
comes down to they're they're people who
have
done in my mind nothing wrong now they
they might have had a protective order
against them but sometimes again as we
know from the Innocence Project even
those that are convicted they not waste
guilty you know so but these men have no
criminal convictions and no legal
impediments to getting their guns back
they just have practical impediments
through bureaucracy through the court
system and through some police
departments to obtain a protective order
you don't necessarily have to have
actually been accused of abusing someone
it could be that you are an imminent
threat of abusing someone yeah
absolutely so even that isn't
necessarily true that there's they've
done something it's only been accused
and then they weren't proved guilty
that's exactly it a lot here is what I
think is the worst part of these things
is it comes down to what I call he said
she said usually or he she said she said
or he said she said is that I could say
that he said he's going to cut my throat
with a
knife guess what protective order here
we come you know because that's the
threat of abuse it's the threat of
physical violence with a weapon and the
bottom line is it depends on who the
judge believes and here's the thing I
keep reminding people in this state we
do not elect judges so we can't unelect
them once they're on the bench they're
there forever or until 70 you know
they're they're there forever and it's a
big difference I come from a state where
you elect judges and so I'll tell you
something that I believe every defense
attorney or even attorney in general
will ask you if you come to an attorney
with a problem one some of the first two
questions most of us ask before we ask
about the facts or anything we ask two
questions who's the judge and who's on
the other side because that makes a huge
amount of difference and you think well
the facts should matter you know what
the actual conflict is and what the
specifics are yeah it should but guess
what makes a huge huge difference you
know we all know the judges who lean one
other representative
jamon thank you Mr chairman I'll try to
keep my question
brief um I actually had a conversation
with one constituents in the last couple
months told him about this bill that we
were going to be facing it and he told
me and I'm just wondering if you could
tell me how many times you've heard this
occur where um the domestic violence
order has expired um the police
department is so honorous to get the
Firearms back to go through that process
and it cost so much but but it was
easier for them to go to a federal
licensed dealer and purchase a new
firearm and leave the firearm in the
possession of the police department took
about 10 years and finally the police
department reached out to him and says
are you ever going to come back and get
this firearm he goes I've already owned
like 16 of them so I don't need that one
back have you ever heard of that
happening absolutely a absolutely um and
but it's happened even more so because
the person doesn't want to go without a
gun in other other words I can't tell
you how naked I feel I've only went a
couple places where you know my guns
can't go with me and I felt naked and
exposed and whatever and so most people
the minute they're able to be able to
lawfully protect themselves again they
want to go get another firearm And when
they see it's going to be who knows when
they're going to get it back they're
like what the heck I me as well just go
buy another one because you know you
take two or three day I mean I've had
clients after initially try to get their
guns back but they take a half day off
work there's a cur fluffle at the court
so they've already lost that money and
they like wait a minute I've taken two
half days off work I still don't have my
guns back I may as well save my court
money and go buy a gun so yes no that's
sadly happened more than
once representative
fratt you answered my first question
about the cost there excessive cost uh
would that be the same if a person was
found not guilty we're talking about a
protective order expiring but if a
person went to court getting the guns
back after the
court sadly the process is the same same
yes thank you yeah representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question my question is going
to be if the expired order happens an
individual can purchase a new firearm
under both federal and state law what is
the purpose of the law or the history of
it that we passed to maintain the
firearm to have a separate hearing to go
before a judge and have an order issued
to return Firearms if they can just go
out and purchase new ones what are we
doing with this this
law I think it's horrible the way I
think the law state of the law right now
is horrible the way it is this bill
improves the horrible state of the law
quite a bit do I think the entire
process should be scrapped I
do but as I'm realistic politically and
realis
practically the best I can hope for at
this point is that you pass this bill
but but I agree with you that shouldn't
be the process I agree with you that we
have a protective order that ends I
should be able to go get my stuff the
stuff that I had to give to you I should
be able to just go pick it up but that's
you representative Su
Newman yes thank you
if I took my notes correctly you said 70
about 75% maybe a little more of
protective orders are granted yes yes
after and so I should be real clear
because probably members of the
committee don't understand something I
didn't explain something to you is that
initially the individual will go to the
court of the Police Department and ask
for a protective order to be issued
that's considered a temporary order and
then the person who the protective order
has been granted against has an
opportunity for a hearing and at that
hearing is where the um the numbers come
from the way I receive them in other
words that of the people who apply for
that initial order which is considered a
temporary order and then what we call a
permanent order which is the um one you
typically one year I've never seen them
issued for less than one year so 75% of
those who apply for that temporary they
become the permanent yes yes if I if I
could continue thank you for that but
the approximately 25% that are not do
not go through no weapons are taken or
dangerous devices are taken while those
are being considered to be dismissed I
guess no I should explain this to you
better um and I apologize for not being
clear because a lot of members of the
committee probably don't understand this
so I want to if I may just start from
the very beginning so let's say that
someone goes to the police department
person one and says and they call a
judge or magistrate get a protect
temporary protective order out what they
then do protective order against person
number two the police department where
person number two lives D literally
drives immediately to person number
two's house who the protective order is
against and they say Sir you've been
served with this protective order and
this is where some horrible abuse begins
and it's I'm really glad for your
question representative because it's
important is they say to the person do
you have firearms or you know weapons
that type of thing and they usually have
already asked the person who's protected
against what weapons they think they
have and if the person says yes I do
they say where are they at they will not
let you go back in your own house and
they'll tell you they'll arrest you if
you do they will go in and rumage
through your house and get all your guns
and all your ammo and anything else that
they think is in violation of it and
this becomes really problematic and I've
had this happen in many cases you'd be
surprised or maybe you wouldn't the
amount of adult people that still live
with their parents so let's say it's a
30-year-old adult man and he still lives
at his parents house and his mother and
father have their own guns the police
take every gun in that house every round
of ammo every everything even if the
parents the mother and father are
sitting right there saying this is our
house we can show you the property deed
he lives with us his driver's license is
here but these are our guns and our ammo
and this is his guns the answer is all
guns all guns all ammo are
taken and so while this temporary order
is pending all guns and ammo are not
only taken but he meaning the person who
the order is against cannot go by any
guns cannot possess guns cannot have
access to guns ammunition or ammunition
I components which is powder primer and
Brass he cannot go buy a gun now here is
the next problem technically he has a
right to a hearing 3 to 5 days as a
practical matter if he wants any type of
in my opinion unless they are lucky they
have time good attorney an attorney
who's going to prep the case he is going
to have to wave that timeline because if
Johnny Joe calls me tomorrow and says
I've got this protective order I first
have to read the order I have to meet
with him it depends on how long the
order is as to whether or not I'm going
to get a private investigator to go
check things out it depends on a lot of
specifics but I likely will not be able
to take that case and prepare to defend
him in that hearing for a month or two
so meanwhile we have to wave time limits
with the court in order to get a
continuance and he is living with that
protective order for probably 30 to 60
days now during this 30 or 60 days
there's some other things have to
understand that are in it if in fact
they were married he's obligated as I've
said to pay all these bills and continue
it if in like here they're separated or
they're they don't live together that's
something different but a lot of times
you even have people who were it's like
people who are attracted to stars who
think they have a relationship with
someone they don't and they file these
orders and that happens too so meanwhile
that person can't have any third- party
contact with the person there's all
sorts are rules and regulations and so I
have to tell all of their per my clients
I say you have to call all your friends
right now and I said you need to tell
every one of them do not call her cuz
the first thing their friends want to do
is call and say what are you doing he's
a great guy why would you do something
like this that's considered witness
tampering or intimidation and that can
get you some new charges so I tell them
make sure you call all your friends and
family and tell them do not call her do
not talk to her do not say anything to
her make sure you and this happened to
one of my clients make sure you lock her
on your phone because how many of us
have butt dialed people on cell phones
before probably all of us or purse
dialed if you accidentally dial their
phone number during that time period
that's a violation of the protective
order so so yes from the very beginning
and that person goes and makes a
complaint all their weapons are taken
from them
[Music]
see no further questions thank you thank
Kylie um good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee my name is
Pamela kyg and I the public policy
specialist at the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence um the Coalition is the
umbrella Organization for our state's 12
community- based crisis centers and we
serve nearly 14,000 victims and
survivors of Domestic and Sexual
Violence each year um I'm here in
opposition to HB 1337 legislation that
would change the process for how deadly
weapons will be returned to domestic
violence abusers um I think first and
foremost and I know you've heard this
from me before but this bill will place
victims at increased risk risk of
lethality domestic violence is the most
lethal crime in the state and more than
50% of homicides are the direct result
of domestic violence the majority of
these homicides are caused by Firearms
we know that domestic violence and
Firearms are a deadly combination a
victim of domestic violence is five
times more likely to be killed by their
abuser if there is a gun in the home
firearms in the hands of those who have
been violent increase the risk of lethal
outcomes and serious injuries not only
for the person who is protected by a
court order but also for the community
at large so this is really about Public
Safety at its core um this bill puts the
burden on a victim to further prevent
their abuser from accessing these deadly
weapons this can potentially put them in
more danger because they will have to go
before a judge just before the
protective order would expire um I want
to clarify some of the statistics that
were shared earlier today um according
to the most recent report from the
domestic violence fatality Review
Committee which I have a copy of the
report I can pass around um actually
only 40% of final protective orders were
granted between 2020 and 2021 and that's
they do it on a biannual basis so we
won't have the next report for another
year um so I think it's just really
important to clarify that there is a
very high bar um in order to get a
protective order they're not handed out
freely it is not 75%
um and so in order to be granted a
domestic violence protective order three
things need to be true there needs to be
a finding that the law has been broken
that domestic violence has been
committed and this is in a civil process
and not a criminal process um there
needs to be evidence that the victim is
in immediate danger and there is a
credible threat of further abuse so
there is a finding that harm and
violence has occurred um and so I think
that's really important to emphasize
here um and I think what's another just
um piece I want to highlight is that
this is really about prioritizing uh
victim safety in this process so we know
that Mo the most dangerous time for
victims is when they are trying to leave
an abusive situation and when a victim
seeks Relief by filing a protective
order the process can already place them
at risk it is not always safe to seek
relief via a protective order that is
something that needs to be taken with
utmost consideration for their safety
and whether or not this is the right
time time or if it could escalate
violence um this bill would only further
place them in an untenable situation in
domestic violence cases victims are
frequ frequently have to balance their
own safety with that of their children
and are constantly in fear of making
decisions that could further jeopardize
their life um when someone has
previously exhibited violent behavior
and been found by the courts to be a
safety risk why are we putting victims
in a more vulnerable and potentially
left threat threaten sorry I'm so sorry
threatening situation um and so again
like this is not the appropriate
approach um to address some of the the
issues that have been brought up today
when it comes to returning Firearms so
in conclusion HB 1337 is a nightmare for
victims and makes unnecessary and
potentially dangerous changes um to RSA
173b the Civil domestic violence statute
and intent which was intentionally
written to establish protections and
enshrine best practice IES when it comes
to responding to domestic violence in
New Hampshire and I urge you all to
you representive
jamman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for your testimony um
but it spurned a question in my mind um
if a
person has abused another person and the
protective order has been put in place
there has been a conviction of domestic
violence that person then under the
lottenberg amendment that was made many
years ago by a by a congressman or a
senator from uh Connecticut that person
is now a prohibited person they'll never
get their Farms back in their lifetime
so I'm I'm
curious
why if the if the You' be
opposed if if the domestic violence
order had has
expired for them to go through the riger
role and still not get the they will not
get their firearms back are you aware of
that um thank you for the question
representative um I'm not I think I'm
following I I would just say that this
bill just shifts the timeline in a
system that is already working just fine
there doesn't need to be a change to the
law and we have a concern that someone
would have to go before a judge to say
this person is dangerous
days before a a protective order could
expire which could trigger retaliation
from an abuser so it's it's more about
the timing and the safety risk that
could then come the we feel firmly that
the the statute is doing what it needs
to do and was intentionally um designed
thank
you thank you Mr chairman for the
followup and I don't mean to put you on
the spot um if the person that has been
abused even if there hasn't been a
conviction still believes that that
person is still a threat they have the
ability to go and renew that order
correct that is correct thank
you all right representative
s thank you and thank you for taking my
question I just want to clarify one of
the points you made about um the most
dangerous time might be just before a
victim of domestic violence is ready to
leave and I I'm not sure if you heard
about the incredibly tragic story out of
my town of Durham um where the news
broke yesterday where um the victim will
not be charged because she was acting in
self-defense um but that the
circumstances were that her
abuser um found her Escape Plan and
that's what triggered the final uh fatal
attack um I'm curious you know I mean
she she didn't have time to get to the
protective order stage but whether there
are other people who might be in a
situation um and how that might relate I
guess yeah no thank you so much for that
question I won't speak to the specific
case but I will speak to the pattern of
domestic violence so domestic violence
at its core is about power and control
and that is why um often times when
someone
realizes um realizes that um the victim
is trying to leave they're trying to
then find ways to exert power and
control and that can escalate violence
and I'd be happy to share additional
materials with you if that would be
helpful thank
you
representative
Newman thank you and this just relates
to the question of the previous
representative asked about the um a
prohibited person would have weapons and
would never get them back you you said
in order to get an order you need a
finding that criminal abuse has occurred
could you just explain what that means
yeah thank you so much for your question
uh representative so um RSA
173b um has uh the definition of abuse
and outlines the qualifications that you
need to meet in order to qualify for a
protective order there is an an an
numerated list um of other crimes like
animal cruelty um simple assault uh an
uh stocking and so on it's a long list
I'd be happy to share the statute with
you um and so when one of those things
occurs that is part of the protective
order thank you to be clear though abuse
does not not have to occur to get the
ordered only the threat of abuse can get
the ordered too is that correct um there
are some folks in the room that can
probably better explain the legal
process but the and I'm sorry I don't
have the exact definition in front of me
but it you have to demonstrate that
there is a credible present threat to
your safety um and that has to meet the
strict uh criteria in that list okay
thank you um representative Stone thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question so under a civil protective
order that is expired an individual is
no longer prohibited from purchasing a
new firearm or possessing a firearm
doesn't it make it a moot point to make
an additional process to go through
returning firearms that were previously
owned if they can go out by a brand new
one can I get back to you on that
question because I don't know the I'm
not a law enforcement officer so I don't
know the process around return of
firearms and um so I'd like to just look
a little bit more into that thank you
than
testimony chair calls
wher good afternoon Mr chairman and and
members of the committee I'll try to be
brief uh I'll start off by saying that I
agree with uh um attorney Dean's um
analysis of the situation um but I'd
like to add a couple of points um when
someone is and domestic violence order
has expired it hasn't been renewed it
hasn't been made permanent then there
should be a presumption of innocence so
it's my opinion this bill doesn't even
go far enough I support this bill but I
don't think it goes far enough I would
go um down to line
29 where it would put the put the burden
excuse me 21 put the burden on the court
the courot is the one that issued the
original domestic violence order put the
burden on the court like it says in line
21 to do the check to make sure that
that person hasn't robbed a bank in the
last year um that the prot protective
order was in effect and just have
languages says if there is no prohibitor
the court shall uh issu an order
returning the firearms and I understand
that the law enforcement has some some
issues they want someone else to make
this decision so there's no liability on
them so I think we could have an
agreement with law enforcement I think
they might agree with this approach by
putting this on the court the one that
made the order and the one that says NOP
we we checked your back around and you
get your Firearms um and and I would
suggest that you consider making this
bill um even better and and I kind of
resent the uh testimony of some others
who said whenever there's an order they
are still presuming that that person is
guilty and if the order isn't extended
they are no longer guilty they are
innocent so I would ask that you
construct this bill um with that in mind
maybe a few tweaks here and there be
happy to to work with you on that I
would also say this about the storage um
I don't support removing the liability
for for law enforcement from damaging
Firearms um in this legislation Firearms
are are not only a a defensive tool but
they are also an asset some of us buy
firearms because it's like putting money
in the bank when I graduated from high
school I bought a Colt Python paid $300
for it that Colt Python today is worth
$1,200 if it's in good condition so if
you remove the liability from police of
not keeping guns in good condition you
not only hurt the owner but I don't if
you remove that liability I don't think
the police will any longer inventory
those guns coming in and put a condition
on those guns coming coming in it's into
their best interest now on the way in to
say this gun's in good shape this gun's
in Fair shape just in a Layman's you
know view but if you remove their
liability for keeping these firearms in
good condition um I don't think there's
any incentive for them to keep them in
good condition think you need to keep
the incentives there so that's my two
cents on this
Bill thank you um I think you might be
mistaken I think that Python's probably
worth about $4,000 yeah it could be but
it's a little used now that being said
representative Jamber thank you Mr
chairman and thank you councelor for
taking my question um my question is is
a little bit semantic um if the bill
were to call for the State Police
gunline to have a report from the spots
computer system two or three days before
a DV order has expired that tells them
to go and run this guy a a gun check and
then notify the police department that's
holding the firms that the DV order has
expired he's passed a gun check give him
his guns back do you think that would be
workable yeah I but I think that the
burden should be on the court to go to
the gun line I mean obviously when
there's a protective order in place now
you become a pro prohibited person on
the gun line and um so there's a
mechanism now when you're not a
prohibited person to get off and there
are reports that come from the court um
and if my recollection serves me right
about 400 a year of of these type of
cases um and we have the statistics
which I don't have with me when those
requests come to the gun line for the
check you know the vast majority of them
fly right through uh as an innocent
person so um I think there is a
mechanism you know we could think that
through um but I think the burden should
be on the court to ask and I think there
should be some timelines you know on the
court they can't drag their feet
but also you know with my executive
branch hat on we're wasting a lot of
court time requiring hearings for all
this that that shouldn't happen we're
already short about seven Circuit Court
judges and you know we need to see if we
can find a way to get rid of some
unnecessary work so that the rest of the
swiftly thank you for your testimony
thank
brigh good afternoon uh for the record
my name is Bill brigh I'm a major with
the New Hampshire State Police um I just
I thank you for hearing my testimony
this afternoon I just want to say that
um when I signed in I signed in oppos to
this bill with the language that it it's
written as of now so um I think that
this the way the bill is written now it
shifts the burden to the victim to
request a hearing um which I don't
necessarily agree with um what uh
councelor wheeler suggested in this uh
the burden being shifted to the court uh
to come up with some sort of way to
determine whether or not they can issue
an order to return Firearms I think is
something that we can work with my my
suggestion would be to um give us a
little time to work on this bill to see
if there's some some middle ground that
we can come to on it um I think that the
suggestion that everybody that has a
protection order is in is innocent that
may not always be the case as you know
criminal cases have to be proven there's
a burden of proof that have to be that
has to be met in order to uh get a
conviction in those cases and that
that's not always possible even when
there are um even when abuse has taken
place and there may be many different
circumstances uh to come to that
conclusion um but I think that uh from a
law enforcement perspective um a court
order is necessary to return these
firearms because there has been a
determination made by the court that
there was a credible threat at whatever
point that was um so to put that burden
on law enforcement to say Hey you have
to give these guns back just because a
year passed I think that's a difficult
difficult place to put law enforcement
in um and and I just think that there
there's probably some common ground that
we can come to here um whether that's a
a hearing and I know additional hearings
can be burdensome to the court or if
there's some some process that can be
built here um so that there's some
protections for victims that they
they're not put in into a difficult
situation uh as this process goes on as
well as for those that are accused that
um if they truly are innocent that
they're not uh that they're able to get
their rights restored completely and for
law enforcement so that we're not put in
that difficult situation um to to make
that decision on our own without the
Court's input when the court has already
had input on this
process thank you um to be clear though
if if there is no order the orders have
been allowed to expire for whatever
reason and there's no conviction the
state police has no position on whether
or not the Firearms are returned it's
the question of the burden being on the
on the def or the the victim well the
way the way the law is now in order for
us to return Firearms there has to be a
court order right so whether the the
just because the protection order
expires we still don't return those
Firearms without a court order which is
why the requirement is is on the
defendant to request the hearing to get
that court order okay so if there were
an automatic mechanism that upon
expiration of the order um the court
were to issue an order to to return the
Firearms would that be sufficient so I
don't want to I don't want to commit at
the moment but we would certainly uh
look at the language and and help
develop some of that language um so we
could get it to a place where everybody
could work with okay all right thank you
M isn't part of the reason why a hearing
is is part of this process to determine
whether or not a creditable threat
remains that could be part of the
process and and this is this is what I'm
talking about maybe that still needs to
remain part of the process I'm not sure
I just know that there's a lot a lot at
stake if this bill um were to go through
the way it is right now I think it's
worth taking a deeper look at um I also
think that uh you know there's some
requirements for uh the checks through
the gun line and the criminal records
and and things like that that should
probably take place thank
you represent jamon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you major for taking
my question I'll try to speak up a bit
here
uh I I had said earlier to another
person that was testifying that if a
person had a DV order against them and
they Sur they surrendered their
firearms and in during that year period
they were convicted of a domestic
violence criminal statute then they
would become a prohibited person is that
your understanding as well I believe
that that the protection it could become
a permanent order uh for the protection
order and that uh there may be some some
things established with that conviction
that would uh prevent them from owning
Firearms yes followup thank you Mr
chairman and as a follow-up to that if
there has been no conviction of the um
criminal domestic violence which would
trigger the lottenberg uh Amendment and
the order has
expired um other than liability of the
police department that's holding the
Farms is there I I I understand you're
saying the court told us to take them we
want the court to tell tell us to give
them back is there anything on your end
that you would get a notice that this
this DV order is expiring do you get
that notice at any point I actually
don't have the answer to that um I don't
deal with these on a regular basis but I
I can find that out I'm not
sure
represent Stone thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my
question as I said before you probably
heard my last
question if we have no legal basis to
deny somebody's right to purchase a
firearm once the orders are expired what
legal basis do we have to retain their
property if it was seized other than the
current state law which might sound very
questionable to some of us on this
committee what the current state law
requires a court order to return the the
firearms and so that's the basis of of
my statement
so I guess that that is the basis of us
keeping those Firearms at that point I
don't want to keep somebody's firearms
that that we don't have a right to but
in that instance the court has
determined that we are supposed to take
their firearms I think it's reasonable
for the court to determine that we give
them back if I may just clarify I think
what we're we're all asking is if if the
orders expired and the person is not a
prohibited person and they can go to the
gun shop and buy a bunch of new guns why
make them go through the hoop of getting
the order and all that and you see what
I'm saying it seems it seems like it's
why do it if they can get them anyway
from they're not a prohibited person I
see what you're saying now I didn't
understand before um so I don't have a
good answer to that question
unfortunately can I have a quick
follow-up yeah go ahead is it more of an
administrative thing that there is no
mechanism currently in place that
notifies your agency that this person's
now orders are expired there's nothing
prohibiting from receiving the Firearms
is that the paperwork concern of your
agency is the liability aspect of
returning someone's firearm without
knowing what the stating in the court is
well I I don't want to speak to whether
there is a mechanism in place because
I'm just not sure that there is or not
to let us know that that court order is
expiring um there may be I'm not 100%
sure and there may be I'm sure that
there's somebody in the room that
probably knows the answer to that
question um and your the rest of your
question was just whether or not
um can you ask the question again Sor
basically I'm asking is it kind of a cya
thing to make sure that you're giving
the guns back legally to somebody yeah
so before we return any firearm in any
case I mean I think it's prudent to run
the the necessary checks to determine
whether or not that person can legally
have a firearm and that's that does take
thank you for your testimony thank you
Enders good afternoon my name is Stephen
andw I'm an assistant County attorney in
marac County I've been a prosecutor for
over 20 years um I I do disagree with
some of the wording in this bill and as
we just heard I think a court order is
is necessary really to return Firearms
when we talked about the process
earlier um as many people have said you
have to file a motion for return of
firearms it's a one-page form that you
fill out and I can certainly leave this
with the committee it's a standard court
form it's nothing uh honorous to fill
out it's nothing that really would
require an attorney to fill out it's my
understand understanding that there's no
filing fee associated with filing a
motion per return of firearms so there's
no cost in doing it in terms of time
frames there is a time frame in the
statute in RSA
173 B5 section Roman section 10A it says
you can file that form within 15 days of
the expiration of the protective
order and upon reing of such a motion
the court shall schedule the hearing no
later than 50
155 days after the expiration of the
order so this isn't a a case where you
know this lags on for six
months with reference
to you know the the the term innocent I
think that's certainly a loaded term um
while these people may not have been
committed of a crime there is a Judicial
finding that they present a credible
threat to the safety of an individual
and I think if the court makes the
finding that you present a credible
threat to the safety of an individual
and orders the police to seize your guns
it makes sense that the court should be
involved in returning those
Firearms so to me it makes sense that
you would need a court order the motion
simply triggers the court order it it
doesn't make sense for and the hearing
on that motion to return to Firearms is
very limited in scope again under 173 B5
Roman
10A there's two things which the court
can
consider the first thing is whether or
not the defendant is subject to any
state or federal law or court order that
prohibits them from possessing a firearm
and the second is whether the plff has
requested an extension of the protective
order so having the plaintiff start the
process to prevent the return of firearm
arms almost makes no sense to me because
the plff may say look I'm scared for my
life I'm not going to renew the
protective order but I'm very frightened
of this individual well the plaintiff
couldn't theoretically go to the hearing
and say that because that's not one of
the things the court is empowered to
consider when returning
firearms and I presume that the reason
the statute reads the way it does now is
to prevent essentially like a red flag
law situation where it's pretty black
and white if you're legally entitled to
possess your Firearms the
court returns your
Firearms
um with reference
to the uh striking of the fees and the
liability for the police
departments really that's a policy issue
for you guys to decide I as I said once
before I've never heard of fees being
being being charged again when you look
at the fees statute the police
department can't make money on that
essentially they can pass fees along if
they encounter fees and I can certainly
Envision a scenario where a person in a
small town um has a very large gun
collection and the police department
simply can't store it stores it with a
either a storage company or has to rent
a facility to do that and passes those
fees along to the person and I mean
really that's a public policy decision
whether those fees go to that person or
are spread among the uh the taxpayers in
the
community and it's really the same thing
with with immunity with reference to you
know some of the stories you hear about
evidence officers being unavailable or
taking time to return
Firearms this bill doesn't address that
and that's going to occur um you know no
matter what happens I I've told people
before I ended up having some of my
property in a Police Department property
Locker and I tried to get it back and
I'm the guy who writes the Motions for
the police department I'm on a firstname
basis with everyone in the police
department and it took me about two
weeks to try and get an appointment to
to get my property back because
everyone's busy and everyone has their
own schedules but I do think that um it
is essential to have a court order and I
would just note as well whenever the
police department obtains property and
we're not just talking about Firearms
we're talking about any property the
police department obtains there is a
statute under 595 A6 which sort of
defaults that the court should request a
that the I should say the police
department holds the property as the
court is directed so in order to get
property
returned I would seek a court order
almost no matter what that property is
so I don't think it's unusual to have
the the police you know request a court
order with reference to sort of the
two-part the the question of well if
this person can go out and buy a firearm
anyway what's the point of the police
department not returning their guns to
them I think there's a two-part answer
to that the first is how does the police
department know this person can go out
and purchase a firearm because I don't
think the police departments can run NX
checks on people who come in and say I'm
here to retrieve my
firearms the second part of that answer
is is liability and well you may say
well there's no real liability there
it's more than liability there's a
public perception if you went if if a
court made a finding that a person
presented a credible threat to the
safety of another so much so that the
court ordered that they relinquish their
firearms to say the conquered police
department and that person then went to
the conquered police department at the
expiration in that order picked up their
gun and went and used that gun to kill
their
victim I guarantee that it's going to be
all over not only the local news but the
national news that that person received
the gun from the conquered police
department and whether the conquered
Police Department had a legal obligation
to return the gun or not nobody wants
that exposure nobody wants to be on the
news for that
so we are always going to default to
wanting a court order I'm happy to
questions I I understand the the concern
but it seems to me that it could be much
more
streamlined if someone gets a temporary
order um based on allegations they make
we know that sometimes they don't follow
through and that order is allowed to
expire they just never come back for the
following hearing yeah so the the person
now has to incur the expense of going
through another hearing to get the
Firearms back that were taken that the
person never came through and followed
through with the order in the first
place it seems that it in the interest
of Justice it someone shouldn't have to
to go get their property back and pay
that kind of money if it could be more
streamlined um to it seems that to me if
it's not carried through and it's not
followed through on well again in order
to obtain a temporary order the plain if
needs to make a showing as well that
there is and it's actually in my opinion
a higher showing than a permanent order
which again makes sense because it's
granted on an xart day basis so the
plain if does have to make a showing of
abuse and um essentially
some some threat that uh they they
needed
immediately um so there is a finding
made with reference to whether or not
that person follows
through one of the things I can say is
that domestic violence is unlike any
other crime it's and it's very
frustrating as a prosecutor doing
domestic violence cases because I think
the national district attorneys
Association talks about 80% of victims
recanting and certainly that doesn't
mean it didn't happen it's that
victims's goals in domestic violence
cases
vary very differently than the normal
sort of crime victim if someone breaks
into your house you may want that person
punished you may want that person to go
to jail but with domestic violence
you're talking about a person who's an
intimate partner so most victims want
the abuse to stop and that's their main
goal and they may get a temporary order
and feel that the abuse has stopped and
there may be factors weighing in on them
to not get a permanent order and it's
not that it didn't happen it's that they
think that's the safest thing for them
to do at that point is not follow
through um so I don't think you should
read too far into a temporary order
being issued but then a victim perhaps
not following through with the process I
don't think that means that they're not
in in danger I don't think that means
that Firearms shouldn't have been seized
to begin with no I'm not saying they
shouldn't have been seized I'm just
curious as to whether or not you think
there's a way to streamline it so that
in the cases where the person could in
fact go buy more firearms that they
don't have to pay extra to go back and
to court again to get their property
back well and I think representative
Wheeler's suggestion um essentially that
the
court begin these
supon is is a possibility to streamline
that right now as I was saying you have
to file a motion to trigger the process
you could certainly have upon the
expiration of the protective order the
court triggers the process on its own
but I think that's a a a sizable burden
court um represent Pratt hold on we have
I'm
Rel yeah thanks for the question uh when
you go when a uh an honest person goes
to court to release their property back
after they've been not charged nothing
holding against them uh you recommend a
one-page form you recommend going to
court without a
lawyer I'm saying that the court has
created a onepage fill-in-the blank form
to streamline the process and make it
easier for people so you just fill that
out you don't have to go to court you
would fill this out file it with the
court and the court would give you a
hearing notice and then you'd show up at
the hearing and again there'd be two
things considered at the hearing the
first would be whether or not you're a
prohibited person which you could stand
there quietly and gunline is the one
that would have to say you're not a
prohibited
person um and whether or not the orders
being uh
extended okay I'm only aware of three
cases of this happening and uh every one
of them was multiple months multiple
dollars multiple legal fees more money
than the guns were worth in three
different cases that's problem I think
that's just of what we're talking about
today you also mentioned a police
department couldn't run the ncks check
why couldn't they before they released
the guns run Nick check I they're
prohibited by law from doing so really
they do it every day I was wondering why
they couldn't do it for that they can
run a criminal record check every day
but to run a a firearm specific the FBI
doesn't let them do that all right thank
you representative stong thank you thank
you for taking my
question would it be satisfactory if uh
like at a final hearing if the petition
was dropped or found not uh sustained
that there could be a simple box on the
form that could AOC or judicial Branch
could Implement to facilitate Firearms
being returned since all parties are at
that hearing or at least if the other
party didn't show at least some of you
appeared before the judge would that
satisfy the requirement in your mind for
at least though that portion of it I
think that there's sort of two parts to
that I think that you could check a box
to initiate the hearing but I still
think there should be a nck check prior
to returning the Firearms so I think
that those two considerations that are
currently in 173
B5 10A 1 and two the court should still
make those findings prior to issuing the
order to return
Firearms follow up so again it sounds to
me like the real issue is deferring the
liability onto the court from the agency
is that
correct I think having a court order
again is appropriate what triggers that
court order I don't know that I care but
I don't think it should be on the victim
to or the agency to return the Firearms
right safe answer thank you thank you
repr
scitech I have a question and a half um
I have an answer in a
quarter typical lawyer
now first part is this there's something
a little slippery in what you had said
earlier I'm not sure if it you you
buffed it out later but it sounded like
this I forget the context but it was um
but she's still
scared but she's not going to renew the
order now wait a minute if you if you
had the gumption to get the order in the
first place why isn't this order
continued it would seem that if the
facts circumstances have not materially
changed the it's would be an automatic
extension I want to talk about that that
particular part of what you said the
other thing is this and this the half
question because others have asked it
sounds to me that with a little bit of
Education you can do this
prosay if you're clean when it's uh
after the EXP expiration of the uh
order protective order there my I I'm
happy to answer your half question first
which I I think you can do it prosay um
again it's a pre-printed form that you
fill out you file it there's no fee you
go to the hearing there's two things to
be considered at the hearing I'm sure
you can find lawyers that are willing to
take your money to to do that just like
you know you can find lawyers to
represent you for a speeding ticket um
with reference to your first question
about why a person who is in fear for
their safety not renew a protective
order again my experience has been that
domestic violence is a very complex
thing and I've seen
victims act in ways that wouldn't
necessarily make sense to you or I but
certainly make sense to them in in the
circumstances um so I I do think you
have people who choose not to continue
secure thank you for your testimony
thank you and I'll leave that form with
you thank you is there anyone else
wishing to testifying this bill was not
turned into
card seeing none I here by close the
public hearing on House Bill 1337 and we
will be uh 10-minute recess before the
next
hearing no no no
no what lunch no no no time for
lunch um
15 I have to actually leave so I have to
introduce my bill and then you guys can
take
right
ladies and gentlemen before I open the
public hearing for House Bill
1711 first off I would just like to
thank everybody for their patience today
we are aware that we are running a
little bit behind we want to give
everybody the opportunity to speak
because that's what you came here to do
on this particular bill I will ask that
if we call your name to testify and what
you had planned on saying has already
been said please just let us know so we
can move on to the next person and I
would like to remind the members of the
committee that you will be recognized to
ask questions only please keep any of
your comments or lead in stories for the
executive
session with that being
said Mr chairman
I now opened the public hearing for
house B 1711 you're not going to bang
the hammer wow I just did it is heavy
okay thank you um my name is
representative Terry Roy I represent
Rockingham District 32 and I'm here to
introduce House Bill
1711 1711 um it the reason I brought
1711 in the first place as many of you
are aware there was a tragic uh killing
of a former police chief at the New
Hampshire hospital last year it came to
our attention that the person
responsible for that shooting had been a
previous patient of the hospital and had
had Firearms taken from them in the past
because of their mental illness they
should have never had Firearms after
that um we have there's a federal law
that says that if you have ever been uh
involuntarily commit committed or um
determined to be a mental defective
which is an ancient term in other words
mentally ill and dangerous you are
prohibited person from having firearms
in New Hampshire we have up until
2016 there was never a law that required
reporting of people who have been found
um or who have been involuntarily
committed because they were dangerous
reporting it to nxs to the FBI so that
they would be added to the list in 2016
uh representative J.R Hull from the New
Hampshire Firearms Coalition put a bill
in that said that no one could be
reported for being involuntarily
committed unless they had been first
deemed by a court to be dangerous and
there was a court order well that was
already law that you had to go before a
judge to be involuntary committed the
process to be involuntary committed
requires that you get an attorney if you
can't afford one one's given to you you
are allowed to cross-examine Witnesses
you are given Fue process before you are
involuntarily committed
if after that it's found that you are a
danger to yourself or others the court
will commit you involuntarily at that
point you are a prohibited person so
before um representative Hall put that
bill in in 2016 we didn't have anything
that mentioned involuntary commitment
and nicks together at that point the
Attorney General attempted to start
putting people on that list reporting
people unfortunately the Hampshire
Supreme Court found there was a conflict
in the laws where the involuntary
commitment statute um had
confidentiality in it that wouldn't
allow the two laws conflicted and they
said it was
unclear this law clarifies that what
this law does is it makes it so that if
you are involuntarily committed and
found dangerous because you can be
involuntary committed for other reasons
um besides being dangerous but if you're
found
dangerous you are going to have your
name put on that list now what's
important to understand is also in New
Hampshire prior to this if you're on
that list for a mental health reason
there's no way for you to get off ever
right now there's hundreds if not
thousands of citizens in New Hampshire
who cannot buy firearms because either
their doctor has reported them because
under RSA
332 I colon 2 a doctor can report you to
the Department of Safety if you are
speaking to your doctor and your doctor
says you say to your doctor I'm thinking
about killing someone or myself they can
report you and you'll end up on that
list and there's no way to get off the
ATF will not take anyone's name off of
that list unless the state has a law in
place that establishes how someone can
get their rights restored New Hampshire
has no such l no such program so anyone
who's a citizen of New Hampshire who
ends up on that list is there for life
regardless of whether or not their
mental health gets better so you could
be a college student and go through a
rough time you could uh lose a child and
you become despondent Anything could
happen and you have a rough period in
your life where you are endangered to
yourself for a short period of time and
you do need mental health and you end up
on that list you will be there for the
rest of your life if this law or
something like it does not pass because
there's no restoration process in New
Hampshire so what this law does it does
two things it fixes the Gap that was
created after um after representative
H's bill came in and said okay we'll
report to the Nicks and the court said
no you can't because of the confidential
now if this law passes people who are
involuntary committed their name will be
submitted to ni
and eventually if they get better they
can get their name off that list so it
does two things it it it fixes that hole
that was created and it also gives
people a way to get their rights back um
and it's it's incredibly complex I want
you to know that we we spoke to everyone
we spoke to the mental health
professionals we spoke to the Attorney
General's office who worked with us on
this we we went to um representatives of
the Court um any possible stakeholder
you can think of that I didn't talk to
I'd be shocked we talked to everyone um
and many of them here in the audience
today um if if their testimony is
necessary so with that I'm happy to take
any
questions representative
Muse thank you for taking my question
and thank you for partnering on the
bill um can you can you briefly run us
through the process for uh Firearms
restoration under the bill I can try um
so the ETF actually has a a form that
needs to that has a list of things that
have to happen for you to get your
rights restored one of them is that you
have to get a a a judge to say that you
are no longer a danger um an independent
medical
evaluation um as part of that it has to
it has to um be entered into the system
um I'm trying to think of what else was
on that
list
um you have to you have to get the
independent medical evaluation the judge
has to say that you're no longer a
danger and I believe if I'm missing
something else you have to help me out
but there there's a specific spefic list
of things at the ATF and what's
important to not in this bill is that I
put a mechanism in it that if the ATF
the ATF first has to approve our
restoration process so the bill
specifically says if the ATF doesn't
first approve the restoration process no
one no one's name goes on the list so
we're we're not putting the cart before
the horse if no one can get off the list
no one goes on the list so the first
obligation is going to be on the
Attorney General's office to get that
process approved by the ATF once they
say your process to get people's rights
restored is okay then people's names can
start being reported first that has to
happen and um I apologize if I missed
several followup I I think the point was
just to have people hear that there
there is a process um and that one of
the one of the things that this does
open the door to is new sure actually
being able to get funds from the federal
government because we do have things
like the relief from disability process
yeah that's that's true the the federal
government up to right as far as um
reporting goes the federal government
makes funds available to states to help
with their Nick system if they report
people according to the federal
government's wishes well we haven't been
reporting people so we haven't had the
ability to get those funds to help with
our Nick system by reporting and having
the way for people to get off that makes
us now eligible to get funds from the
federal government to help pay for our
system so that's also a key important
part not the driving one but it's a side
bonus that we will be able to get those
now any further
questions thank you very much chairman
Hannon good good afternoon members of
the committee allow me to correct myself
honorable Dr Hannon don't it's okay
Joe's fine thanks um I'm here uh
speaking on behalf of governors of New
Hampshire and uh we're in opposition to
uh this bill as written um there's a few
reasons um I I understand the intent and
um naming the the bill it's it's I
understand this this man was a hero uh
nothing against him I think he was uh
doing an amazing job in horrible
circumstance uh he was an unarmed
individual whose job was to stop
potentially armed people from entering a
secure facility I think that's one of
the the most important aspects we have
to look at uh when looking at this
specific incidents um we have too many
dead heroes and I think we need to do
things that prevent that from happening
people should be allowed to defend
themselves if they're charged with uh
doing something such as this
um a few other things um you know we I I
appreciate uh representative Roy talking
about uh this is only for people who
have been adjudicated uh and considered
a potential dangerous danger to
themselves or others uh but if you look
at the list uh on page where is it on um
line 24 on page one uh adjudicated is
not guilty of a crime by reason of
Insanity well the person could be
temporarily insane but their deprivation
of rights are permanent at that point
and we know that um this is something
that's extremely hard to to undo the be
adjudicated and incompetent toand trial
and Fel found by the court to be a
danger to themselves or others that's
sounds nice but then C involuntarily
committed to a mental facility pursuant
to RSA 135 c34 through
54 um and in New Hampshire the
involuntary treatment standard the
standard to be used by a court physici
or psychiatrist in determining whether a
person should be admitted to a receiving
facility for treatment on an
involuntarily basis shall be whether the
person is in such mental condition as a
result of mental illness as to create
the potentially serious likelihood of
danger to the themselves themselves or
other to others um this person may not
have committed any crime they may not
have actually said they're going to hurt
themselves the standard is is different
for criminal prosecutions and
deprivation of rights as it is for
people that are having their rights
deprived under these statutes and I
think that's something that needs to be
considered there could be someone an
individual who is uh young person or or
even an older person who was uh
involuntarily committed uh because of
bulimia uh because of substance use
disorder as a you know as a teenager all
kinds of things um postpartum depression
uh these are things that are temporary
that could lead to a a commitment order
and under uh section c that I just
mentioned into voluntary commitment that
person would not be able to um to
correct that very easily and it's we
know we've heard for other other
testimony and different bills that it's
a very expensive and costly process even
if the state does get money the
individuals don't get money to hire
lawyers that money goes to the state um
just a couple of real brief things um
you know there were many reasons and I I
I don't want to dwell on the fact that
this person was unarmed uh defending
these uh these people this in this
manner but um the person who committed
the crime was we we heard that he was um
guilty of many other things committed
before and uh was charges were dismissed
from um probably to competency concerns
but they also had protection orders and
their firearms not exactly sure the
details may have been taken in the past
how did they get them back is a question
I have to ask and even if charges were
dropped why was there no protective
order there was an inquiry made I think
by the media uh not not long after this
to see what the uh court order was and
it wasn't released by the court so we
don't know if there was a protective
order should there have been that could
have been enough to prevent that person
from obtaining Firearms through a legal
means nothing would prevent someone from
obtaining them through an illegal means
or committing harm to themselves or
others through any number of other
deadly and dangerous uh means so um I I
just ask that um you know we take into
consideration uh the the words of
William Blackstone um it's better the 10
guilty persons Escape then that one
innocent person suffer you know it may
if it may catch somebody but we're
stigmatizing and we're criminalizing by
depriving people of their civil rights
just by the fact that they have a mental
illness in in a lot of cases and I think
that's wrong wrong um I I I'm happy to
continue this conversation with the
sponsors and see if there's any anything
that uh could be done in the future but
uh as it stands I think this needs to be
ited um
and oh the other thing it's a minor
issue but it's significant to those
officers we're also ordering Court
officers to go and take the firearms
from a person who has this order uh that
potentially puts the officers in danger
which is part of their job I understand
and they they knowingly do their job
well and bravely but it also puts the
person who they're taking the firearms
from in danger you know what if the
person comes to the door with a phone in
their hand and they think oh he he
that's his gun and they just shoot him
these things have happened we've seen it
in the media we've seen it in the news
and I don't want to put not just the
officers at risk but the individuals who
are potentially being victimized by
having their rights deprived uh through
through these means i' be happy to take
any
questions thank you very much there
there any
questions I'm seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh members chairman Roy
has an amendment for this bill that is
here uh that I didn't know so I'm going
to pass this out I'm just going to
you
one
Karen
Rosenberg would it be possible to grab a
extras sure let's just see how many we
have Brad do you have any down
there would you mind doing that for us
please that'd be helpful thank you thank
thank
you so we are going to get a couple some
copies of the amendment that we will
have at the back table working on that
else okay we can at least we can at
least put those ones over so people can
have
it thank you representative all right we
all set thank you okay thank you for
your patience oh that's okay thank you
my name is Karen Rosenberg I'm the
policy director for the disability
rights Center where the state's
protection and advocacy system for
people with disabilities and our charge
is to protect and advocate for the
rights of people with
disabilities um so this is a
challenging um bill for our office
frankly because it does represent a
departure from some privacy protections
that were afforded to people with
disabilities um and also it involves
potentially removing rights that people
all people are guaranteed under our US
Constitution that said um with the
amendment which I'm hoping it looks like
what I think it's going to look like I
think it's something that our office
would not oppose um and I want to um
talk about the amendment and what um my
understanding is about assuming it says
what I think it says um the concerns
that IT addresses that um I reached out
to a couple of you about so this the
some of the concerns my office have has
involve privacy and confidentiality of
mental health
records um and the other issue we have
has to do with um how traumatic
confiscation of weapons could be
following an order of dangerousness and
an order that someone surrender or have
their guns their their firearms removed
um um and then because that could happen
very quickly under the bill is
introduced and the person could be
hospitalized and come home to a home
that was broken into and thirdly our
concern has to do with the time frame
and process that someone would follow
when they're no longer posing a danger
they're no longer committed and how long
they might have to wait for restoration
of their rights so I'm going to try to
multitask here and and read and explain
um how I'm hoping that this amendment
addresses those
concerns so in the bill as
introduced there's a provision that has
to do with what information is
communicated to Nyx once the person has
been involuntarily committed or you know
Falls within this perview of what this
bill is trying to address so what it
says right now is um and this is on page
to I think it's line 10 it allows for
the reporting of the person name an
identifier signifying what the
prohibition the applicable prohibition
is for them to own firearms as well as
any non-clinical identifying information
that gives me pause because what is that
um it NX there's as my understanding is
that NYX only requires certain
information does require the name of the
person does require the applicable
provision that would prohibit them from
owning or possessing firearms it does
include their social security number I
think and even their date of birth but
nothing else so I think it would be I'm
hoping that this amendment does actually
remove like remove that um sort of
nebulous additional phrase from the bill
so that we're not you know opening the
doors here to certain other confidential
information being
available so hopefully that does that um
secondly with regard to a person for who
is involuntarily committed so what the
bill provides for is for a court to have
the authority to then order that the if
that per to inquire about whether that
person actually owns or has access to
firearms and then to subsequently order
that if they do that those Firearms be
seized within 48
hours so as I alluded to earlier while
that might be a reasonable that that
could be a reasonable order that the
court might make um it would be
incredibly difficult as a person who's
now in the you know in a mental health
crisis getting hospitalized stuck at a
hospital involuntarily to then be
released come home and their house has
been broken into and their stuff has
been gone through and you know who knows
what kind of state it would be in so
what um I suggested to um representative
Roy and I hope it's in here forgive me
um I'm not a power speed reader is an
opport is are two things one is a
requirement that at the hearing that the
judge would inform the person of this
possibility so even before issuing it's
there thank you representative Murray
even before issuing an order um you know
determining whether the person ought to
be involuntarily committed and whether
you know therefore they might be
required to turn over their firearms
that the person's put on notice
that you know this is this is a likely
outcome this is this is a possible
outcome I could order I found the judge
could order that your AR Firearms be
confiscated but you um have an
opportunity if you want to Avail
yourself of it to make other
arrangements and in that process
actually so that person will be
represented they have a right to counsel
in involuntary commitment proceedings so
or even if they are you know if they've
entered this this realm through the
criminal justice system they also have
have a right to counsel so their Council
can work with them and talk them through
what their options are and provide them
with an opportunity to make other
arrangements to avoid having their homes
broken
into the thing what kind of flows from
that also is that if the court does in
fact rule that they ought to be
involuntarily committed and that their
firearms that they should not have
access to fire Firearms I it just sort
of neatens things up a little bit to
provide these several options that the
person would have
so the court could order them to
surrender their firearms in accordance
with the um Arrangements they've made
the court could order that they deliver
their firearms to an authorized person
this is already in the bill it just kind
of sets it out more clearly so an
authorized person to who doesn't live
with them to hold on to those or if or
could order the police to come and seize
the Firearms within 48 hours if no
suitable Arrangements have been made so
so it retains that possibility but it
provides a little bit more opportunity
for someone to have control over how
they choose to dispose of or store their
firearms um the third concern had to for
my office had to do with the time frame
for being able to just petition the
court for restoration so remembering
that it's the court that is going to
ultimately decide whether the person in
this predicament or this situation is
going to get their firearms back or
their ability to own firearms back and
what this does is say if you if the
person obtains an absolute discharge and
I'm going to tell you a little bit more
about that um then within they have to
wait another 15 days but then they can
petition the court for permission to
have that right restored now if they do
that the court then is going to have to
order they're going to have to submit to
a mental health evaluation also so so
it's not
like you there are other processes in
place um that mental health evaluation
is in the current version of this bill
um but just one thing that's really
important for you all to know if you're
not intimately involved with the mental
health system in this state is that when
people are involuntarily committed to
the mental health system and they are at
New Hampshire hospital they may be
released conditionally and actually that
happens quite frequently so they are
stabilized they are to return to their
communities but they're not really
officially discharged from the hospital
they are conditionally discharged
conditions typically being that they
comply with treatment recommendations or
orders actually in this case right so
it's generally being connecting with
their local Community Mental Health
Center participating in treatment with a
therapist taking um usually taking some
medication those are very common
requirements and if the person doesn't
comply with those requirements they can
be hauled back to the hospital the other
thing that's really important to know is
that when people are determined when
it's when it's determined appropriate to
involuntarily commit someone to the
State Mental Health System and to the
hospital this these commitment orders
can be for up to five years and they're
I I I've never seen one less than a year
I mean and they get renewed so what
happens is you know someone is
essentially not really discharged when
they are physically allowed to return
home and an absolute discharge happens
when that person has demonstrated that
they've successfully engaged with the
mental health system they've
demonstrated that they are taking their
medications or and they no longer
present a danger that's when they get an
absolute discharge for that reason it
seemed really discriminatory to you know
prolong the time period even further for
which some someone could be just even
eligible to petition
for restoration of their rights and so
um that's why the amendment shrinks that
down to 15 days um it also there's
another little adjustment that reflects
current practice which is that generally
in these involuntarily involuntary
commitment cases when there's an
evaluation ordered and there are always
evaluations ordered independent
evaluations the court has a panel of
Psych christs that do these evaluations
and courts generally order these
evaluations and then arrange for them to
happen so that's just a small adjustment
to reflect what current practice is and
then as after Consulting with Dr feder
Who's the chief medical um director at
the state hospital and also with one of
the attorneys I know who represents
people in involuntary commitment cases
what I learned is that generally these
evaluations are scheduled pretty quickly
usually within 15 days so the bill
right now provides for 45 days which is
retained but the the the technical
adjustment is and this is in line with I
believe what Dr feder had in mind and I
think he will confirm this I hope is
that the thinking was that these
evaluations would be completed within 45
days not just scheduled within 45 days
so that's the small Tinker about the
timing and then the other um timing that
I inserted or well hopefully will
insert that's in this amendment is to
also create a time frame for these
hearings to occur because you know like
I said someone could be unconditional
discharg for years and years and now
they're absolutely discharged how long
is it reasonable to prolong you know
their opportunity to have their day in
court and so what this would do would
say Okay 15 days you file your petition
45 days later you have you know you've
had your evaluation ation is reported
and 15 days after the completion of the
evaluation is when the court would
schedule a hearing So within 60 days the
court schedules the hearing it seems
fair because you've already waited a
pretty long time to have your day in
court and you'll have an opportunity to
review the results of the evaluation the
last thing it does is it maintains a
provision that generally if the person
loses theyve filed their petition they
lose generally they would have to wait
two more years to file again but what
this does is it inserts some um it it
basically puts some discretion on the
part of the court if there's a
compelling reason why the person ought
to be afforded an earlier opportunity to
petition again the court would have that
authority to Grant it and that could
come up in a situation where someone's
situation changes like maybe their
behavior was attributable to a brain
tumor that you know was operable and and
and that's why they behave the way they
did and ended up in the hospital you
know so it just basically gives some
discretion to the court it doesn't
require them to do anything so I think
that explains everything that's in here
and please ask
questions thank you very much that's
there is a lot to take in here uh
representative wheeler thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my question I
actually have a really simple question
and it's just I can't write as fast as I
would like to and I didn't get what
organization you work oh sorry I'm with
the disability rights Center of New
Hampshire thank you very much and thank
you work that you're doing that was a
Muse and I wanted to thank you for your
uh for your input uh both before uh and
after the hearing
um I wanted to one of the things that I
I I wanted to try to get into a little
bit because it's it's we we it in a
hearing like like this we get so mucked
up in the details but why why is it
important that we we're paying as much
attention as we're paying in the in this
bill and in this process um to the
people who the bill would actually
prohibit from from possessing firearms I
we kind of an inelegant way of of asking
but um
why why is this why is what we're doing
here by by creating this amendment by
making sure we get these processes right
what what are we accomplishing for
people I I think that what we need to
recognize is
that people with mental illness ought
not to be stigmatized unnecessarily or
discriminated against in terms of their
access to and ability to enjoy the same
civil rights that everybody else can
enjoy and and and I think that's what's
the and that's why it's important to get
this right and pay attention to those
people because we as a society often
look upon someone who has experienced a
mental health crisis or experiences
mental illness as less than and less
entitled to the same lives that the you
know that are enshrined in our
constitution ution and that's
wrong and and that's why we ought to
care about making sure that you know yes
if someone is dangerous and they are
actively dangerous and actively posing a
risk we have a mechanism to to respond
to that and can make a rational and
decisions might be made that are that
that are that we do this with people who
are felons right courts will if you
convict you know committed a a violent
crime and you're a felon a court will
remove your right to possess Firearms
you will because of
dangerousness and I think that it's a
mistake to assume that just because
someone has a mental illness that they
are dangerous it's an assumption that's
really
unfair thank you thanks representative
n thank you Mrs chair and thank you for
taking my
question as the um I think I said Miss
anyway
um Madam Madam chair um my question is
around confidentiality and especially
when we're we're discussing the
stigmatization and of course we don't
want to put anyone in that position I
appreciate that you're here to to Really
um guide us and help us make sure that
we do the best we can for uh people with
disabilities my question is um in to
your understanding having worked with
the sponsors to to bring forth this
amendment um when it is reported if if
someone uh goes to purchase a a weapon
and then they cannot because of a
situation like this does the Privacy
provide for um that information not to
be conveyed to the person that they're
trying to to purchase a weapon from the
the reason so my understand I have I've
had zero personal experience with NYX
but my understanding from people who
know more than I is that when someone
goes to purchase the firearm and if they
are on the nck list the deal the um the
licensed Firearms dealer would get a
notification that they are not eligible
to purchase the firearm I don't think
that they would receive information
about the reason why thank you you are
correct
pH representative celik thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question I I just want to clarify you
made a reference um a few moments ago to
withholding weapons from convicted
felons you are not equating people with
mental illness you sure to make a
distinction between those two I just oh
my goodness no I oh thank you no I
didn't mean to do that at all I think
what I'm trying to say is that courts
know how to remove you know weapons from
people who are dangerous and I
understand how that might be necessary
at times and I just use that as you know
an example okay and can we ask a quick
followup and and people with mental
health illnesses can presumably recover
yes oh oh thank you for asking that
question yes all the time people with
mental illness can recover fully can
also you know if if it's more of a
chronic nature can manage their symptoms
with medication and treatment I mean
time seeing no further questions thank
you Victoria
Sullivan had to leave
she
right
burrow um I I am I am for this bill uh
if you could just let just state your
name I know I did Steven buau
representing myself
um I think there should be other
amendments uh to this bill uh because
there's people that are having
adjudicated or committed mental
defective added to their next background
check um but were never found
incompetent never um found to be a
danger to themselves or others and were
never involuntarily
committed but yet they have adjudicated
or committed mental defective on their
record where it doesn't apply and
there's no way to remedy that and that's
denied because of you know such a a
finding on their record there should be
justification for that information to be
there and I'll I'll give you a couple
instances there's a person who was
denied a permit to
carry they actually received the federal
background check which they're not
supposed to receive that's not supposed
to be copied or disseminated to anybody
including who the check is done on
however the the Nicks background check
came back with adjudicated committed uh
adjudicated committed mental
defective and it showed the uh the court
the case number the charge ID and when
that information was
referenced looking at the case summary
it showed that that person had the
charge dismissed there was never a
question of competence there was never a
finding of
dangerousness the person was never
involuntarily committed or had any other
prohibiting factors but yet had
adjudicated committed or adjudicated or
committed mental defective on their
record how's that person supposed to
have that removed from their record it
it should have never been there to begin
with so I think there should be
amendments in this bill for people
who have false information added to
their next background check to have that
removed and they shouldn't have to jump
through all the Hoops if if that
information is false and it shouldn't be
on the record a person shouldn't have to
go through a trial in court and then an
evaluation to prove
that they're competent there was never a
proper finding for that to be there
another
instance
um a person had another court case
the charge was
dismissed the person was allegedly found
incompetent to stand trial but not a
danger to themselves or
others they were never involuntarily
committed and in fact that person turned
around had that charge
annulled once something's an olded the
person is to be treated as if that
arrest has never taken place but the
state turned around went to the court
wound up getting access to anold records
non-conviction
one of getting access to sealed
documents pertaining to an a
evaluation the state turned around and
then had adjudicated or committed mental
record there's no finding of
dangerousness the person was never
committed to a mental institution and
didn't have any other prohibiting
and the question of competence is being
much there was a case in I believe it
was 2007 in the New Hampshire Supreme
Court um the state of New Hampshire vers
Scott
Buchanan and the Supreme Court made it
perfectly clear
that incompetent to stand trial cannot
be equated with adjudicated or committed
mental defective there has to be the
dangerousness the state continues to
equate incompetent to stand trial
regardless of if you were found not to
be a danger to yourself or others or
even involuntarily committed the state
is still equating incompetent to stand
trial with adjudicated committed mental
defective and having that placed on
people's background check denying them
their constitutional
rights
now in order for a person if a person
was found adjudicated or committed
mental defective pertaining to a um
criminal case that person wouldn't be
annulled
um another thing is if there's a
question of
competence that denies a person the
right to file suit against
say the police if it was an unlawful
arrest on false charges and the person
had their rights
violated that person no longer can file
suit in the United States District Court
uh under section 1983 for rights
violations it deprives them of that
right now there's another instance where
a person had a criminal case they
represented themselves if there's a
question of competence
a person cannot represent themselves
even if it's a Class B misdemeanor and
they typically wouldn't be
afforded uh appointment of councel if
there's a question of competence raised
not only is the judge
obligated to file for
evaluation but that person
can't represent
themselves but on a criminal case where
an individual represented
themselves there was no question of
competence there was no
finding um M Mr bur if I if I could
just are you speaking on House Bill 1711
or
dis now on on that on that case a person
represented themselves and there was an
alleged finding of incompetent to stand
dangerous what's to stop the state from
taking that and placing incompetent to
stand trial on that person's record
there was another case where and the
question of competence only pertains to
criminal
cases but yet there there's a case where
an individual had a speeding ticket
represented themselves and the judge
dismissed the the uh speeding ticket
claiming that the defendant was
incompetent to stand
trial that doesn't make any sense what's
to stop the state from taking that
incompetent to stand trial even though
it doesn't apply to such a case and the
person is not a danger to the themselves
or others was to stop the state from
adding adjudicated or committed mental
defective to that person's record so
there should be some sort of remedy for
people who have had adjudicated or
committed mental defective added to
their record
but that's incorrect it doesn't even
apply to
them so that so I'm just asking that
there be some other amendments made to
this so that people who have had
adjudicated or committed mental
defective to their record and it does
not
apply there should be some remedy that
or process that a person can go through
and have that false information
removed I I I just I I think some I I
think there's parts of the system that
are being abused and people are being
denied their rights and
privileges so I don't know if there's
any questions we'll find out for
you Representative
no um if I and remembering from um what
chairman Roy introduced in the beginning
he what he was talking about one of the
things benefits of this bill was that it
did allow for someone to adjudicate and
be removed from it if it were a
temporary situation so if that is indeed
the case is are you in support of this
bill I'm I'm sorry I'm I'm I'm it it
sounds to me um like you are you're
discussing uh your concern is around uh
whether someone can be removed and if
there is a process for someone to be
removed from that and then and therefore
restore their right um to possess
Firearms so my my question is if that is
provided for in this Bill a remedy and a
process uh for that to be adjudicated
are you in support of the rest of the
bill yeah absolutely but the the but
what the bill covers is for people who
have been through a legitimate
process and been found incompetent to
stand trial and dangerous to themselves
or others which would fit the criteria
for involuntary
commitment but if a person hasn't been
found to be a danger to themselves or
others nor have they been involuntarily
committed then it shouldn't be on the
record only a person who's been through
the process and had a finding of
incompetent and dangerous to themselves
or others or has been involuntarily
committed or others other things that
are that are covered it only applies to
them it doesn't apply to people who have
had the information falsely placed on
the record where it doesn't apply
because then that person who's had the
information added to their record
falsely would also have to go through
the same process which means they'd have
to go to court they'd have to be
evaluated and a person who has
never you know what I mean if the
information isn't correct a person
shouldn't have to go through an
evaluation and this and that because it
it never applied to begin with okay
thank you thank
you know
that all right thank you very
simkin good afternoon Madame chairwoman
and members of the committee thank you
for giving an giving me an opportunity
to
testify um I make it my mission when I
testify to bring information that I'm
fairly certain will not otherwise reach
you um in the interest of full
disclosure I'm a federal firearms LIC e
and have been so for a tad over 40 years
agency I want to again repeat a
foundational fact which often is
overlooked or not known at all which is
as that end
2022 there were approximately 474
million firearms in the United States
these are firearms made
after one on or after 1 January 1898 to
present their various
exclusions and I could list them if you
wish anything so numerous cannot be
controlled everyone here seems to assume
that someone who is prohibited has to go
to a dealer to get a firearm this is
simply wrong criminals own and rent or
sell firearms people can borrow firearms
from Neighbors so the notion that oh
we're going to enact this and it's going
to stop those who
are mentally defective Ive and dangerous
from getting Firearms this is simply
Pulp Fiction it will stop some of them
but it will not stop all of them now to
come to the specifics of this bill and I
testimony this bill if
enacted in effect in fact will ensure
that those who have a spell of mental
distress forever lose their right to be
armed the bill should be subtitled the
roach motel gun control
Bill and it should as it is and even as
amended should be voted in expedient to
legislate the Bill's proponent set forth
ways for a person who has been
involuntarily committed
to regain their civil right to be armed
but those pathways are a fiction they're
a a fiction because a person who has
been involuntarily committed cannot
choose his or her own attorney and key
Point follows and they cannot have that
attorney's fees and costs reimbursed
from taxpayer funds at that attorney's
normal hourly rate so
basically once someone has been
involuntarily
committed they are in the road Motel
they check in they can never check out
testimony I will actually direct you to
the website for this Black Flag product
1981 the idea here that a court or a
doctor is going to make a finding that
an adjudicated person has regained
mental health and is eligible to own
firearms I suspect this Pulp
Fiction uh those of you with long
memories may recall that in the 1988
presidential
campaign much was made of the fact that
a Massachusetts governor had granted a
Furlow to a convicted
murderer and while this convicted
murderer was furloughed from prison he
crimes the idea that a public official
whether a judge or a doctor is going to
put their good name and their financial
well-being on the line by certifying
that someone is cured it may happen I
don't think it happens
often um why do I come to this
conclusion well here in New Hampshire
since
1996 pardons have been few likely fewer
than five so few I can't find
any official data so if the governor or
the governors of New Hampshire have not
been willing to Grant pardons very
often why would one think that other
pardon I I'm deeply skeptical of
that the other
issue that I think is not well
understood has to do with the costs of
litigating with a
state I have some relevant
experience this is a Massachusetts
temporary non-resident license to carry
its
predecessor was revoked wrongly in
2009 I spent about
$125,000 to recoup the license which I
did by virtue of the unanimous decision
in order and Order of the Supreme
Judicial Court of
Massachusetts in
mid3 the cost would have been far higher
had I not done most of the law and
legislative history research so the idea
that a person who has been a adjudicated
can
somehow handle this on their you know on
their own
resources it may be occasionally
true um but I think that would be by far
the exception that proves the
rule
further there's another assumption
behind this bill that I believe is
factually
wrong and that error will have
catastrophic
consequences one once a person's name is
put into the federal FBI Nicks databases
as having been adjudicated New Hampshire
has no way to compel the federal
authorities to recognize any restoration
of their civil right to be armed I
understand in the bill there's this
provision we'll make a deal with ATF but
ATF can change its mind and it does for
example there was Circa 1990 a type of
shotgun that was fed by a 12 round
revolving cylinder so each shot the
cylinder just like a a revolver and a
handgun ATF allowed it to be sold then
ATF said wait a minute there's no quote
sporting purpose end quote for such a
shotgun we are going to reclassify it as
a destructive device so every time that
it changes hands a $200 tax has to be
paid
ATF can change its mind it did and I can
prove it and they
wouldn't argue with me fast forward
you've probably heard about arm braces
being used on certain types of pistols
ATF initially said no problem then they
said no we think putting one of these
onto certain pistols makes a short
barrel rifle then they went back to
saying well maybe they are permissible
under certain circumstan an es so the
notion that a deal that you make or that
the Attorney General makes with ATF is
set in
stone sorry representative is
wrong
um this isn't
theoretical uh as a non- attorney
representative I appeared before the New
Hampshire Supreme Court on behalf of a
friend
who a dozen years before had acquired a
simple oui conviction in Massachusetts
that made him a prohibited person under
federal
law he went before a specifically
created Massachusetts entity called the
Firearms licensing review board which
found that he had changed his ways and
they gave him a letter so
stating in due course he moved to New
Hampshire he being an honorably
discharged veter
Army decided he wanted to work as an
armed security guard he applied for that
license to Department of Safety
disclosed his oui conviction Mr simpin
if you if you could please stick to
exact I am I am right on Madam chairman
I am right on target so I'll sum it up
really quickly thank
you even though he was totally honest
with Department of Safety they revoked
his license he sued food they restored
it then after that safety probably the
behest of the US Bureau of Alcohol
Tobacco firearms and explosives again
revoke the
license on the basis that the department
didn't want its employees to
risk being prosecuted for issuing a
license to a person whom the
feds considered to be
prohibited now this matter ended up
litig litigated before the New Hampshire
Supreme Court that found that
Massachusetts had restored a civil right
to be armed and his armed guard security
license was given back to him I know
because I wrote his brief and was before
the court to make his
case key
point the feds do not have to accept
anything that New Hampshire does the
Attorney General of New Hampshire tried
to get the US Supreme Court to
overturn the New Hampshire Supreme
Court's decision restoring his license
the US Supreme Court denied the petition
for
curari why that was done I have no
clue
so any
enactment that relies on the feds
respecting what you enact here is based
on error and this bill is so based and
it should be deemed inexpedient to
legislate um for those who are skeptical
I attach a copy of a letter to the
attorney general from the then acting us
attorney for New Hampshire providing
immunity to State officials who would
act to restore this gentleman's revoked
license but he and we're now 10 years
down the road still will not go to a
licy to acquire a firearm for fear that
the feds still deem him
prohibited he will be denied and then he
will have committed a felony because the
feds will argue you knew you were denied
and that we paid no attention to what
the US to what the New Hampshire Supreme
Court
decided
I will cheerfully answer questions on
related thank you very much um one final
point if very quickly if there's anyone
here who knows who ordained that Chief
much
Dr
Hank I don't think chairman Roy would
be good
afternoon my name is Dr John Hank and
I'm representing the New Hampshire
Psychiatric Society and the New
Hampshire Medical
Society both societies strongly report
Bill
1711 as an important legislation to
reduce the public safety problems of gun
violence and
suicide I have worked as a psychiatrist
at New Hampshire hospital over the past
29 years and I was working at New
Hampshire hospital on November
17th when gunshots were heard in our
lobby all the paat patients and staff
had to shelter in
place because an active shooter was in
our
building only later I found out that
security
officer Bradley hos had died
heroically while protecting all the
patients and staff at New Hampshire
hospital when I first started working at
New Hampshire hospital I thought that
individuals who were committed because
were danger to themselves or others were
being reported to a background check
system to prevent them from purchasing
or possessing
firearms I thought New Hampshire was
complying with the federal Brady
Law eventually I found out that New
Hampshire was not complying with this
federal law and this has resulted in an
unsafe Public Safety
situation House Bill 7
1711 is a solution to this
problem the American Psychiatric
association has called for
legislation to utilize background checks
as a way to reduce gun violence and
promote Public
Safety Research on background checks
suggests that denying firearm purchase
to individuals legally prohibited from
gun ownership leads to reduction in the
risk of
violence among those denied
individuals a study that focused on
mental health related firearm
prohibition similarly found a
protective Association when the relevant
records were stored in the appropriate
background check
databases another study showed that the
implementation of the Brady Act was
associated with reduction and Firearm
suicide rate for people aged 55 and
older in closing gun violence is a
Public Health
crisis the New Hampshire Psychiatric
Society and the New Hampshire Medical
societies strongly support House Bill
1711 as a way to potentially reduce the
risk of
suicides and homicides in New Hampshire
thank you for your attention and I'm
open to
questions
nobody thank you very much for your
vry thank you madam chair and members of
the committee um thank you for the
opportunity to public publicly address
house bill 1711 uh my name is Angela vry
I'm the northeast regional director for
National Association for gun rights a
member suppored organization with
thousands of members and supporters in
the state of New Hampshire uh today the
committee is obviously hearing comments
on 1711 a bill that will tie mental
health records to background checks and
uniformly report this information to the
federal government's next system on
behalf of National Association for gun
rights and our members in New Hampshire
I come before the committee today to
oppose House Bill 1711 and vote in
expedience to legislate by this
committee New Hampshire the Live Free or
Die state has historically been opposed
to the overreach by the federal
government and has previously taken
action to uphold this principle of uh
honoring State's rights one way in which
the state was has done this is by
passing the Second Amendment
preservation act barring the enforcement
of unconstitutional federal gun control
laws in the state of New Hampshire this
law protects law-abiding citizens and
law-abiding gun owners from falling
victim to radical ideas of California
and New York that we must put reasonable
barriers in place and jump through many
hoops and hurdles before being allowed
to exercise our god-given Second
Amendment rights another way in which
New Hampshire has defended gun owners in
the past was by passing constitutional
carry allowing graned Staters to carry a
firearm that they are legally allowed to
possess this law has not only saved
lives here in New Hampshire but has also
saved lives in the 26 other current
states where it has been
enacted as a resident of the communist
state of New York uh I thank New
Hampshire for taking these actions to
save lives and protect C citizens uh
constitutional rights but now Democrats
and Republicans alike are coming
together to support House Bill 1711 and
undo the progress that they've made in
upholding the Second Amendment this
comes in the wake of the shooting at the
New Hampshire hospital in November where
a mentally deranged individual would
take the life of security officer
Bradley hos while I am for reducing
these types of tragic events this bill
will not do a single thing to prevent
this type of shooting from happening
again
the shooter John Mador previously had
his guns taken away in 2016 and was
taken into custody by tra by straford
police following his arrest and
psychological evaluation at the New
Hampshire hospital he was released back
into society and subsequently gained
access to Firearms once again proponents
of this bill say that by passing it it
will prevent people like Mador from
Gaining access to firearms because their
purchases will be checked against the
Nick system and will be denied will be
denied from purchasing the firearm there
are problems that arise with this check
though including people being falsely
reported as not being able to own a
firearm when it's really somebody else
with a similar name and identity if this
does happen it becomes a lengthly and
costly process to appeal the decision
and also the fact that Dylan rof the
shooter from uh South Carolina who shot
up the black owned Church uh should have
been flagged by the nck system but
wasn't because his arrest was never
reported to ncks so this only provides a
false sense of security to the general
public besides the unconstitutionality
of the Nick system the bill simply put
will not uh will not work because of
other ways to purchase a firearm asides
from commercial sales criminals will
still be able to get their hands on guns
through private transfers the black
market or through Flatout theft this is
proven by a 2019 report from the US doj
showing that only 10% of firearm related
crimes were committed with a gun
purchased through commercial means while
90% % were committed with a firearm
obtained through private transferred
theft or off the street the only thing
that this bill will do is dismantle law
abiding gred stator rights to privacy
and disincentivize them from exercising
their second amendment rights overall
our main points of contention with this
bill are one the historical framework of
New Hampshire fighting back against
Federal overreach two the
unconstitutionality of the Nick system
and O other federal gun control laws and
systems and three that it will only
affect law-abiding citizens and not
actual Criminal criminals from getting
their hands on a firearm with this I Ur
I urge the committee to Mark House Bill
1711 as inexpedient to legislate and
stop the bipartisan attack on gun owners
in New Hampshire instead of placing more
restrictions on law abiding gun owners
you should seek to let people like
security officer Bradley hos defend
their institutions by carrying a firearm
for self-defense thank you and we'll
keep our members informed of your
decisions thank you very much
representative
Pro
so do you
believe that
if uh Chief hos had a firearm that day
things may have turned out different
much so yes and the
state took away his right to protect
correct anybody
else representative scitec did you make
the statement that the Nick system is
unconstitu
correct how come the courts haven't
nobody challenged that no has the court
found that or is that your statement we
can't put our trust in the courts that's
my
statement are there any further
questions thank you Mr V thank
you let me just
ask is Dr kin still
here
okay um Katherine giddens she had to
up I'm not sure if I want food or a
drink after this
same um there are multiple bills this
session that are nothing more than gun
control or gun confiscation bills
masquerading his mental health bills
this one is no different while we should
all be saddened and angry that an
unarmed security officer former law
enforcement was murdered this
emotionally written Bill does nothing to
stop criminals from number one
committing murder and number two from
getting Firearms one of the biggest
issues we have in this state and across
the country is mental health if someone
is violently mentally ill why would be
they be even released from a secure
mental health facility rather than
pushing more discriminatory gun
confiscation bills why don't we actually
do do something to address the serious
mental health issues we have we should
be open reopening mental institutions so
that those who are violently mentally
ill can have a safe place to live where
they won't hurt themselves or others
contrary to what psychiatrists said in
the 70s and 80s when they pushed closing
all of these institutions some people
cannot live in society because they are
too dangerous and we have seen this on
multiple occasions with mass Killers
across the country we need to stop
handing out psychotropic drugs like
candy
many mess Killers have been on these
drugs these two were pushed by the same
psychiatrist who claimed without
actually knowing that these drugs would
make it so violently mentally ill people
could live happily in society we need to
have more and easier access to mental
health care and make no mistake a
majority of people with mental illness
are not violently ill in fact a majority
are more likely to be victims of crime
than commit crimes pushing gun control
as a mental health issue is an affront
to Common Sense the mentally ill and our
fundamental human right to self-defense
please vote in expedient to legislate on
this bill and maybe try doing something
to help solve the serious mental health
state any questions we're good thank you
representative scitec could you in maybe
two
sentences say exactly what your problem
is with the bill not I I don't want as
as succinct as you can make it please
it's a gun confiscation bill and it's
okay thank you Miss
okay
doctor if you're going um if you handed
us actual testimony if you could
highlight representative scitec
representative scitec please if you
could
highlight if your intention was to read
everything that you're passing out if
you could just highlight those parts
since you're passing it out that would
be great what I'm passing around is the
APA position statement from the American
testimony good afternoon Madam chair
honorable committee members my name is
Dr Samantha sweater I'm the associate
medical director and a psychiatrist at
New Hampshire hospital however today I
am not representing New Hampshire
hospital but I'm representing the New
Hampshire Psychiatric
Society the New Hampshire Psychiatric
Society is in strong support of House
Bill 1711 and we would also like to
recognize the Monumental bipartisan
legislation on such an important
topic I also want to refer to the APA a
position statement on firearms in
support of my testimony that I'm passing
out and will not delve into during my
testimony one important
distinguish one thing I think is
important to distinguish is an iea
versus an non-emergent involuntary
admission so this bill would only report
people that have been found to have a
mental illness and be dangerous to them
M themselves or others by clearing
convincing
evidence in an non-emergent involuntary
admission which means they have already
gone
through
the is different from the emergency
involuntary admission so the emergency
and voluntary admission is the iea and
that is 135c 27-33 it is not included in
this bill which is 34 to 3 54 and the
iea is for people who
that's the prayer and complaint that you
file and you send someone to the
emergency room or anyone can file um and
send someone that you're concerned about
to the emergency room and then a
provider will evaluate that person and
then send them to a designated receiving
facility on an emergency basis and then
they are detained for up to 10 business
days if the person goes to a designated
receiving facility and they're found to
have a mental illness and be a danger to
themselves or others due to that mental
illness then the provider can petition
with the team for an non-emergency
involuntary admission and that's the
conditional discharge that you already
heard other people speak about today um
so that would be an involuntary
discharge outside of that um I do think
it's important to distinguish that a
temporary emergency involuntary
admission order is not covered in this
bill as it's currently written um and so
therefore the only people who are
adjudicated to be found to have a mental
illness and be danger to themselves or
bill outside of the other comments that
have been said today I don't have
anything else to add other than to
recount The Experience on November 17th
as I was also there at New Hampshire
hospital um when shortly after
3:00 I heard a
scream and someone sprinted into my
office flew open my
door ran into my office and slammed the
door behind herself hiding behind the
door and she
said there's an active shooter call
911 I grabbed my phone started calling
911 and after I was done I realized that
there had been no code silver called
there had been no announcement no one
else in this building where there's
hundreds of employees knew what was
happening and everyone was in
danger so I tried to call the paging
system and it was down we couldn't
notify
anyone I've been working
there for over 5 years these people
aren't just people I work with they're
my
family and I couldn't tell them that
they were in danger and it was an hour
of
that I tried to notify everyone I could
you know trying to text people and
trying to figure out ways of notifying
you trying to remember and off the top
of our heads the numbers to the units
and call them to just try and tell
people
and it was genuinely one of the worst
moments of my life just not being able
to protect people I'm a healthc care
professional to help people and I
couldn't for an hour I just had to sit
danger and then after an hour we were
evacuated and it it wasn't better and we
were all in a room big room I suppose um
many of us crowded in a hallway or
outside in the cold um and then that's
when we found out
that Chief hos had
died
and that was someone that many of
us saw almost every day um leaving the
facility
and someone a coworker was murdered
100t from my office while I stood there
and then I had to sit there while other
people I loved were in danger and I
them if something like Bradley's law had
existed it's possible that that wouldn't
and so I urge you to vote ought to pass
to try and prevent similar tragedies
from occurring in the future thank
you thank you doctor on behalf of the
committee please accept our condolences
for your loss thank you there won't be
any
Dean
good afternoon members of the committee
after a long day um Penny Dean
yeah and I oppose this bill for two well
several reasons the first reason of
course is
ideological but the second reason is
mechanical and
practical this bill is poorly drafted so
even if you
support the concept and even if you
support what what it purports to
do you've got huge problems with it now
I have a copy of the amendment and I was
trying to follow the bouncing
ball and make sure I'm speaking to what
I believe is the amendment and not the
original bill so if I make a mistake I
apologize but I'm trying to follow which
one replaces
what and so I want to start talking
about on page one how they never on page
one is that this applies to people who
it's a danger to
themselves and I have a huge problem
with this
because each person has a right to make
their own autonomic decisions I mean
there are those who cry say listen women
have a right to make choices over their
own body well if I have a right to make
a choice over my own body the womb I
have a right to make a choice over all
of my body what I do or what I don't do
so you might think you know me running
out and banging my head against the wall
of my house is really bad and it's going
to cause a brain injury but that's my
right you might mind think it's another
hagendaz when I need to lose a few might
be bad but again my body my
choice and so I want you to consider
that sometimes people are if you will
would come under this bill because of a
danger to themselves not a danger of
others and that's a big big deal but
secondly to think that anybody can't get
guns elsewhere I think someone should
get in the car with me we'll go to
Manchester the city of your choice I bet
within 10 minutes we can score some
cocaine heroin or any other illicit
substance you want they're illegal get
them no problem just have to find the
right street corner it's the same way
with these drugs doesn't make or I'm
sorry some way with Firearms there's
still people who are going to sell
illegal Firearms no matter
what but the other thing you have to
look up at is that this allows the
current bill if I'm reading the version
correctly that I have on page two line
supon to order that the person's
information be transmitted to the next
system I have a huge problem with this
so we supposedly are going to rely on
the doctors we're going to lie rely on
the court whoever's on the other side so
anybody in the world gets to make a
decision except for
me about
me I don't think that's Equitable or
Fair the other problem that I have and
it's a very serious mechanical problem
15 15 I'm making sure I'm following the
original verses the amended um it's the
original version I think that still is
those parts page 2 line 15 says talk
about court transmitting it to the
Department of Safety for IND um entering
to the nxs
indices I think this is such a huge job
that when I used to have employees in my
office there were certain things that
only I would do because the buck stops
here so the question is and I'm in no
way maligning any hardworking Court
employees but do they understand the
implications of incorrectly faxing or
transmitting the wrong name to the Nyx
indices and I would say they maybe don't
so we don't have a designated person
here that's doing this for example with
petitions to anull and nulled files
those are kept in a lot clerk's office
and on the electronic system only
certain people with passwords can see
those are we going to let any front
office clerk backs these things over
electronically send them over what if
they mistakingly hear what the judge
said that's that's a huge deal this has
to be handled by a specific designated
highlevel person that really understands
at lines this is on page two still lines
17 through lines 23 particularly lines
22 through
23 and I know there's been some changes
that's part of the amended version but
it still doesn't solve the problem we
have a couple three things here it is
perfectly lawful in this country I could
find a convicted felon boyfriend or
husband tomorrow morning at 8:00 they
could live in my house full with my guns
and ammunition I would just have to keep
them inaccessible to that felon in other
words I can still have my guns I can
still have my ammunition my powder my
primer my brass they just have to be
inaccessible to that person
what we're doing here in taking this
person's guns and it's very
explicit they cannot be in a house with
guns so you're going to treat a mentally
ill person less than you would a
convicted
felon that's got to be wrong on so many
levels so many levels because we talk
about the authority the court is going
to have to take their firearms so what
if that felon's fire
Firearms or I'm sorry what if the
mentally ill person's Firearms are in my
house so the police according to this
are going to have right to come into my
house and go through my house there has
to be specifications that if it isn't
the mentally ill person's house that
they've got to get a warrant there has
to be some sort of hearing and finding
because a lot of mentally ill people
sometimes end up on the street and
sometimes they end up couch serving
couch surfing rather
through the homes of friends and family
because they simply some of them can't
maintain employment or whatever and so
that'll be a true case of no good deed
goes
unpunished you've got to make sure and
this legislation does not do it to find
out if you're going to Johnny Joe's
house where they're couch surfing that
you need a warrant and ask Johnny Joe
first you're going to come through and
take my guns too because that's what
this
says just because I let him stay in my
house or I'm my
couch you have to look further um we
look on lines 2425 and 26 of page
two and it says law enforcement shall
carry out the order of the Court as soon
as possible but in no cases 48 hours
after the order was
issued that is a very short period of
time and we're still not talking about
how that is going to be accomplished
because again they come in with a no
knock warrant is this going to be a
nighttime warrant there's a huge
difference when you apply for a search
warrant a judge has a right to say if
it's a daytime warrant or a nighttime
warrant I think they should be only
daytime warrants allowed number one in
this situation number two I don't think
no knock warrant should be allowed here
no knock warrants are dangerous and it's
presumed they're no knock they should be
knock warrants that's a huge difference
if it's your house but here's the other
issue what if the person again because
mentally people do make mistakes or
deliberately do things do essentially
like swatting does say their guns are
located at my house and I don't even
know them if we don't have a hearing
procedure we have cops coming and
knocking or quite frankly breaking down
my door to get guns for a person who
never lived there we're just taking that
person's word and that person we're
claiming is so Mill we got to lock them
up and we're going to take their word
for something like this there has to be
some verification there's no procedures
there the other issue which is really
huge and one of the other Witnesses test
touched upon it is this is all
contingent on approval from
ATF ATF speaks with fork tongue and that
is the kindest thing I can say about
them ATF over the years has changed
their position on what was called street
sweepers and they changed it in such a
way and you have to understand the
mechanical thing people went to normal
gun stores bought street sweepers had
them for years and if you weren't part
of the gun Community or checked regular
gun regulations you didn't know that you
had 30 days from the date they gave an
wait wait strike that I can't remember
it's 30 days or the number of days but a
very few number of days from when ATF
made the announcements to register
your street
sweeper as an NFA device or it was
considered
contraband and after that you couldn't
register it and if you got caught with
it felon here you go Federal felon
because you're in possession of
prohibited property no reasonable person
would have ever thought that would have
happened but worse yet the ATF has
issued opinion letters to Federal Farms
licenses and manufacturers said ATF were
building these um they did it with the
arm brace they did it with the reset
triggers and most recently cases I'm
working on in federal court in Boston
they did it with what's called
suppressor wipes where the manufacturers
went to ATF and said this is what we
want to do please give us written
guidance so we can make sure what we're
manufacturing is within the law they
gave them written guidance they said you
have to apply for a form one and build
your suppressors ATF is now about a year
later some two or 3 years later we're
calling those form ones that they
approved saying we changed our
mind they do they have years and years
of history of not honoring their words
with nothing changing on the other party
side and this is what's important to
know there were no changes in the wipes
there were no changes in the
manufacturing and so we are going to now
put our citizens names in a system where
ATF can change their mind about what's
acceptable they did that with Greg
Dupont in Massachusetts they first said
it's acceptable
that the Firearms licensing review board
restore his right to carry his second
amendment rights they then changed their
mind years later for no reason so what
I'm trying to say is we are playing a
very very dangerous game here when we
rely on ATF to say this is going to be
okay and that our process and our
procedure is okay because here's the
problem once you get people's names into
the federal indices we cannot make them
pull them out and sometimes they refuse
to pull them out so you have to think
about what are we going to do for these
forever if you go to the next p i want
to make sure I'm following the pages
um the other things the other problems
that we have at least from my
perspective as a practical problem
is at these hearings there's nothing
here that says they're going to be
closed hearings or confidential by law
so just like these hearings here or
courtrooms they are public anybody in
the public can walk in and walk out and
hear and see everything that's happening
so you are now going to take this
confidential and you're going to make it
public cuz you're going to Force these
people to make it public if and when
they want their rights
restored and so you look at that and you
say why do I want to make this
public and that's going to be my only
chance to get my rights back but I think
the other thing that always has amazed
me and it's disgusted me and upset me is
everyone makes a big deal about oh they
have to be locked up by clear and
convincing evidence we don't lock people
up in the state prison other than Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt last time I checked
but yet we lock these people up and
that's what you're doing if any Of You'
have never been to the New Hampshire
hospital or conquered Hospital their
special a w you should go there you
won't like it
much and
say that standard is good enough to put
these people away and you look
about and I'm asking myself when they
say the emergency inv voluntary of
admission is not part of this well
that's not quite telling the whole truth
because the emergency one becomes a
regular one after the next process and
procedure and it becomes one so the
initial one yes is not covered but that
morphs into second ones and I argue that
it is covered by this so to say the
initial one isn't as technically true
but it's not telling the whole story and
that's what you have to do in these type
of things is tell the whole story
the next thing we look at is Page
four and we look at lines
two I want someone from the Department
of Health and Human Services Behavioral
Health evaluating my mental health the
same day I want Sarah Brady and Gabby
gord's doing it you got no
chance because there are some people
that think the mere thought that we love
guns is
wrong and particularly in the medical
Community there seems to be a high
number of those individuals but here's
what I'm asking myself as a practical
matter and it goes back to
money and a lot of these people don't
have
money if we want an independent
psychiatrist to evaluate our client and
to say in open court with essentially
their licenses on the
line that they're not going to act in a
manner dangerous to Public Safety I'm
going to suggest just a couple three
things will happen and I will bet a
nickel on it and I rarely bet my hard
earn
nickels and that is that somebody who's
anti-gun trying to shut down the gun
people again are going to go to the
malpractice carriers that write
malpractice insurance for these
psychiatrists and psychologists and
they're going to ask a question on their
malpractice renewal do you do these
types of hearings and they're either
going to refuse to insure them or they
are going to escalate their rates
through the roof because if you're an
insurance carrier who tends to be
cautious and wants to make a lot of
money ask yourself what you're going to
say to your friendly psychiatrist who is
now writing evaluations and going to
court and testifying as an expert
witness that you believe these people
are now
okay I think that's a huge thing so how
many psychiatrists and psychologists are
we going to be able to find who are
going to work for us and testify and at
what
price that's one thing um the next thing
that I think is really problematic on
page 4 is lines 11 12 and
13 and they want the court to review the
circumstances minimum mental health and
any criminal record so you're not asking
the court actually you're not mandating
that the court can review only this
instance that brought them there you're
letting the court review their entire
criminal record you're letting the court
review the reputation and num these two
words here character witness and
character evidence lawyers go by the
rules of evidence and a lot of people
don't know by The Rules of Evidence but
the Rules of Evidence are all these
court rules that allow what comes in and
comes out and character and reputation
evidence with certain exceptions are
like the things you're just you you try
and bring those in and everybody's on
their feet going that's reputation
that's character that's propensity with
exceptions there's always
exceptions and that's what you're going
to bring in so are we going to have
swearing contests here where if I can
line up 10 people that says I'm a good
girl now and I'm all better and you can
line up 50 that say I'm still some crazy
old woman does that mean I don't get my
gun rights back I mean really what are
we looking at here and it's just really
there's
no specific
times about how quickly they have to
have these hearings there's no specific
limits and how long they can be judges
want to rush things in and out in 15
minutes short on court time I sometimes
want 3 days for a hearing to bring an
adequate record forward we don't have
any specific timelines the other things
that courts say all the time in all
fairness to them is these are statutory
things we have to have this hearing this
hearing and this hearing with in this
mon Mone days anything that's not
statutory you get pushed out in the
weeds cuz we don't have to have your
hearing within days so what are we going
to have here 5 years later we get a
hearing one year later I don't know will
that be enough stress on someone who's
trying to get their firearm rights back
I don't
know the other thing that you really
want to look at which
is laughable in a black humor such away
if the final court order grants relief
the court shall as soon as possible
request that the Nicks entry be redacted
and shall notify the United States
Attorney General that the basis for the
record being made available no
longer
applies that's not how we do things
now right now they have um in New
Hampshire they report it through the
state police criminal justice
information service
and I've asked a million times over the
past 20 years if data is exchanged
hourly daily by the minute every 24
hours I have never been able to get an
answer so how frequently that data is
exchanged I do not know I would love to
know I've never been able to learn that
but the bottom line is I've got to tell
you if you sit at a court sometimes and
a DVP comes in they are at that fax
machine faxing overtaking the guy's guns
they're doing that in record time and
I've seen them be not so quick when
they're dismissed to take them back so
the question is when they say as soon as
possible we don't have a timeline here
if you don't have a timeline you could
press that little fact button a minute
before why can't you press that little
fax button or electronic thing in a
minute now so I think that's going to
matter but again what's really huge is
are these public or private when you
appeal to the Supreme Court which is
line 20 on page
denied I don't know if anyone has talked
to the court about this but the Supreme
Court shall review the case do noo and
has the discretion to review additional
evidence the Supreme Court is not a
trial court in New Hampshire anyhow it's
an appell at court I don't know if
anyone's talked to the court about how
they're going to handle this and again
we're going back to are these public or
are these private
um as we know Juvenile and certain other
matters are private they're closed
literally they they have M you know the
Bay's at the door you're not coming in
it when you look at page
425 through 33 I've addressed and I
think it's huge what the ATF has done
and that alone should give everyone
pause to say do we want to go down this
path this way because we really can't
trust
them and it isn't just me with my
distrust for them we have years and
years of practical actions that they
have taken and things they have done
where they have changed their mind to
say that we have to
good part of
the amendment still from what I can see
still treats
the mentally ill person that they can't
live with other people that have
firearms that's a again the huge problem
and I don't see a change in the
amendment I see it still being set that
way which again restricts how many
people they can live with or the people
they're going to live with have to be
willing to give up their firearms and I
don't know even my best friends or
whatever if I'm willing to give up my
firearms to give them a place to live
maybe I'll Pony up some money from an
apartment for
him but I think when you look at this
and you look at the standards it's
almost like a popularity
contest to
get the rights back and more importantly
there's not a timeline this is another
thing that's hugely
important courts do not have with rare
instances a time in which they have to
issue an order so if you look at the New
Hampshire Supreme Court at the US
Supreme Court It's Not Unusual that they
will hear a matter and they won't issue
a decision for 6 months a year year and
a half and that's the right there's no
timeline I don't see a timeline in here
so you put your evidence before the
court they can take a year to decide
they can take however long they want
that's huge when you're the person
waiting for your
rights so you have to ask
yourself I always put myself in the
shoes if I were the person going through
this this process how fair would I think
it is how how well would it address my
needs and I respectfully say it wouldn't
but I think the other practical thing
that needs to be done there has to be a
list of licensed psychiatrists that we
think would be acceptable to courts to
opine um pursuant to page
three um lines 1 through
six and ask how many of them would be
willing to do these type of exams and
once we see that list I can tell you
from my experience there was only a
couple that I think I could call in this
state and one of them unfortunately is
deceased that would give my client a
fair hearing that would be
objective and that didn't hate guns and
that would make a professional opinion
about whether or not my client should
have guns and so I just respectfully say
to you that even if you're for this
concept which I'm not and for this
process they want to do it this is not
the vehicle it's deeply
flawed and I'm happy to answer any
questions I can for
anybody thank you attorney I I just
wanted to um ask one question just for
clarification when you were speaking of
whether it would be an open or a closed
hearing on the the very first sentence
on the top of page line two on the
original Bill where it says
notwithstanding any other provision of
law including the requirement of a
closed hearing and file under blah blah
blah is that what you referring to or is
there is that something different where
you r able to find that um let let me
you said we're on page the very top of
page two the very first sentence not
withing any other provision of law of
law
including um no I would I'm sorry I was
referring to when the person's
attempting to get their rights back okay
this is this is the process there and
um I see problems there but I was trying
to highlight what I consider to be the
largest problems if I were doing what I
call a proper job I would you guys
wouldn't even get dinner you know what
I'm saying in other words I I would I
would go through this and really
really what I call bird dog and do a
proper lawyer job so I'm I'm not going
to represent that I did a proper lawyer
job on this I hit what I called
the biggest things that I think any one
of them alone
should make this bill fatal it should
should not go anywhere but with all of
those without even me going into what I
call the minutia of it even more it's
problems representative PR thank thank
you turny there is a lot to unpack here
without without a doubt thank you for
thank
you
much
Sterns like I won the lottery being
called good afternoon Madam chair
honorable members of the committee for
the record my name is Susan Sterns and I
serve as the executive director of Nami
New Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness I'm a resident of samton
and I have family members who live with
mental
illness indeed I'm not a lawyer I'm not
a doctor I'm first and foremost a
mom I do want to say on behalf of the
Nami New Hampshire family our staff our
volunteers and the folks we serve how
incredibly saddened we were with the
events on November 17th and the loss of
Chief ha many of us knew him indeed I've
heard from so many family members about
how caring and kind he was to them when
they would visit their loved ones at New
Hampshire
hospital so on behalf of Nami New
Hampshire I'm here to offer testimony in
what I would call cautious support of HB
1711 there are indeed several key
Provisions in the bill that we feel are
critical to preventing discrimination
and protecting the civil liberties of
people living with mental illness as
well as helping to ensure the safety of
both individuals and law
enforcement according to the National
Institute on Mental Health one in five
Americans is living with a mental
illness one in
five the vast majority of people living
with mental illness get up in the
morning put their kids on the bus go to
work come home make dinner help the kids
with homework do the laundry go to bed
get up and do it all over
again given
this it is critical that the language in
this bill limits who would be prevented
from purchasing a firearm to individuals
who have been found to be a danger to
themselves or others after probate
commitment hearing and to people who may
have been found not guilty to stand
trial but who have also been found to be
dangerous to themselves or
others in addition to those conditions
at Nami New Hampshire there we feel
strongly that several Provisions that
are in the Bill and that appear to be in
the amendment is my first read through
um that are really essential to its fair
and appropriate
implementation is these include that the
report made to the nck system be made by
law enforcement or the judicial branch
in order to protect that therapeutic
relation relationship between providers
and
patients that there is a process by
which a person can petition the court
for Relief and to have their rights
restored and that any removal of firearm
should be done in a way that limits
engagement of the individuals in law
enforcement in order to avoid dangerous
confrontations the reality is that for
many people the initial diagnosis of a
major mental illness is a crisis yet
treatment works and making sure that
people understand that there is help and
hope is a critical part of the recovery
process this bill as written helps
ensure that people who have been
determined to be a danger to themselves
or others do not have access to Firearms
when they are on well yet does not
permanently deny them a constitutional
right and offers the promise of recovery
and the ability to live a full life in
the
community on behalf of the nearly 44,000
folks we serve each year we ask that you
ensure that any bill on this matter on
which you vote ought to pass addresses
the concerns we have raised and protects
the rights of granite Staters with
mental illness and I thank you all for
dedication representative
scitec you said 44,000 people represent
who are these 44,000 we served last year
nearly 44,000 individuals demographic of
what that looks like um that is
individuals who are impacted by mental
illness they could be living with a
mental illness they could have a loved
one who has a mental illness it also
includes people who may have lost
someone to Suicide it also includes
people who may have been impacted by
co-occurring mental illness and
substance use disorder it is a broad
array of people who are impacted as we
know I don't think there's any one of us
who is not impacted in some way in our
personal
lives thank you very
much we
have two cards left so if you are
holding on to a card now is the time to
turn it in uh because after these guys
are called we will be closing this
public hearing we still have one more
left after this
um Jeffrey Jeffrey
thank you madam chair members of the
committee this time as I come before you
I am uh representing the New Hampshire
Psychiatric Society and New Hampshire
Medical Society I am so glad to be able
to testify today because I think this is
important legislation on an issue that
I've been thinking about for a long time
this bill is tailored to New Hampshire's
approach to mental health
law rather than targeting the mentally
defective as the Brady Bill does this
bill uses procedural triggers for legal
events that demonstrate a patients
dangerousness this approach is important
to minimize the stigma of people with
mental illness advocats often point out
that people with mental illness are more
likely to be victims than perpetrators
of violence and this is true initially
proved in the 1998 MacArthur Study and
replicated several times since but I
think we can be nuanced in how we talk
about this patients are more vulnerable
um than they are dangerous over time but
there are such things as behavioral
crisises and that is why psychiatric
hospitals
exist there have been a number of
objections raised I'd like to briefly um
address um one is the idea that um
because of the availability of guns uh
in our society that this bill would do
no
good I feel that potentially is an an
instance of stigmatization the
conflation of the mentally ill with
criminals most patients who come through
our Hospital are not criminals they
would not know where to go to pick up an
illegal gun any more than any other uh
person without a mental illness who's
not a criminal
what um there objections been raised
regarding reluctance to pronounce a
person cured
when I am done with my testimony I'm
going to pass out to you a um resource
document from the American Psychiatric
association from 2020 regarding to
restoring access to
Firearms excuse me this document
provides guidelines to allow
psychiatrists to have a framework and a
standard of care for which to perform
these evaluations a resource document to
refer to when to allow the judge to
understand the limitations of of their
evaluation and recommendations of how to
proceed with that
evaluation moreover as I suppose
everyone knows doctors take calculated
risks all the time every time we
discharge a patient from the hospital we
are taking a calculated risk to society
and to the patient and to our
liability um that is not something that
we are totally averse to we we have to
do that that's part of our
job um and I might might add that if one
were to do as a psychiatrist if you were
to do one of these restoration
evaluations you would be doing it as a
forensic evaluation you would not have a
doctor patient relationship with the
patient the way that this bill is
written therefore you would not have
malpractice liability you would actually
not need malpractice insurance to do a
forensic evaluation because by
patient
um some objections were also raised to
some of the language on page 3 13 to 15
um and also the language around
dnovo um um uh review by the Supreme
Court all of that was carefully selected
language in order to meet the atf's
requirements to take a patient off the
Nicks list if it were not there and it's
not there in current New Hampshire law
you they won't comply with a request to
take the patient off the Nicks list we
thought this through this is designed to
work to protect the patient's right to
be
restored sp sp 171's intention is to
prevent events like what happened on
November 17th 2023 you've already heard
some accounts of that so I'm not going
to go through my account it'll be in my
written testimony and you can read it
it's a little different but it's always
the same but I do want to talk a little
bit about the
aftermath since November 17th there have
been both expected and unexpected Ed
Fallout there's been patients who have
been stabilized for long years and now
have lost many of their gains there
staff who have had to take time off to
seek help for the stress of living with
what they have seen for three of us this
was our second a active shooter event
there was one in darmouth Hitchcock a
few years ago as
well for me I was deeply
angry angry that I could not help a man
who was down in my own Hospital angry
that a man who honorably served his
community would lose his life and their
and his family lose their time with him
angry that we had not somehow been able
to prevent this as a hospital as a
mental health system or as a society
angry that we've spent years trying to
build this Hospital into something good
where people with mental illness can
find care where families can feel
comfortable leaving their loved ones
where people can spend a productive
career Advan ing the field and doing
meaningful work and then to think that
on November 17th so much of that was
lost and that perhaps it could have been
prevented two psychiatrists and a judge
had determined that this shooter was
dangerous if you count the Ia an
additional psychiatrist and
judge his guns were seized but there was
no system in but there is a system in
place to ensure that there would he
would not be able to buy another gun but
New Hampshire had no way to report this
information to that system HB 1711
allows us to join the majority of states
which
do you can't help but relive it from
formal event reviews reminders around
the hospital like Signs and cards
well-meaning friends and family who want
to support you Vivid memories come to
mind every day remembering the surprise
of the thought I could really die
today the helpless n of being trapped
and the guilty worry I hope I'm doing
everything I can to not let my people
down and yet the very next day with the
Franklin shooting the world had already
moved
on I am a psychiatrist I hear stories
every week where any reasonable person
would say well that guy shouldn't have a
gun where a patient's family member
would thank you for making sure they
can't have a gun or patients themselves
later in a different state of mind would
be grateful that they couldn't buy a gun
moment please vote ought to pass on HB
1711 and give us this tool to keep our
patients and the public safe I'm happy
to take any
questions scitech this qu uh Madam chair
you may rule this question out of order
and I'm uh happy to
no I'm going I'm going to ask my
question you can stop me but I'm going
to ask my question the players are here
uh the bayth at my court is armed how
come if you've had two incidents at the
hospital your Chief the chief was not
armed I I'm here speaking for the um
Psychiatric Society I'm not authorized
Safety
okay thank you very much thank you
representative Hall ladies and gentlemen
this is our last card if you have a card
warning thank you madam chair
representative Hull serving the towns of
Dunbarton hookit Allenstown and epom
here in opposition to House Bill
[Music]
1711 I have not I am speaking as as the
bill was introduced I I understand that
an amendment may have been proposed I
have not seen the amendment I cannot
speak to the amendment I will speak to
the bill as introduced if one of you
would kindly get me a copy I would like
to review
that secondly um my condolences to Chief
Hoff's family um we lost the public
servant that
day I think it's a real tragedy that
we're going to nickname a bill after
him because every law enforcement
officer that I know carries privately
because they understand and the society
that we've come to live in and it would
be really a real tragedy if it was the
state that denied him the ability to
protect himself and the others in the
hospital that day I really think that
this committee should do the
investigation to find out why a former
law enforcement in this case the chief
of police was disarmed when managing the
metal detector and being the first
primary defense for the
hospital that alone should be the only
thing that comes out of this bill is to
servant his family is owed more than
we're going to give them because he lost
that his life that day because he
couldn't defend
himself
next I had the chance this past fall to
learn a lot more about mental health
than I ever wanted to um a dear family
member had a mental health crisis that I
hadn't expected um I learned a lot learn
that diet actually believe it or not
what you eat is highly tied to how you
do mentally there's a big there's a big
understanding of of the gut Mental
Health
Link apparently 50% of EP epilepsy cases
can be solved just by changing someone's
diet I had no idea I learned a
lot so with that said um we do have a
mental health crisis in the US and in
New Hampshire we need to do something
about
it changing the diet is is is clearly a
first day but these are not ill sorry
these are not violent patients for the
most part there are exceptions but I
want to be clear in my testimony that
the vast majority of people that have me
mental health issues are not
vient okay there are exceptions to that
and what this bill will do is allow
those that are exceptions to go into
society unrestrained because we put a
piece of paper and says well they're not
Timothy McVey was not ruled a mentally
handicapped or deranged individual but
he managed to take
fertilizer and diesel fuel and end the
people these people need our help they
don't need to have their firearms
restricted that's not the solution the
way we help them is to give them the
next I want to report on nck since Nick
seems to be the foundation that we're
going to the Magic Bullet the magic
Silver Bullet we're going to solve this
paragraph one on page two right we're
going to be entered these names are
going to be entered into Nick's indices
for those who the court for those found
by the court to be a danger to himself
or herself or
others in 2018 the government
accountability office did a report I
have sent this to all of you via email I
would enter ask that that be entered
into the into the file because I think
it's
important what the GAO found the
government accountability agency in 2018
was quote few individuals denied
Firearms purchases are prosecuted and
the ATF should assess the use of warning
notices in Le of prosecutions
first um it is a federal crime to
knowingly fill out a for 4473 as a
prohibited
person there were 80 sorry 8.6 million
Federal Nicks transactions in 2017 there
was
111,000
denials there was 12,000 roughly in
order of magnitude
investigations and would you believe
there was 12
prosecutions say that again 112,000
people who Den not were denied 12,000
who warranted an
investigation and 1% sorry .1% of those
12 people were prosecuted now this is a
felony level offense and we're saying
that this is the magic cure to to the
hand I think we can do better than that
I think we should first find out why the
chief was disarmed this bill should be
completely Rewritten and we should find
out which St state agency prohibit him
from protecting himself we owe that we
family we also know that the Nicks list
is is not being managed well based on
what the GAO found it is not the
solution that everybody thinks it is so
just because names get entered doesn't
mean that people are actually prohibited
and those that are prohibited okay if
they were truly prohibited no one's
bothering to do any
prosecution so it's not going to solve
any anything real we also know that if
you are prohibited by a federal agency
and I don't know how this ties into this
bill this is not my area of expertise
either in law or medical but if at the
VA Hospital were part of the process and
they were the agency that that actually
was part of the recommendation by which
you were reported there might not be a
way to get off through a state level
form as someone mentioned
before that means we put our our
veterans at a
disadvantage I truly want to solve abuse
suicide issues there are we we've seen a
lot of suicides that's unfortunately
unfortunate um in um uh uh Miss Fallon
who's a state employee sends out a
monthly report on the number of of
opioid overdoses I would encourage you
all to get that it's a good report last
one that happens from early
January we had 201 people who died of
Fentanyl
last year now I'm not a drug user I
don't know that many people who are but
I don't think fentanyl is high on the
list because everybody knows the real
term the real consequences of using
fentanyl okay that was fentanyl alone
that wasn't mixed with some other drug
that was fentanyl alone these are people
who have given up on life and are
choosing to end it if we truly want to
solve suicide let's look at the
prominant killer in the state of New
Hampshire which is opioid AB abuse not
firearms I would ask that you would find
this bill inexpedient to legislate I do
think this committee should call for an
investigation of why Chief hos okay was
was unarmed at when he was providing SEC
security detail with that I'll end my
testimony thank
you any
representative I'm closing the hearing
on House Bill
1711 and um you've all been very very
patient as all of our members and I do
um need to let them have a at Le at
least a a 10-minute bio break we will
come back we will hear the last bill of
the afternoon which is House Bill
1701 and representative Muse if you just
give me a second so we can figure out um
before you guys all run out of here we
are executing some of the bills this
afternoon we have to we're here we got
to do it um so do what you need to do
for 10
minutes
those of you that have been here um for
the duration of the day once again we
thank you for your patience we've also
been here for the duration of the day we
understand uh with that being said we
are on our last Bill we do have quite a
few people that would like to testify
and in the spirit of giving everybody
their chance to be heard I do not have
intentions of limiting testimony but I
would ask that when you do present
please just be very specific to the to
the bill itself and then we shouldn't
have any need to have to um limit any
testimony um with that I will now open
the hearing on House Bill
1701 and we recognize representative
Manion to introduce his bill
thank you madam chair members of the
committee my name is Tom Manion
representing Hillsboro one the town of
pelum this bill is also a a result of a
constituent request um its purpose is to
anull involuntary commitments of
individuals that have been deemed
potentially harmful to themselves and
required psychiatric treatment uh and to
be abundantly clear this bill
specifically excludes commitments as
punishment for crimes pursuant to RSA
chapter 651 as being eligible for the
analment um there are those Society they
go through life experiences that they
are unable to cope with trauma grief
devastating financial problems the list
is extensive uh in some instances these
problems lead to people uh lead people
into a dark
place where the state must intervene to
prevent the worst from happening
resilient and many people can bounce
back from what could have been another
tragedy however the stigma of receiving
that care follows you for the rest of
your life uh this bill creates an Avenue
for people to petition the court after
enough time has pass to have the
commitment annulled and and treated as
though it never occurred I remember when
I enlisted in the Marine Corps in 2004
despite the fact that they were waving
all kinds of prerequisites the recruiter
was extremely inquisitive about whether
I'd received any kind of psychiatric uh
care as it would be a disqualifier for
enlistment it's understandable at face
value but implies that Rehabilitation is
impossible which to me is a discredit to
the mental health profession and the
resiliency of the human mind uh in a
somewhat parallel path the uh Nicks
background check which I've stated
before this committee violates our right
to not self-incriminate under the Fifth
Amendment of the United States
Constitution also requires divulging in
uh involuntary commitments why the
ATF which shouldn't exist has a
mechanism for relief from disability we
do not qualify and don't and shouldn't
submit names to them in the first place
I believe this bill similar to our
cannabis annulments uh RSA Reserve uh
serves as a clean path to keep the
federal government out of this intimate
intimate matter and allows recovering
individual a recovered individual to
regain their rights I ask that the vote
uh the committee vote OTP on HB 1701 and
questions thank you representative um
can you
maybe just give us a a little bit of
a synopsis of what this bill does yeah
so the the bill it it it allows for
annulment of involuntary Commitment if
as long as it's nonviolent right so
there's a the punishment section where
if you're committed for a violent crime
to a psychiatric care all of that is
excluded this instead allows you to
anull it and treat your commitment as if
it never happened to include like if you
were to approach a military recruiter
you can treat it as though it never
happened you could be like I'm fine and
when you fill out the the check the the
Nicks background check there's also the
check box like I've ever been committed
you could say no honestly because as far
as our laws law is concerned it has been
analled with the analment okay thank you
very much representative
scitec um I like to ask you about uh
Roman 7 uh I want to be sure I
understand it a journalist or reporter
shall not be subject to penalties for
broadcasting that a person has been
involuntarily committed subject to a
commitment order that has been ened
including the content of the record does
that mean that the reporter is free to
say this person has an En olded record
and it contained the following
information yeah when I filed this the
the OS had asked if I wanted to mimic
exactly like how the the Cannabis one
had been and that I believe that's there
to just kind of make it so if a reporter
ever reports on it they're not guilty of
any crime for divulging the information
like I'm I'm assuming if they got a hold
of the information they may have got it
through nefarious means there may a
criminal thing there but if I can follow
so that means that while it may be
public you they can broadcast it as
public information nothing can be done
legally about this they're subject to
they can get their job go in the Marine
Corp do whatever sure even though this
is known it's been en olded I would say
under the state statute like it it
shouldn't
concern as far as the law is concerned
it didn't happen right that's the
nment representative Muse what would you
consider your level of expertise to be
with issues like voluntary and
involuntary commitments and discharges
and annulments in the state of New
Hampshire I I don't have any expertise
whatsoever my background is in software
and I come from a Marine Corps military
background anybody else thank you very
much representative thank
you we
got representative
I will do my best to answer questions
afterwards um this this is is going to
be a little difficult uh for the record
my name is Ellen Reed I represent
Rockingham 10 that's new market and new
Fields um you may be surprised to see me
as a co-sponsor on this bill it is odd
um I entered as a co-sponsor with a very
clear agreement with the prime sponsor
that I would come and testify that I'm
not okay with the current language as it
is written and I will not support it as
currently written on the floor but it
does need an amendment and I do think
with the amendment it is worth
supporting and I will tell you why um
first I need to State because the one of
the rights the main right probably
that's being restored here is the
ability to own a gun uh I need to State
my position generally on guns I see them
as a tool um a tool that hopefully you
don't ever really need usually I think
people who are obsessed with that
particular tool are kind of weird
um however there are proper uses for
that tool and I also taught American
government at college for four years
which meant I taught the Constitution so
the other side of that is the Second
Amendment does exist I understand it
exists I understand why that it why it
exists and when I taught that I would
frequently show my students footage of
tianan square um and unarmed people
being mowed down uh I will say also that
the Supreme Court has backed up the
meaning of the Second Amendment because
it does refer to a well-regulated
militia however just as everybody in
this room I'm sure would not question
the right of a Sovereign Nation to
defend itself it turns out that that
right as Supreme Court has stated is
built on the inherent human right to
defend your own self your own body uh
from harm and so therefore um my
position may seem nuanced on guns in
general so as I said I signed on to this
bill specifically that I understand that
the language says that if it's someone
that the rights are restored after 5
years after an involuntary commitment
unless the person plad Guilty by reason
of insanity to a violent offense I think
that needs to go a little bit further
and actually no one who was um
involuntarily committed in in relation
to any violent offense whether they plad
uh uh Not Guilty by reason and insanity
or not should be excluded from this
restoration of Rights if there was a
violent offense committed you should not
be getting your firearm back however and
this is where I'm going to get into my
personal story the vast majority as I
understand it of involuntary commitments
across the country and I cannot speak
specifically to New Hampshire um are
72-hour holds after someone has tried to
kill
themselves I've actually told some of
this story before in my first term in
favor of a gun safety measure um and I
think it's funny I have to tell the same
story kind of almost on the other
side so my story is when I was 18 and I
didn't have a lot of um social education
I didn't really know a lot of things
about the world I got involved with my
first major boyfriend who turned out to
be extremely violent for a year and a
half I was beaten repeatedly um he held
me captive for 3 days in an apartment he
hit me with a car um when the cops saved
me from one instance they said it was
the worst case of domestic violence
they' ever seen where someone didn't die
and if I didn't leave I would definitely
die
um this went on uh until actually uh he
had a warrant he ended up with a warrant
and I got away from him in a
relationship sense but he continued to
to stalk me and send me uh threatening
messages until there was a warrant taken
out on him in the state and then he was
forced out of the state and he continued
this was when I was in college he
continued to send me death threats um to
the point that and apparently he had
other warrants in other states as well
the FBI got involved I literally had two
FBI agents in my dorm room as a college
student um and it didn't end until I
moved to Japan for three years where he
lost track of me um during that time of
a lot of upheaval and me not really at
18-year-old me not really knowing how to
handle things uh in a particularly low
moment I took an entire bottle of my
brother's uh clonin which is an anti- um
spasmodic uh drug um because I just
didn't know what else to do my life had
become so bad at the age of 18 and I was
rushed to the hospital uh
apparently they couldn't find my blood
pressure apparently my temperature was
84 and the point of all this is that I
was put into a 72-hour involuntary
commitment because I had tried to kill
myself the irony is I get through that I
get away I go to Japan I come back to
the States I get my Master's Degree in
New Hampshire I you know have this kind
of much much much better healthier life
and um after 11 years he found me and he
started sending me threats again to the
point regularly until to the point that
the police offic officers in New Market
had to get a warrant for his phone
records so that they could find his
location to deliver an order of
protection against him turns out he was
in Texas by the
way so at that time I was scared and I
went to go shop for a
gun as one might
do and um I personally like I said it's
a tool uh I personally don't like guns
but at that point I thought maybe I
should be familiar with this Tool uh I
ended up not purchasing one but it turns
out I wouldn't have been able to so very
ironically the very cause of the reason
I almost killed myself was the reason I
needed protection later and here at the
age of 44 because of me being in a low
point at the age of 18 I would not be
able to buy a firearm today if I was
honest on those Rec on those forms and
that is why I agreed to co-sponsor
second so to the point of
suicide um five years is is a good time
to wait for someone after they've hit a
low spot and I know that mathematically
because insurance companies when you go
to buy life insurance that would cover
uh accidents and the like they will
cover suicide but only after 2 years
after you've had the policy which means
that the insurance industry has
mathematically figured out that you are
no more of a risk of suicide two years
after being suicidal than the general
public because they are willing to pay
you for that life insurance policy even
years suicide is a problem
um I don't think that we take away the
risk of suicide simply by taking away
what we think of as the means of suicide
because when people are determined like
I was in that moment they will find a
way I think the way you deal with
suicide is you provide people who are
struggling with robust Health Care
Mental Health Care physical health care
I think you provide them with the basic
needs of living and the tools to improve
their lives I think you provide them
with compassion stigma free compassion
and dignity and
support and in case you think speaking
callously or without experience from
suicide that boyfriend that I mentioned
he ended up killing himself in 2016 the
same year that I I got elected so he's
no longer a threat in my life my uncle
also killed himself but more importantly
I wasn't very very close to my uncle my
dad who I was very very close to killed
himself when I was
21 and as much as I would love to have
him with me
today he was very depressed and if he
asked me in the moments before he did
that give me another option how do I end
this suffering I wouldn't have been able
to give him one because those supports
that I just listed for you we don't give
to
people so even though it pains me to
say I do believe in people's bodily
autonomy and I do believe in the right
to die because I don't have a better
option for people who are suffering
unless we provide them with health care
so if what you want to do is prevent
violence then you focus on the people
who were violent which is why I ask you
to amend this bill focus on the people
like that boyfriend that I had but you
don't punish
people from having their constitutional
and human right to defend
themselves just because they went
through a bad time 10 or 15 or 20 or 30
years
ago
sometimes to defend themselves from the
very reason they went through the bad
time to begin with and especially when
there's no evidence that they are any
more likely to take their lives after
two years but in this case five years
questions thank you represent I shut
everybody up well we we we generally try
not to ask questions on on such things
um and and representative just so you
know we try really hard to um Let It Be
the sponsor if you think that a that an
amendment is necessary we would ask that
you take care of the amendment and not
ask the the committee to do that just so
I'm happy to to offer my assistance
thank
Hall thank you madam chair
representative hle serving the towns of
B sorry to many years of doing bow and
Dunbarton Dunbarton hooks at Allenstown
in Epsom um I would like to thank
representative Reed for her testimony as
I said in the prior
Bell I had the chance to have a a deep
dive into mental health in the last six
months um not on my roadmap not for me
personally but someone I care about
learned a
lot um I'm here in support of this bill
back to the same rationale that I gave
before most of the people who have
mental health issues are not
violent I had a discussion with an
attorney several years ago we were
talking about um in Broad Strokes that
attorney's client and that attorney's
client basically couldn't fix an issue
but if it was tied to a crime they could
so if there's a criminal element to this
mental
health um adjudication at all then you
can get the whole thing en
olded but if there's no not you're
stuck why is our society have a policy
in place that it's better to be a
criminal so you can clean up your record
than having a health issue in this case
mental health issue so you can't this
seems like a clean simple thing going
forward um representative Reed I'd like
to see her amendment in terms of
excluding certain
individuals I from at a high level I I
don't see a major concern about that I
mean if if you plead Insanity to a
violent crime and that's how you believe
at the time your Council LED you to
believe that that was the right thing
and you're in the mental health um
Hospital in
conquered I'm not sure upon release you
get a chance to get that an old but
outside of that small narrow scope as I
said before most mentally ill patients
are not violent why are we giving Pro
and in some cases they may have been
depressed nailed it right she had a bad
experience had about an an episode of
depression of some sort and then that
triggered her inability to defend
herself this happens a lot more often
than we might think and I would ask that
you would pass this bill I will gladly
join if there's a subcommittee to work
on the language I don't know if this is
an early bill or not it's an FN so it
probably is um but no matter what I'm
willing to help Shepherd this through
because I think it matters we should not
require people to be criminals so they
can get and a record and old thank
representative before I Slaughter this
hereos
to
if you could just for the record state
your name since I was not able to do
that be awesome thank you I'm Cynthia
hospital and New Hampshire hospital
wanted to express and share some
information regarding the bill um just
concerns in terms of the vagueness of
the wording with regard to the analment
and how it might impact our medical
record and our ability to provide
continuity of care to patients ad to New
Hampshire hospital or committed to New
Hampshire hospital who may in Future
Days require another commitment because
of a relapse in their
condition um so
on
page one line 27 section 6A the person
whose record is anold shall be treated
in all respects as if he or she had
never been involuntarily committed um we
just would like to see some more clear
wording around that to help protect our
um medical records at New Hampshire
hospital so that we can continue to have
that information for people who've been
admitted to us in the
past and
then section six C court records and any
medical records relating to an anold and
voluntary commitment shall be sealed and
available only to the person whose
record was en olded his or her attorney
or his or her medical professional and
just um his or her medical professional
is is kind of a vague term as well we're
not quite sure what that means does that
mean the medical professional at the
hospital if you are um committed in in
the future to New Hampshire hospital
does that mean you're outpatient
provider um just some more clarity
terms thank
you
um if I may just add I have a pink slip
in too but I can just quick quickly spit
it out if you want um so the the impact
of the potential to have um that
language around um having to what is the
language the impact of
6A is that if if taken a total face
value we would not be able to use prior
medical records if the person needs to
come in for another commitment if the
patient needs to have a dangerousness
assessment if the person needs to have a
competency to stand trial assessment all
those records would be unavailable to
forensic assessors and essentially
really their ability to render a
um informed opinion to the court
regarding those types of questions so
that's that's a concern regarding um our
135c hold on one sec representative
Newman could you just remind us of your
you said you did turn in a pain card I I
did okay could you just remind us of
your name as we're just trying to get
I'm so sorry Jeffrey feder thank you
that's representative
Newman could you just comment on how we
how the wording might be changed what
you think about how it could be changed
to to address that where an En elment
means it's gone and you can't keep it
and there's no absolutely no record so
how can you have an adelement without
that I don't have language at the top of
you Dr Hannon still
Dean
thank you members of the committee I
mistakenly understood that this bill was
tied to um
1701 1711 I apologize it is not I'm very
much in support of it knowing that it's
a stand or believing that it's a
Standalone Bill if that makes sense so
yeah just so the card can be corrected I
don't want to thank you and I apologize
for making the mistake this bill is a
fabulous bill and it's too bad that one
of
the um sponsors couldn't hear me testify
because I think all of her concerns
would be elate and here is why there is
already massive Provisions in the
current annulment statute which is RSA
6515 that solves I believe all of her
concerns and specifically I would direct
you to but not limited to RSA 651 colon
5 Roman 3 sub number two sub the letter
B is in boy the letters H is in Harry
the letter H is ey is an ice cream and
specifically
6515 Roman 13
a through H is in Harry and 6515 Roman
14 there's many many many exceptions for
all sorts of violent crimes and rape and
robbery you know giant lists that I
won't read to you that cannot be en
olded this statute or this bill would
not change that but I would just ask you
briefly one thing because I know it's
the end of the day so I'm not going to
bird dog this one either but I'm going
to explain to you that if a person
commits a
crime and their iea I can get the record
of null and get the rights back but let
me tell you what some mean police
departments do they deliberately get
people iea and do not charge them with a
crime even though they can charge them
with several because they know they
won't be able to get their gun rights
back and I had a case years ago and I
called the chief and I begged him to
charge my client with something anything
he could even make it bad and he had a
whole list of crimes he could have
legitimately charged my client with he
says you want me to charge your client I
said' I do
please and he says why my mistake was
telling him why he's like absolutely not
it's a good thing to know and I'm sure
he passed the word along I thought by
being forthright and reasonable with him
that I would get a good response well
that didn't happen but here's the larger
issue we actually tried it I still told
the client I said listen you buying an
expensive lottery ticket we're going to
go to conquered District courts where it
at judge Bole and judge Bole said to me
bless his heart he said attorney Dean
can you show me any statute that gives
me authority to do this I said I can't
but it's plain all wrong and it should
be covered you know we we can find a way
and he was like yeah nice try and so my
point is that if you commit a crime any
crime be it large or small absent rape
robbery and a whole bunch of crimes you
can get your record anull and your gun
rights back but if you just have a
really bad day you can't and that's just
plain not fair so I respectfully say
this bill should be ought to pass and I
can answer questions and you say how can
this be that can't be right and the
answer is it's not right it's the way it
that thank you there any questions we're
much Paula
Mattis
I'd like to say good afternoon but I
think we are now in evening so I want to
thank yeah we you are you are you are so
um I do think this will be very brief um
I'm Paula Mattis I'm the director of
medical and forensic services for the
New Hampshire Department of Corrections
with me is Jane Grant she's our
strategic Communications administrator
we are representing the Department of
Corrections in opposition to HB
um I would like to I wish there weren't
speakers between us but I'd like to
piggy back on what New Hampshire
hospital said with regard to some of the
definitional matters pertaining to this
bill we too don't understand what is
meant by medical professional or who
selects the medical professional in some
of these uh Court proceedings the courts
um appoint people to make evaluations is
that that person's Medical Professional
I don't know by looking at this bill
another um definitional issue is um um
the the analment of is when we speak
about annulment we're talking about
getting rid of something completely but
it's unclear to us are we talking about
annulling court paperwork or we talking
about the attempt to in all medical
records which may be tied to those
proceedings um as someone who's worked
in behavioral health for a number of
years both at New Hampshire hospital and
now for the Department of Corrections I
can tell you these are very complex
processes there are a lot of things that
happen from the point of time whether
someone is being receiving an
involuntary commitment under RSA
135c or the ngri process which is
excluded from this bill and it's very
that is very clearly
stated um the other issue is is that
these processes are not pigeon hold
people can be over here over here
getting this H there can be multiple
things happening at once and all of
these require people to be making
decisions specifically with involuntary
commitments with the ngri process the
court and with incomplete
records as any of you know if you don't
have all the information it's really
hard to make a decision and this bill
though as well- intended as it appears
to be will result we believe in
confusion without cleaning up a lot of
the language without understanding the
processes under which these decisions
are made it is incredibly important for
those evaluating and treating people who
may need help in these situations to
have all the information at their
disposal to make those decisions a
additionally my fear our fear is that um
we for with an absence of Records or
records that may be spotty as a result
of the way this current legislation is
or proposed legislation is written um it
could have a detrimental impact on
future evaluations for anybody um um in
our system uh so it could result in
dangerous persons going free it could
result in people who need mental health
treatment not getting it or being
released um and um I would encourage the
committee to uh vote this in expedient
to legislate without much clarification
needed around how we're going to manage
medical records Healthcare records for
the population being
considered and that's the end of my
testimony and we are happy to take
questions if there are
any representative
jandan thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my question question uh I
I took some notes which is very unusual
for me but um it sounds to me like the
the hospital the state hospital the
psych secure psychiatric unit and
Department of
Corrections still want to have access to
the medical records for any involuntary
commitments is is that correct I can
speak for the New Hampshire Department
of Corrections under which the secure
psychiatric unit or spu is managed and
the answer is
yes New Hampshire hospital course
representative is under Department of
Health and Human Services and I believe
they've left thank
you representative Stone thank you madam
chair and thank you for taking my
question typically how long do you
retain records under your current
policies upon uh an individual leaving
your custody for our health care records
the Department of Corrections has a
7year window I want to be clear that
means that if someone were released from
our custody today we never saw them
again at the point of seven years from
today we would um uh uh destroy that
record we would shred it it's
confidential Health Care information we
would shred it but we have obviously
have people in our custody who have been
there for quite a while those records
are from start to finish you'll have we
we have people who are in our system 20
years we have a complete health record
for the care we've provided to them
followup followup so it's very common
practice to see an individual that may
be uh sporadic but over a longer span of
time such as the 20 years be a repeat
visitor it is not un commmon
representative thank you representative
Newman thank you madam chair and thank
you for taking my
question do you believe that that this
CH something like this to go would it
would it need a new definition or a
special definition of En helment to be
able to maybe carve out what you
um a special definition of En nment I
think uh that is in statute already and
I'm not an attorney I want to be very
clear about that so I think I'd want to
defer that uh answer to someone who has
more expertise and understanding in that
kind in that part of the New Hampshire
statute thank you thank you for your
questions
okay representative
Ms did someone else okay representative
Muse followed by representative Stone
thanks what what kind of problems do you
think it would create to not have access
to records like this for
you it would
be troubling from the perspective of not
knowing the kind of History so that we
can help people um both in the let me
say like this a lot of the folks that
come to us have long histories of either
mental illness arising from genetic
predispositions or from trauma without
having all the information so that we
can understand what is Baseline for them
I.E what is to be expected on a dayt day
or what has been helpful to them in the
past what hasn't been helpful to them in
the past that continuity of the record
is critical if you are in the position
of doing an
evaluation either for um something such
as competency which happens in our state
it makes for a better informed more
comprehensive evaluation if we know this
person if we have all the information
plus frankly from just a human
perspective making having people tell
their story over and over again is not
always helpful it's very frustrating to
people typically um it can it can not it
can trigger them it can cause some more
problems in terms of the immediacy of
that whereas a good evaluator a good
clinician can look at the records and
say this this go through it and
understand the person and pick up where
the last person left off so that
continuity is
critical thanks for helping me
understand I'm afraid that was a bit
wordy thank you for being that actually
is really helpful thank you thank you it
was very helpful thank you rep
representative Stone thank thank you
madam chair and once again thank you for
taking my question dealing with the
secured psychiatric you're dealing with
mostly uh individuals that are found
incompetent stand trial that's not
accurate all right could you give us a
definition of the actual individuals
that you house there the secure
psychiatric unit currently and I know
many of you are aware this is changing
in the future but currently serves many
Masters we are the inpatient psychiatric
um Hospital we're not a certified
hospital but that level of care for
those people who are our residents
people who are sentenced individuals to
the state facility we also serve that
function for the county houses of
Correction throughout the state we
currently do uh take the um take
transfers under current statute from New
Hampshire hospital for people they
determine are beyond their level of care
we also um take um from uh people as
necessary from the developmental
Services System who may need that level
of care uh that's a different state
statute there are five statutes that um
make Provisions for people to be sent to
us and the last is rare and it does
occur is um the sexually violent
Predator law uh 135e you can find the
references for that but those are in in
very general terms representative those
are the um five populations we serve at
the secure psychiatric unit thank you
very much for thear clarification thank
you for your
question any further questions we could
thank you very much for your testimony
time just for clarification uh Dr Korn
did
um my name is Andrea rice Hawkins I'm
the director of gunsense New Hampshire
project of gr State progress our
organization has weighed on state and
federal firearms policy since 2009 House
Bill 1701 seeks to establish a relief
from disabilities program for people
whose mental health treatment has ended
so they can restore their gun rights
while our organization supports that
intent we cannot support the process
outlined in this bill uh it is flawed
and it also does not meet the guidelines
by the US Department of Justice Bureau
of Alcohol Tobacco firearms and
explosives to fully provide
Relief by not meeting those standards an
individual who seeks and finds relief
under the process outlined in this bill
may still be unable to restore Firearms
rights at the federal level and worse
May mistakenly attempt to purchase a
firearm thinking they have satisfied the
requirements and thus subject themselves
to both legal and financial trouble
these are not new concerns our
organization has testified on versions
of this particular Bill since at least
2014 and there's a reason why for the
last decade this policy has not been
passed and conquered regardless of the
makeup of the state legislature or the
originating chamber instead we support
the process outlined in House Bill 1711
which meets the federal guidelines and
adequately restores Firearms rights for
granite Staters whose Mental Health
crisis has passed here are just a few of
the problems with House Bill 1701 it
erodes the quality of the relief from
disabilities program for people whose
mental health treatment has ended it
diminishes the state's ability to
determine when a person should get
relief and does not provide the court
with appropriate evidence to deter to
consider when making these
determinations section four reads when a
petition for enement is timely brought
the court shall require the New
Hampshire hospital or secure psychiatric
unit to report to the court concerning
any other recent commitments of the
petitioner and any other information
which the court believes May Aid in
making a det determination on the
petition no documentation is
specifically required in statute
regarding the initial commitment or
treatment including whether it is
ongoing complicating things section two
states a petition for annulment may be
made 5 Years From the date of the
commitment order not after it has ended
it also does not require that a mental
health provider assess the person's
mental health and suitability to possess
Firearms it does not specifically
require consideration of the person's
mental health history or the person's
reputation as developed through
character Witnesses or character
evidence House Bill 1701 Section 5
further reads the petition shall be
granted until upon a showing that there
have been no additional commitments
since the time of the commitment order
that the petitioner seeking to anull
I'll emphasize shall or unless the court
finds by clearing convincing evidence
that such an nment is not in the
interest of Justice discussing only
additional commit ments gives no regard
or conversation around ongoing mental
health treatment and
suitability what we should be looking
for is when someone has an absolute
discharge as is the standard established
in housef 1711 which you just heard
requiring the court to show by clear and
convincing evidence which is a higher
standard that the enement is not in the
interest of Justice puts the B burden on
the court without ensuring the proper
documentation and expert input to
certain that if treatment is ongoing
that's one thing but what if it is ended
in the absence of information here or it
is the absence of information here that
is worrisome the court cannot know what
it does not know about the suitability
of the petitioner which is why adequate
policies outline what must be considered
in a true relief from disability
program this bill would not meet the ATF
standards for relief from disability the
ATF Form States the state use uh the ATF
Form that a state uses to certify that
his established a qualifying mental
health relief from Firearms disabilities
program makes it clear that the
disabilities program must satisfy
certain minimum criteria I'm happy to
forward a copy to the committee of what
that form looks like it's two-page form
very clearly at the top it says these
minimum standards have to be met section
five of that application States proper
record in determining whether to Grant
relief the lawful Authority receives
evidence concerning and considers a
circumstances regarding the Firearms
disability imposed by 18 USC 922
G4 B the applicant's record which must
include at a minimum the applicant's
mental health and criminal history
records mental health records and
criminal history records and see the
applic applicant's reputation developed
at a minimum through character witness
statements testimony or other character
evidence these are the minimum standards
which other states with relief from
disability programs meet in order to not
endanger Public Safety or the safety of
the petitioner by inappropriately
granting relief too
soon we
support having a process and that's why
we support the process outline in House
Bill 1711 we have supported that process
for the last 10 years we're excited that
the committee is entertaining A bill
that would include that this process
before you actually jeopardizes rights
restoration and we would encourage the
committee to put your energy towards a
build that actually provides what you
seek to do happy to take any questions
thank
you representative celik thank you so
much um my question is merely functional
um I'm a bit too tired to have taken
notes on all of what you presented I was
hoping you could email us a copy I am
more than happy to email a copy um I'll
send a copy of the testimony along with
that relief from disability programs and
all the minimum requirements and you'll
have my contact information if you have
any questions definitely happy to talk
about it thank
much so everybody knows it is here we
are on our last
card attorney Ender Ender Andre if
there's anybody that has not turned in a
it please correct the last name as I am
aware that I did not do a very good job
hi everybody it's uh Steven andris I'm
from the maram county attorney's office
I'm an assistant County attorney I've
been a prosecutor for over 20 years I'm
sure you're all happy to hear from me
last on a Friday on a noon
bill um I I do the involuntary civil
commitments for our office under 135c
and I also do a lot of
Competency um evaluations and litigation
I have two real concerns with with the
language in this as proposed the first
is paragraph two which is line nine
where it talks about no petition shall
be brought until five years from the
date of the commitment order the
difficulty with that language is that
you can be committed to the state
hospital for a period of five years so
you can have your
hearing spend five years in the state
hospital and then get out after five
years and the day you exit the state
hospital you could then file for an
enement because it's 5 years after your
commitment um if the state hospital is
reporting on any subsequent commitments
there wouldn't be any subsequent
commitments because you literally would
have been committed three days
earlier um I would suggest to either
change that to a much larger time frame
after the date of commitment or to
change that from five years after the
date of perhaps absolute discharge from
the designated receiving
facility um which would be the date that
the New Hampshire hospital or whatever
the designated receiving facility
essentially closes your case the other
concern I have is um on the second page
those first three lines in paragraph C
of subsection six court records and any
medical records relating to the en old
inv voluntary commitment shall be sealed
the concern I have there is I understand
that this bill was was essentially
copied from the criminal statute and in
the criminal statute it makes sense to
seal court records because at this point
any one of us could walk into you know
maramont County Superior Court and say I
want to see State versus Jane Doe's file
and the clerk's going to hand it to you
and you can sit there and thumb through
it and look at all those records the
same is not true for New Hampshire
Hospital medical records are already
statutorily protected you can't just
walk up to New Hampshire hospital and
say I'd like to see Jane Do's file
obviously won't give it to you um
there's some exceptions to that but even
if you are the caregiver that lives with
Jane Doe when she's released New
Hampshire hospital isn't going to give
you her file without her consent except
under certain limited
circumstances my concern with sealing
the court records as people have alluded
to Prior is that we use those records to
help determine competency to help
determine um sanity if people are
raising sanity to help determine
dangerousness or mental illness if we're
pursuing involuntary civil commitments
and I'd hate to have a situation where
the office of the forensic examiner or a
doctor we hire in order to do um an
evaluation says I can't do a full
evaluation because there's there's um a
gap in medical records because they had
been sealed due to an enement um I happy
to answer any
questions
we saved you for last just for that
questions I appreciate
that it has it has been a very long day
uh it appears we do not have any
questions actually wait don't leave I do
you had mentioned I I was looking on
page two and I thought you had said line
nine but I didn't see anything there
about the the days you were talking
about yeah so the line nine is the first
page paragraph 2 first page line nine it
talks about five years from the date of
the commitment
order page one I'm sorry thank you yeah
and then page two is the ceiling of the
records that I don't like and how long
did you say so it where it says until
five years from the date what was your
recommendation I would I mean for me I
would probably either do that 10 years
from the date of the commitment order or
change it to 5 Years From the date of
absolute discharge from the designated
receiving facility which is where they'd
be committed to okay and I mean if
you're also interested in Crossing Out
Lines six and 7 it talks about
proceedings initiated pursuant to 13517
a there are no proceedings initiated
pursuant to 135 17A 1351 17A refers back
to 135c so it's impossible to actually
commit a person under 13517
a thank you very much that was
helpful still no questions we're good
all right thank you very much have a
good weekend thank you is that it y okay
seeing no further cards I am closing the
hearing on House Bill
1701 and we are we have um one two three
we have five bills do
however one of them we are going to just
open and go into a recess a
representative per has an amendment that
is not ready for us yet so we just need
to take a couple minutes here and decide
do you guys want to take 10 minutes get
drink the Dems are going to quickly
us across the hall uh for five
minutes okay so we are going to meet
back in here let's call it s minutes
give us five minutes to just chat real
quick we'll get back in here and we'll
knock these out
thank
you
e
all right guys listen up real fast
before I open any of these up I have two
amendments that we're going to pass out
I did not pass these out earlier just
because there were so many papers being
flying around I didn't want them to get
lost in the shuffle
um the first one is an amendment for the
for the cameras with the bridges Bill
and we'll discuss it whenever we get
there and the other amendment is for the
invasions of privacy again it's what we
discuss in committee with the
questioning so we'll discuss that
whenever we get to it so just so you
guys know what the both of the
amendments are before you leave
representative Roy has an amendment uh
we gave the amendment to his bill that
we heard earlier we passed that out but
he has another amendment here we're not
hearing this this bill right now but I
still want to give the amendment because
we have it but before you leave we'll
give you guys that one just so they
don't get lost okay everyone on the same
page with that okay so give
us representative n if you'll pass these
down that
side and representative you found that
yes the first one coming around
is uh for the for the
bridges and now this
one is the invasions of privacy one two
seven what what if you would pass those
down
you
okay
okay ladies and gentlemen um I'm going
to open you guys with me we ready I'm
going to open the executive session for
House Bill
1330 and we are going to go into recess
on House Bill
1330 the sponsor has an amendment for
that bill and ask that we wait until
next week but we did have it scheduled
for executive session so I just wanted
to try to follow the procedure as much
recess
we are going to open the executive
session for House Bill
1025 and I will recognize representative
Reed to make a
motion I motion to itl I'll second
that representative Reed would you like
to speak to your motion yes I would um
the house bill
1025 um is uh would make it um legal for
uh um someone to use um derogatory and
inflammatory words without um any kind
of consequences we uh found that in the
subcommittee this is would be very
incendiary causing um potential violence
and flare up of um the people being
screamed at so we decided we probably
should itl this thank you thank you
representative PR would you like to
speak to your second no I think she
nailed that quite well
thank
you I would agree I would just say that
we did have a uh a subcommittee on this
and the the sponsor um was not able to
make it and didn't indicate if he was
not going to make it and uh we had the
the two of the Democrats that were on
the subcommittee didn't show up that day
either so representative Reed and I
spoke uh with representative gathright
and we made a recommendation of of itl
without an official vote does any any
body else like would anybody else like
to speak on House Bill 1025
representative janen thank you madam
chair I I just want to mention that um
part of my district is actually Hampton
which includes Hampton Beach and if we
were to passed this bill uh it would
have a crippling effect on the ability
of the H Hampton Police and State Police
and the Rockingham County Sheriff to
inforce uh good order on Hampton Beach
uh which is at family beach so I I also
supporting the
itl thank you anybody else like to
speak all right at this time the clerk
will call the role the motion on the
rhods oh I so that that's okay so um I'm
actually going to go last so start with
the next one
down representative Pratt
yes uh representative scitec yes
representative PR yes representative
janen yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar
yes um representative
Muse yes representative Balden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes
um the clerk votes yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler
hi missing some people so oh in the
chair
yes oh representative wait hold on
representative soon Newman I apologize I
didn't I didn't we're getting there
okay what do I do do so she is here
for is she here well she's sitting in my
SE because I'm over here so yeah but who
but who's missing from you guys
today for
who okay so when you normally when you
would call Alexandra
Murray you going to she is yeah so
instead of calling her name uh where she
you're just going to go like this and
then you write sh
her representative Su
Newman
thank
you
okay 17 yes the vote is 17 yes motion
passes any objection to
consent okay I am closing the hearing or
the executive session on house B
1025 and I am opening the executive
session for House Bill 1260
and I recognize myself to make a motion
of ought to
pass second seconded by representative
Murphy and I also would like to
introduce Amendment or offer
Amendment what am I
d419 and I will just speak to my
Amendment briefly if you all remember we
held the
the hearing on this bill and it was uh
the invasions of privacy if the person
was a minor that the Privacy had been
invaded and one of the things that I
would like to to correct a little bit
was representative Muse had asked me a
question when I was presenting the bill
and he had asked if this essentially was
an increased penalty and I answered yes
because it is however what I didn't
stress enough with that was the way the
bill was written at the time did not
offer any kind
of any kind of I should say wrong and
that's not really the right word right
now if the person that was being invaded
was a child and the bill originally was
looking to make that be you know a
little bit more egregious so yes it does
offer an increased penalty however
children were not recognized in the
first place so now they're going to be
the amendment that we're
offering will essentially if it is a
repeat offender
if it's a child so initially it will be
a a f a class B felony but if it is a
repeat offender for the invasion of
privacy for a minor it will be a class a
felony which is basically the the
questions that we had uh during the the
hearing additionally I just wanted to
mention there were some questions around
the sex offender list that had been
discussed I actually did go through with
an amendment for that as well
and upon further consideration we
realized it really just was not the bill
to put it on and we thought that that
would do better to just be a whole
separate bill alog together and we will
explore that at a later time but not
with this particular bill um with that I
would ask or take any questions if
there's any on
that representative selig may I second
your
Amendment oh it was already seconded by
representative Murphy okay I didn't hear
that sorry that's okay just want to make
sure
representative
bden on the topic of the prior vote are
there not 18 people in the room
currently did the clerk count her own
vote uh can we can we ask that after
we're done talking about this bill we'll
it we are we are missing I think two
people but yeah just so we don't get
at
representative Willer did you have a
question did you have a statement no
okay everybody go on the
amendment okay so at this time the clerk
will call the role this is on the
amendment for House Bill
1260 representative Pratt I
representative scitec yes representative
PR yay representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
Muse yes representative Balden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray
Newman yes representative Sue Newman
yes uh the clerk votes yes
representative zelig yes representative
wheeler yay
and the chair
18 Amendment passes the amendment passes
18 to zero and now the motion is ought
to pass as amended for House Bill 1260
the clerk will call the
second
need second for that motion you seconded
it huh she
seconded representative M will you make
you representative Pratt yes
representative scitec we representative
PR yes representative janen yes
representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes representative Su Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
selig yes representative wheeler y yay
vote sorry you voted twice Madam
chair
yes thanks for bearing with me all okay
we we got this so um while I believe
there was a point of order and I I
should have I should have addressed that
right away but we were in the middle of
another bill and I didn't want to get
confused so representative uh brought up
that she thinks the count was was off on
our first bill which was
1025 and the clerk will just let us know
where we're at with that you are correct
so the vote for House Bill 1025 is 18 to
zero and we are 180 on the amendment for
1260 and 18 to Z
on on ought to pass as
amended
consent I did on the first one um 1260
will also go on the consent calendar
anybody opposed to
that awesome
okay I will close the public executive
1260 and I will open the executive
session for House Bill
1448 and recognize representative Stone
to make a mo
motion thank you madam chair I'd like to
make a motion on HB 1448 to
itl thank you is there a second sure
I'll second that rep representative SEL
like had her hand up
or it's somebody else wants to go I know
representative Stone would you like to
speak to your motion I would briefly I
like to say that uh this bill has some
good points unfortunately we didn't get
an amendment on it and I know the
discussion of the time frames was also
uh reported by the department of safety
and hopefully uh the sponsor will uh
take care of that for next
session thank you representative C would
agree thank you representative s does
anybody have any any comments
on representative Willer thank you madam
chair I I would just like to Echo what
representative Stone said and say that
if the sponsor is going to bring forward
a bill and be off offered the exact
language for the amendment that he needs
to fix it I think it'd be prudent for
that sponsor to address that and change
it and otherwise we're going to have to
itl it and that's what we'll do thank
you representative wheeler
representative scitec we could have
too he said we could have interim
studied it as
well I would just like to say that
during the the testimony I was a little
bit concerned
to think
that there's possibly something that is
sitting there that would prove
somebody's innocence or guilt and that
it may be done away with um for various
of reasons and I actually would like to
have seen an amendment as well and one
of the things that I really would like
the members of our entire body to
understand is just with a lot of other
committees we hear a lot of bills and we
do our best to give every single one to
doe process and and and do everything we
can to either kill it or to pass it and
you know really just isn't something
that we're able to take on to amend
every bill that possibly could need
amended representative janen thank you
madam chair I I agree it is not the job
of this committee to introduce uh
amendments for a a CO a prime sponsor
that said he would come with one uh I
would like to mention that procedurally
the the prime sponsor of this bill could
still uh come to the house floor with
his Amendment amend the bill overturn
our itl and pass the bill um and if you
were to do so I would support his
effort thank you representative janver
anybody else like to speak on where we
at 1448 right at this time the clerk
will call the role the motion is itl on
1448 representative Pratt yes to the itl
representative scitec yes representative
PR yes please representative janen yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
Muse yes representative Balden
yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Ray Newman yes representative Su Newman
yes the clerk votes yes repres
resentative cig yes representative
wheeler
18 motion passes 18 to
zero we are closing the executive
session on House Bill what was that
1448 and I will open the executive
session on House Bill
1217 and I recog recognize myself to
make a motion of ought to
pass seconded by representative wheeler
I offer amendment to House Bill 1217 the
amendment number is
0233 h i second your your Amendment
there's a second representative jenan
seconds the
amendment um if I may briefly I'll just
speak to the
amendment again during the the public
hearing it seemed like that we had um
pretty much support from the committee
on the bill uh basically what we're
trying to say is that the covered
bridges are pretty much his historical
markers they are used for um great
tourist
attractions so so many things all the
way around when these bridges are
destroyed or damaged if there's any kind
of recklessness involved there's a great
amount of Commerce that is lost to the
town and there is nothing that the that
the town can do to even try to recoup
any of the the Lost damages there uh
what this amendment will do that
representative Jan had brought up was
actually just put a sign in front of the
bridge within 100 ft to let the
pedestrians or I'm sorry to let the um
the drivers know that that they very
well could be being recorded um the one
thing I would like to address as far as
privacy I know that that comes up a lot
as far as a public
road I really can't think of anything
that's more public than a than a public
Highway um and the other thing that this
amendment does is because so many so
many of the roads are actually
state-owned leading to these covered
bridges this is actually going to put
that cost onto the state and they will
have to be the ones to put up the
sign representative jener would you like
to speak to that yes as a young man I I
served in the New Hampshire Conservation
Corps in Cornish New Hampshire and uh
Cornish is known for as Cornish Windsor
bridge and I remember that particular
summer it was struck by a truck they
never found out who it was it took them
seven years to raise the funding to fix
it and there was an argument is Vermont
responsible or is New Hampshire So to
avoid that I think that it's it's good
to have this bill um but the the
amendment the reason for the amendment
is I was here when this the house the
Senate and the the people of the state
passed Amendment to be which is the
right of privacy and if you're going to
a business here in New Hampshire and
you're under video surveillance they
have to give you notice so I think that
this amendment accomplishes giving
notice and somebody asked me about the
100 foot why would why would you say 100
feet here's why if I want to go and take
a picture of a historic bridge I don't
want a picture of that sign 100 feet
away gives me room to get that picture
without getting the sign in it so that I
I fully support the
amendment that was actually a great
definition I'm glad that you that you
gave us all that Insight I didn't even
think of that uh does anybody else would
any of else like to
speak representative
wheeler do you have something you'd like
class Madam
chair that is not ask mad chair but I do
I mean if you're going to put me on the
hot seat I do just want to say that
these bridges are such an important
piece to New England's hist hist and
when people think of New England they
think of these hidden Bridges these
covered bridges that picture of you know
the orange leaves with the nice bridge
over it and the idea that people would
posit that they have the Privacy to
vandalize these Bridges is absurd so I
like what you said uh the priv no one
has the Privacy to be on a public road
and vandalize it and uh especially when
it comes to our cover Bridges which are
integral to the economy of our state and
the tourism of it I think if we're going
to have cameras and thank God we do then
we should use them to protect those
bridges so that's what I was thank you
thank you representative Willer you may
need to say that on the house floor
um does any would any would
anybody representative
Newman I have nothing to add and I
apologize to the
committee oh does anybody else have
anything that they would like to add no
at this time the clerk will call the
role the motion is ought to pass for
d233 representative Pratt yes
representative scitec yes representative
PR yes representative Janan yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed yes representative Stone yes
representative tenar yes representative
Muse yes representative Balden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative
Murphy representative Ray
Newman representative Su
Newman the clerk votes yes
representative
celik representative
wheeler Madame chair
yes and the vote is 18 for the
amendment the most now on the on the
committee is ought to pass as
amended do we do we have I'm sorry guys
help me out do I have to do a whole
another motion again okay I make a
motion to pass as
amended the bill as second seconded by
representative
janen any any further
discussion no the clerk will call the
role we are voting ought to pass as
amended House Bill
representative Pratt yes representative
scitec which is Polish yes
representative PR yes representative
Janan yeah which is
German representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenar yes
representative Muse yes representative
Balden yes representative Bradley
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Ray Newman yes
representative Su Newman yes clerk votes
yes representative Cel yes
representative wheeler yay Madame
chairwoman the chair votes
yes
180 motion passes 18 to nothing with
that I will close the executive session
1217 18 to nothing is that we all okay
with the consent
calendar I will close the executive
session for houseb 1217 and Madam chair
I'm just wondering if we did consent on
the previous Bill we did that all of
these bills are on the consent calendar
unless anybody has a issue with that
okay um with that our business for the
day is done I would like to just take a
minute and thank uh representative n she
yeah it was not an easy day at all uh
Brad back there held it together with
our amendments um and thank you guys all
very much we we just pounded out another
I don't know how many bills on the on
the consent calendar a little bit of
little bit unheard of so um with that
have a great weekend everybody we'll see
week
that